e
e e
all right I'm going to uh call the house
Judiciary Committee to order and I
[Music]
recognize I I recognize representative
Perez to lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance I PL aliance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible liy and justice
for
all my the last play
ball of
course all right all right I'm I'm going
to open the hearing on House Bill uh
199 oh okay all right oh great okay um
it's uh extending the statute of
limitations on civil actions relative to
damages caused by
pfas I'm not going to try to pronounce
the whole thing
ffas um and I would um recognize uh
representative Wendy Thomas
co-sponsor Suzanne Vale oh the prime
sponsor I'm sorry okay yes I I'm sorry I
recognize uh representative Vil is that
correct yeah sorry sorry about
that good
morning oh it is the right one I'm sorry
good morning chairman Lynn and The
Honorable members of the House Judiciary
Committee I am representative Suzanne
Vale representing Hillsboro County 6
Nashua W 3 presenting House Bill 99
199 19 uh H HB 199 extends the statute
of limitations of Civil actions related
to damage caused by peroral alcohol and
polyal alcohol substances also known as
pasas
chemicals and this would change the
statute of limitations from 6 years to
20 years and I have
some background on what we would be
working on during that time HB 199 is
still seeking to discover new forms of
harm as one of the worst environmental
disaster continues to unfold in Southern
New Hampshire and specifically in
miramac the bill addresses the
difficulty of the six-year limit for
calculating
damages and those damages are
remediation medical monitoring and
property loss related to past
contamination stco Baine reported that
they had been leeching P pfoa into the
water supply to New Hampshire Dees and
that was in
2016 and since that time the New
Hampshire house has been engaged in past
investigations that have spanned several
committees involved many communities in
public water supplies and private Wells
we struggled to reach everyone who needs
to know that the water is potentially
contaminated and is contaminated in the
case of St gobain the clock may have run
out with the six-year statute on many
potential
plaintiffs um as an overview the effects
of past on the health and environment
pfast chemicals are bioc cumulative and
they are environmentally persistent
that's why they are called Forever chem
chemicals they are used in products such
as non-stick Coatings like Teflon pans
waterproof Fabrics like
gortex uh firefighting home foam
carpeting food packaging and more these
chemicals easily enter the soil they do
not dissolve and are often as I said
called Forever chemicals for that reason
longitudinal studies implicate past in a
multipe of disorders including fetal
development issues development and
endocrine disorders cancer kidney
disease high cholesterol and
tumors concentration in breast milk
impacting nursing mothers the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services in collaboration with Dartmouth
medical school is studying Regional
clusters of disorders to Monitor and
test exposed
victims in regards to contamination in
New Hampshire the contamination
originates in Southern New Hampshire
from the St gobain performance plastic
plant and originally reported in
2016 the contamination Zone around this
plant impacts May ma Lichfield lader
Amherst and other towns additional past
contamination sources include the kley
landfill in Northampton and Greenland
and a super fund project which is
leading leeching pfast chemicals and
there is another manufacturer in amher
that used app past and different
applications than the coated Fabrics San
has provided bottled water to some
residents since the contamination was
revealed but the recycling of those
bottles becomes a burden on the
municipality and the towns must decide
what to do with all of that plastic City
towns and taxpayers bear significant
costs for remediation Health
complications and property losses the
challenges with past
manufacturing um that we
face in our locality is that s gobain
delayed and installing filtration
systems which increased
exposure they had difficulty keeping up
with the kind of filtration that is
needed in order to reduce the amount of
particles to our parts per
trillion many residents are still
unaware that there is a
problem despite many efforts um both in
the legislature and in the state
departments to notify and help people
find the resources they
need P I think the global issue is that
past producers have influenced and
delayed EPA regulations for decades
allowing continued past production and
continued widespread contamination when
we knew very well that there were
physical consequences for working in the
factory and using the firefighting phone
so why extend the statute of limitations
to calculate the scope of harm
especially for vulnerable groups such as
children elderly pregnant women and
nursing mothers to identify victims and
assess the full extent of the problem
Statewide to protect municipalities from
bearing disproportionate costs and to
Define Camin contamination zones based
on Wells meeting maximum contaminant
levels or less and to provide education
to Citizens and medical providers for
harm reduction and care of value
valuation given the latency of illness
onset and the complexity of past
contamination extending the statute of
limitation to 20 years is
vital so what I did was I sent you
around a handout that says in New
Hampshire the 20year statute of
limitations for certain legal actions is
designed to serve several important
purposes instead of reading you that
entire document um if you just let me
know if it would be better but the key
benefits of a
20-year um is Preservation of legal
rights in real estate disputes such as a
boundary issue or an adverse possession
claim of property it may take years for
the individual to even realize their
legal rights have been
infringed um and the 20e um statute of
limitations encouragement of fair
resolutions some legal disputes take
time to surface and it ensures that
injured parties have a fair chance to
seek
Justice um the protection of public
interest certain cases have long-term
implications for public trust and
economic stability a 20-year limit
allows for thorough investigation and
action to protect Public
Welfare um and the deterrence against
wrongdoing which you know right now
we're saying you can come to New
Hampshire and you
can set up a business that over time
begins to contaminate an area and 3 to
six years later you know you don't have
to worry about what happens over the
next 20 years and you also don't have to
worry about um forever chemicals having
a
forever um statute of
limitations so the bill came through to
this committee as 1089
um and it was built on a bill House Bill
236 which was passed in
2021 and that bill was the one that
extended the statute of limitations from
3 to six years so at this point in time
that is proved to be too short of a
period of time and people believe that
having more time and having 20 years is
a step in the right
direction um the complexity of certain
cases such as those that are in inv
involve environmental law property law
um complex Finance Financial
transactions and um comprehensive
Medical Care um a longer statute allows
for proper fact finding and it also
allows for a date of finality for the
person who's seeking remedy and for the
company who is is settling
so we came up with the 20year statute of
limitations because this committee
during the hearing on the second bill
which was to open up the statute of
limitations entirely there was strong
testimony um in favor of the type of
statute of limitations that would be
applicable and there I'm sorry I don't
remember the gentleman's name but he was
an attorney from DC who came to tell us
about what kind of problems we would
have with an open-ended statute of
limitations so I think what I should do
at this point is leave you with
testimony and then take your questions
um I also circulated a testimony from
the honorable James McConnell who served
in the legislature from 2014 to 2018 he
is is a strong advocate for this bill he
would prefer however that instead of
extending the statute of limitations to
20 years that we remove it all together
but we did in the interim
study spend a a good amount of time and
I believe there was a thorough
discussion and it was clear to me that
this committee would not back a
um a open-ended statute of limitation
ations and this committee did vote in
favor of having
legislation but
not as a result of the committee
believing that this was a good bill it
was time to open up the conversation and
the committee would welcome another bill
with what I came to understand um and
with that I'll conclude my testimony I
believe there's people that have a lot
of information behind me thank you very
much questions for this witness yes
representative
know thank you and this is purely
housekeeping but you read some extensive
testimony there are you going to submit
that to the committee for the
clerk's um yes I can do that I'll send
it by email if that's okay I would
really appreciate that thank you other
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
I'm now going to call on representative
Wendy Thomas co-sponsor
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Wendy Thomas and I represent the
contaminated town of
marac uh past forever chemicals have
great health impacts we know this the
EPA has been reporting on it they have
carcinogenic uh properties they are
hormone disruptors and they have great
imp impact to General Health I want to
give you some examples of why this bill
would be
necessary there was a study done in
Italy in a contaminated Town similar to
the town of marac with the same uh
levels of past
contamination where pregnant women were
drinking the water uh during their
pregnancy there was a higher rate of
learning disabilities of the babies that
were born to those women since then we
have confirmed that pasas in Ed during
pregnancy results in some babies having
uh uh learning disabilities I just went
to a school board meeting in marac last
night 20% of our kids have learning
disabilities the CDC recommends that 20
points uh 20 parts per trillion is what
sets off screening uh screening
protocols uh if a mother ingests that
past uh contaminated water at the levels
that we have in our town and in this
town in Italy um the babies can can test
at 20 parts per trillion if they test at
20 parts per trillion that means they
start screening which means you start
screening babies for high cholesterol at
age one now how many people know that
even in our town I talk to people all
the time who who think that the water
problem is fixed um and that they don't
have to worry about pasas in the water
and or environment
anymore I mentioned that uh pasas is a
hormone
disruptor anyone who has teenagers knows
the power of
hormones what we're finding is that
children ex that who are constantly
exposed to to past contaminated water
again at the levels we're seeing in
marac have a greater rate of
infertility that's not something you
discover until you've gone through
puberty and you've actually tried to
become pregnant or to to to be involved
in a pregnancy um if you're a boy um
we're also finding young boys uh who
have prostate cancer um and so that's
one of the recommendations to start
screening 12 and 13y old boys for
prostate cancer um that's that's just
unheard of prostate as we know is
something that that typically hits older
men um I'm going to use my family as an
example we have a contaminated well that
is so contaminated it was shut down in
2018 uh we've been on bottled water for
the last six years that means that every
drop of water that I have had to drink
in the last six years has come from a
bottle every ounce of water that I use
to cook comes from a bottle we can't
sell our home my kids have moved out
they're adults who's going to buy a home
that doesn't come with
water um my kids are now adults they've
been exposed to this wellwater their
entire lives all of them have autoimmune
diseases all of them have P related
symptoms these are things that they're
just finding out now and they were
exposed when they were
kids many of you know um my personal
story I have a cancer that is considered
to be PE related it's a slow growing
cancer grade one which means that it
takes many years to develop I was lucky
it was identified it's been removed I
seem to be good right now however every
oncologist that I have spoken to has
said it's not if the cancer returns it's
when the cancer returns because I have
such high levels of past in my blood I
had my blood tested and I have 12 past
chemical that are over the toxic limit
that's allowed for humans in my
blood so you know they talk about
ticking time bombs my cancer could come
back tomorrow it could come back in six
years it could come
back in 20
years pasas is a man-made chemical it's
not something that is found in nature
and because of the carbon Florine bond
which which is uh identify it identifies
the chemical it's it's one of the
strongest bonds we have on the planet
Earth and it's very difficult to break
which is why these chemicals are called
Forever chemicals in our town ST gobain
which has abandoned their their facility
leaving us with this highly contaminated
building on this highly contaminated
piece of property has said it is too
difficult to clean up these chemicals
and so their plan is to let them just
naturally degrade but remember that
carbon Florine bond is impossible to
break which is why these are called
Forever chemicals so these chemicals put
there by this company are going to
impact our town
forever 20 years is not outrageous to
move for the statute of limitations
we're not talking about a car accident
where you've broken a bone and 20 years
later you say this impacts my life we
are talking about chemicals that were
man-made that were put into our
environment that impacted innocent
people that have created Health havocs
in our town and in Southern New
Hampshire um by a company and I it is
not unreasonable in fact it is wise and
prudent to extend the statute of of
limitations to 20 years I'd be happy to
take any questions questions for this
witness seeing yes representative trip
thank you for taking my question
uh you said that you've been drinking
bottled water since
2018 uh no just the last well 2019 yeah
it's when when they started supplying us
this is what the uh the town of marac
considers to be a long-term
solution this is what s go Bain
considers a stop Gap solution it is not
it is not the town of Marx's decision s
ban offered this we have 700 families
receiving bottled water right now over
700 families on private Wells that are
receiving bottled
water follow up yes follow up please the
uh
so you said it's a stop Gap solution has
the
uh do you think 20 years is long enough
for marac to determine that they uh want
uh St Cobain to pay to install water
lines so on my street um and they have
been saying for many years um that they
were going to hook us up to public water
um and last fall they they put the pipes
in our street but they um so we're
planned this this I believe this spring
to to be hooked up to public water the
problem with public water is that it is
filtered at the treatment plant however
it then goes through contaminated pipes
to get to our house so even if I'm
hooked up to public water it's still not
considered well I don't think it's
considered safe because there is no safe
uh level of
PS thank you representative Perez thank
you thanks for taking my question I'm
from London da you're preaching to the
choir um I
have we
have hundreds of people in londondary
who took advantage of getting the
filtration system in
was your is there was your P level not
high enough to qualify for that or did
you just choose not to do
that thank you for the question
um when I joined the citizens Action
Group in March that was um organized
around pest at first you know we didn't
really have we didn't have any science
at the time we just knew many of us had
a medical science background we knew
that these were hormone disrupting
chemicals and curs enic so um the state
told us there there's a boundary around
s gobain initially the state told us
that if you lived half a mile from s
Cain you didn't have to be worried about
it they then updated it and they said
okay our bad if you live a mile from St
Cain um more than a mile you don't have
to worry about it um my family lives
three miles from St
Cain I mentioned I have six children I
don't know if I give you the number but
I had uh six young children at the time
um so I had our private well tested
independently and it came back so high
that we couldn't use it
anymore what my husband and I did is we
installed a whole house filtration
system which is what I think you're
talking about at the time it was $3,500
to install that we also put in a a
reverse osmosis uh for point of of use
um for the water and that is the only
water that I would allow us to use
unfortunately it didn't occur to me and
and and I sleep with this guilt every
single night not to give our dogs
filtered water um I've had four dogs die
of cancer um and lots of the dogs and
cats in marac are dying of cancer which
is one of the things that I Bang the
Drum about you know give them filtered
water give them bottled water they are
the canaries and the coal mine um so we
paid for the filtration however there
are 14,000 chemicals uh in the p uh
category um and we can't test for them
all St gobain won't give us a complete
list because they say it's proprietary
so even though we have filtration we
don't know if it's
safe other questions for this witness
yes representative M thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
could you be very specific about the
problems with the six-year statute of
limitations
um I think that the examples that I gave
um just clearly indicate why you need
longer than six years um a baby who is
born with a past learning disability
typically learning disabilities aren't
discovered until they start school which
is like age 56 so you know then you have
testing and everything and it's
difficult to to connect it back to the
original
P it's difficult to do that anyway um in
my personal case with my um cancer you
know I have a diagnosis date for my
cancer which is almost three years ago
um so so let's say that that I I file
for damages and I I get that covered
what happens you know 5 years from now
when I get another cancer that's pasas
related because of the the p in my blood
is that is that a new injury is that a
continued injury um there are so many
questions about how
P um impacts human health that that I
I'm actually on team forever for that
removing any statute of limitations but
I think 20 years is prudent and wise
other qu representative P pel thank you
um could you tell me how you
differentiate between an illness that's
been caused by pasas versus some other
um
mechanism because we are con surrounded
by chemicals everywhere so I'm really
con I mean is it just based on symptoms
or is it just because you have high
levels of pasas I I mean because 20
years is a really long time for anything
to occur in anybody right and I I think
the the necessity for 20 years is that
this is measured in such small amounts
parts per trillion and we don't know
what the Tipping Point is for exposure
we don't know if it's one a onetime
exposure we don't know if it's a chronic
exposure we don't know how long um with
regard to identifying P related
illnesses what we have right now is a
list from the CDC of confirmed symptoms
which doesn't include my cancer um but
but it is um symptoms along with with uh
diagnostic blood work that shows that P
is in your your body that's that's all
we have right now which is which is
actually insufficient which is why we
need a Time extension because new
information is coming out every
day yeah yeah follow oh I'm
sorry I like to do that too when I'm
there um have you are you familiar with
the term um correlation is not
causality yes yes um however um there I
live in a town where we have incredibly
High rates of of cancer as I mentioned
we've got cats and dogs that are dying
all the time um it's not too difficult
in my town to connect the dots other
question yes representative rmo uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um just to clarify in terms of
this actual statute of limitations
meaning that am I correct understanding
that you'd have 20 years to bring action
does not change the standard of what
evidence have to provide or how you'd
have to prove your claim in terms of a
connection which could be a long time
and obviously there could be a lot of
intervening factors but it would just
preserve the right to bring the action
within that 20 year window
correct other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you whoops I'm sorry
representative
Bon thank you for taking my question
sure I just wanted to know do you feel
it's important right now for our younger
folks to be introduced to the issues or
just p in general just seeing as you've
been exposed to a lot of different
organizations oh my God that's like what
I do oh I mean i' I've been working with
Dartmouth Hitchcock on um educational
material for the general public as well
as for Physicians um The Physician who
did I've had um three very extensive
surgeries for uh cancer The Physician
that did my first operation when I
showed her the blood work results that
that show showed that I had 12 past
chemicals over the toxic limit she
literally didn't look at it she pushed
it back and she said I'm just a surgeon
I don't need to know about past and I
got up and I walked out of the room and
I said you are no longer my surgeon um
and so you know it's it's it's things
like that there
are there are three of us in March that
were that were identified as water
Warriors and this is what we have we
have devoted Our Lives to I mean I I
hold um workshops all the time on the
dangers of PS I I
join protests I organize you know events
I Bang the Drum all the freaking
time so at this point there's not like
an official program so like either you
know school kids or like no no there
isn't but there should be all right and
I would support a bill if you put one in
all right thank any other questions for
this witness another housekeeping issue
do you you read some testimony do you
have that to submit to the
committee yes oh got it thank you all
right any other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
ma'am next I'm G to call on Mike whims
please good morning Mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Mike wison sat I serve as director of
the waste management division for the
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services uh the agency is
not taking a position on this bill but
we did want to come before the committee
today to acknowledge that this is past
contamination is something that we've
been working very very hard on for more
than 10 for 10 years now and um we first
discovered some significant releases
from a couple of facilities in Southern
New Hampshire uh back in
2016 and since that time we've uh
embarked on uh expansive sampling
efforts and we've been able to determine
that there are literally thousands of
drinking water wells both private
drinking water wells and a number of
public Supply Wells that have been
impacted uh by past contamination at
levels above the standards that have
been set and so we've worked very hard
to um make sure that folks get access to
clean water in in the wake of that and
uh really just wanted to acknowledge
that uh you know there are as as you've
heard in testimony a number of concerns
about potential health effects
associated with past contamination and
so um this is something that we we've
worked on very hard we continue to work
every day there are a number of people
at Dees that devote much of their work
to um evaluating sites that have past
contamination and trying to ensure that
people aren't getting exposed to these
contaminants and I'll I'll leave it at
that and be happy to answer any
questions questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you I that's the last of the
pink cards I have on House Bill 199 is
there what I'm sorry
oh I'm sorry Mr
Grace sorry about that sorry Mr chair I
know my handwriting is awful didn't see
it I I'm sorry n GRA with the uh
business and industry Association uh we
oppose this legislation um and the
reason for our uh opposition here is
really in lines uh 6 through 8 in the
section of the statute that is not
modified uh which says after the date
the plaintiff discovers or in the
exercise of reasonable diligence should
have discovered the harm and the Casual
relationship uh to the harm causal
relationship causal relationship sorry
um uh So currently we have six years
after those two components
are um met to bring that lawsuit
um we don't think it's necessary to
extend that to 20 years and the reason
for that really goes back to the reason
for the statute of limitations in the
first place um which is that evidence
becomes stale after time um memories
fade documents are lost um you lose the
ability to uh make that uh that
effective argument there's a
relationship between the harm and the
cause um and that's my third Point here
here um is that there are other
intervening uncertainties so the closer
in time you can have that lawsuit um the
clearer it is the connection uh you know
if you have an an injury with
intervenient events that may also cause
that same kind of injury uh the facts
are going to get blurred by those
intervening issues so as an example that
I'm completely making up because I have
no idea if there's a relationship here
you know if if scientists say you know P
causes lung cancer
uh and then someone develops lung cancer
but they also uh start smoking after the
after that point in time when they have
that exposure you know if you have 20
years it's going to be very hard for the
FactFinder the court system uh and the
jury to determine you know what portion
of that is due to the exposure to uh
tobacco which is well established as a
cause of lung cancer and versus the
pasas um so you know
once it it is it just seems more
reasonable from our perspective to uh
keep this uh statute limitations short
um and I would already I would point out
that it is already twice as long as the
standard civil statute limitations happy
to take any questions and yes
representative
Smith thank you very much Mr chair and
um
are are is the business and industry
Association saying that they have no
confidence in the judicial system in
this country in which a judge and a jury
would weigh facts and make
determinations as to what is reasonable
and therefore we have to protect people
from um participating in the judicial
system absolutely not representative
Smith uh we would never suggest that we
have no confidence in the judicial
system it's a very robust system we have
all the confidence in the world in it uh
what I would offer is that I think it
would be easier for the judicial system
and we would have a more accurate uh
assessment of the of the harm uh based
on the existing statute limitations
rather than than one uh an additional 14
years down the line um after the injury
has occurred and the relationship thank
you and I'll only do one followup Mr
chair although I might be tempted to do
a dozen or two dozen um are are you
saying then that if
reality
unfolds and new information is available
including ining new information as to
how these forever chemicals are
affecting the citizens of this state and
this country that too bad we only should
have a very limited period of time um in
order for
justice to be
protected representative Smith I'd go
back to lines 6 through 8 here um and
just point out that it's there's a
two-part test it's after the harm is
discovered and also the relationship
between in this case the exposure to p
and uh and the the harm so that's when
the statute takes place um or begins
begins that that process of running Mr
chair I'm going to honor my um statement
that I won't ask any questions I just
don't want anybody to think that that's
because I'm comfortable with the
response representative
CH yeah thank thanks and thanks for
taking the question um building on on uh
question that representative Pell asked
of the last witness um the statement
cause uh caus uh correlation does not
equal causation um worked enough with
numbers through my life that I
understand the concept there you seem to
be suggesting that with time the the
ability to
prove and and build on a case that would
require you to show causality
essentially gets weaker um from what I
believe the previous Witnesses have said
it sounds like the statistics the
numbers needed in order to go from
simple correlation to what would
approximate you know scientific
causality to the extent that that can be
known grows over time because we are
accumulating knowledge um not just of
the magnitude of the problem but also
the dimensions of the problem so I'm
wondering if you can see that both
things can be true yes we getting
further away from the cause but this is
not like you know a car accident where
something happened um and then as time
Fades the the memory of that this I
believe Falls more into the category of
where we know that the harm may be
ongoing and our knowledge is only
growing so could you respond to the
difference between sort of your
assertion that you know the case grows
weaker over time you as opposed to being
able to get to the point where you might
be able to prove your
issue sure happy to do so um and I I I
would point out that I think this is why
the legislature uh struck a balance and
picked six years uh back in 2021
extending the timeline past three years
because legislature recognized that
there was a lot of research going into
this area um discovering of this causal
causal relationship um and also uh you
know we were seeing uh you know we knew
harms existed and we were we were being
able to associate them with a cause
um I think the what I would in response
to what you're saying um I I would PR
out kind of the other un my bucket of
other uncertainties and just for the
clerk's knowledge I'm more than happy to
write up a a quick summary of my
testimony today and send that to you um
the you know so if you you have an event
uh or a series of events that you know
causes a a specific harm uh you know
someone is in the military they're
exposed to burn pits for example uh
causes lung cancer uh and then a variety
of other things and then they leave the
military they start smoking they smoke a
pack a day um they develop cancer eight
years in it's a lot easy after leaving
the military it's a lot easier to make
that relationship between the burn pit
exposure and uh and the cancer then 20
years down the line you've had an
accumulation of exposures to uh the
carcinogens in the tobacco smoke over a
longer period of time um so it's not as
easy to uh associate that uh with the
developing cancer
I see that I'm not persuading you but I
you know that's my that's my response
all I'll say is and and it's a qu I'll
ask it as a question but is it not true
that cancer is if if you discovered
cancer a month after being exposed to a
burn pit you could almost exclude the
burn pit as the
cause you know I'm not familiar enough
with that but I assume that's probably
the
case other questions for this witness
representative
Perez just a comment in the fact that
Dupont is as recently as
2022 had cases go against them for what
happened in the 1950s to the 1980s so
right any other questions so I guess the
thing that question that I I I think the
other question seem to have missed is
this as I understand the law
now before the statute of limitation
starts running whether it's 3 years or
six years or 17 years or 20 years you
have to know that you've been injured
and know that it's causally connected to
whatever you're suing about so my
question
is if you know that you've been injured
and you know that the cause is
p if we if I understand correctly if if
under the current law with the knowledge
of both of those things you have six
years to bring
suit why does it make sense if you have
the knowledge of those things and it's
only having that knowledge that starts
the statute of limitations running why
if you have that knowledge should you
have 17 years to bring a lawsuit should
you be able to just sit around and say
you know I know that the that St Goin
has hurt me and it's hurt me in this way
but I'm just going to sit on my hands
for 17 years why does does that make
sense I don't believe it
does Mr chair I believe you should call
a lawyer as soon as you can make those
two uh those those meet those two things
other questions for this
witness being none thank you thank
you now I do not believe I have any
other Witnesses on uh House Bill 199 is
there anyone else who wishes to be heard
on House Bill 19
9 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
199 and I'm going to open the hearing on
House Bill
FN and I'm going to think I only have
one witness listed here I'm going to
call on Eric wind
no exactly exactly all right good
morning chairman honorable members of
the committee thank you for listening to
my testimony and a special thank you to
Chairman Lynn for sponsoring this
legislation on behalf of the board of
tax and land
appeals oh I'm sorry you're AB no you're
absolutely right give
me ah thank you I just think you're more
important you
CH yes if I had a gavel I
would the chair recognizes
representative Lyn to introduce the
bill can you put your button on Sir so
the red lights I I apologize for uh not
introducing the bill but I propose to do
so now so this bill is basically as I
understand it and and we'll have a
witness who has who can I think give you
more detail but basically based upon my
discussion with Miss LeBron the who
asked me to introduce this bill um this
bill is basically designed um to kind of
confirm what essentially happens pretty
routinely right now that that it would
allow the btla to hold their hearings um
in conquered in there and they should
you should understand that they already
have a hearing room they're not asking
for like a new hearing room or
additional facilities it's just
basically uh to sort of confirm that
they can hold their hearings um in their
hearing rooms um uh in the hearing room
and conquered um uh and which is as I
understand it mostly happening or
happening you know relatively routinely
now um and so it seemed to me to make
sense um I from looking at the card
which I saw of only one witness I assume
that you know that there's not
opposition to this and so I think that
we ought to pass it because it makes it
it makes practical sense and I um if
you're going to ask questions about the
details I hope you will wait for Miss uh
either Miss LeBron or the witness uh Mr
wind any questions none seeing none
thank you oh representative sorry quick
just quick question this seems very
specific for legislation like
authorizing that there be a room I'm not
sure uh just from your perspective about
legislation in general why it's needed
that this be captured in in statute
rather than in practice well you know I
I think the the issue
I suppose would be that um somebody
without a statute I suppose somebody
could you know I guess could say well I
want to have my hearing if the if the uh
if the matter
involves um a tax dispute in Coos County
I want to have my hearing in Coos County
um and the and arguably I don't know
whether I mean this would be a legal
question arguably there could be a claim
of you know you have a right to venue in
Coos County I don't know if that would
would would apply in this kind of a case
before an administrative agency or not
but at least there could be an argument
and I think I again I would leave it to
miss LeBron to to tell us or or Mr W to
tell us if there's been any real issues
on that uh but I think this would this
would clarify that you can have the you
can hold the hearings at the at the
bureau's offices so I think that
probably would be one of the one of of
the reasons for doing
that any other questions saying none
thank you thank you Mr
chair now recognize Mr
wind all right good morning and thank
you again my name is Eric wind I am a
member of the board of tax and land
appeals also in attendance with me as
chair LeBrun and our executive director
so we will answer any questions but I
think I can be pretty brief in
describing the issue um as raised by
representative Turner so this is a very
specific problem that we're increasingly
having in the imminent domain procedures
act so there's a very specific act that
prescribes the process that must be used
in imminent domain actions and included
in that requirement is that a
requirement that the board hold a
hearing on just compens ation in the
county where the taking is occurring the
so that is the problematic language that
is in the
statute um and it it it suggests
that it should happen in the county
courthouse if available otherwise it
should be held in such place or places
accessible to the public as the board
shall direct so the problem that we're
increasingly encountering is that County
cour houses do not have room for us as
the number of Judges is increasing our
last reliable Courthouse that would make
space available for us was Rockingham
and they now have full
courtrooms so from there we go on this
process of directing our administrative
staff to try to find some kind of public
space in the county where a just
compensation hearing can be held um and
so we look at other State Properties we
wind up usually seeking Municipal
properties some municipalities are
willing to entertain it but they often
times have a fee to use their properties
for hearings um so it goes on and on
that we go on this trail of asking the
municipalities to wave their fee which
has to go before the
selectman um and so it it it's a long
kind of cumbersome process this is a law
that was written in the 1971 last
updated in 1982 for this specific
provision and so really as we're in the
21st century it just makes sense in a
cost effective way that might actually
save money by reducing the amount of
State travel to use our existing hearing
room use our existing remote
Technologies to hold hearings um and to
authorize that instead of going through
a process of seeking space in the county
first um so that's the solution that we
are proposing as the bill has drafted I
would make one recommendation
respectfully that the effective date be
modified to make it of 60 days after
passage instead of on January 1 2026 I I
understand that this is in the judicial
title of the RSA so that I'm sure that
that's why the effective date was
selected but this is an agency request
and I think it should be treated as any
other agency request and made effect of
60 days um after passage so with that
I'm happy to take any questions are
there any questions of this witness
yes representative
T yeah thank thank you and thanks for
taking the question so and I appreciate
you're clarifying the the answer I'm
wondering reading sort of the additions
in the in the the paragraph here there's
two things going on one it sounds like
it's authorizing electronic or
telephonic participation and then before
that it talks about a suitable room is
it really the intent that you need a
room suitable for electronic
participation is that and is it just the
way it's constructed that makes it sound
like these are two separate
requirements so the suitable hearing
room language is a direct copy out of
RSA 71b which is the board's primary
statute enabling statute and that just
has the language that the state shall
provide this board with a suitable room
for hearings so that was truly just
copied and pasted over um as far as the
electronic participation the intent
there was to honor the spirit of the
statute that this is imminent domain
this is taking someone's property and we
want to be accommodating and offer it
convenience where possible um so that is
why we proposed adding the language
about remote
participation representative
mayos thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question would you be open
to um the parties being able to elect
whether the hearing is held in the
county where the taking taking took
place or whether it's held and conquered
I think we're very open to suggestion um
on that we're just raising the issue
that we are having an administrative
burden and trying to schedule the
hearings in the county where the taking
takes place the statute does already
have a provision where the parties could
agree to a hearing elsewhere there is
burden to getting that level of
agreement too because in most takings
you're dealing with banks that have
mortgages as that they're going to be a
party as well so there are burdens to
seeking everyone's agreement um but
absolutely if they want to elect to hold
to request the just compensation hearing
be held in the county then I think we
would be open to a provision like that
and I'll also note it that not in this
bill is the parties by right can request
a view of their property and nothing
would change of that so the board would
still if they request a VI we would
still go up and take a look at the
property thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you thank
you I don't have any more pink cards is
there anyone else here that wants to
speak on this bill seeing none I'm going
to close the hearing on House
Bill you have a just oh I didn't know we
had another car I apologize Mr
LeBron could you please press the
umone my name is Michelle LeBrun and I
am the chair of the board of tax and
land appeals in response to that last
question the problem that we are having
is that we cannot find
locations to hold the hearings so if the
parties ask us to hold the hearing in
coaz county and there isn't a location
available that's why we offer would
would like to offer the
virtual um
me way of handling the case the law also
states in the next section that we take
a view upon request of the parties we
would take a view of the of the excuse
me of the property that's being taken
after the hearing if the parties request
it
so even if they don't have the hearing
right in the county that the property is
located if they want a view of the
property they do get the
view thank you are there any questions
of this
witness seeing none thank you and could
you fill out a pink card before you go I
will thank
you okay at this point I will ask if
there anyone else that wants to speak on
this bill seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing house on House Bill 268 FN
yeah you know
what we just recess for a minute I just
want to Judiciary Community being recess
for five minutes
any e
so you know let me just ask a question
and again as I said as I've said from
the beginning I'm not going to do this
if there's any kind of you know
significant opposition but based on my
discussions with the ranking member it
appears that this might be a bill that
we could EXA now I've talked with uh the
the witnesses who appeared and uh
although they would although they would
prefer to to move up the effective date
uh they're comfortable with us executing
it if we're comfortable with it and then
they would propose to make that change
in the Senate um which I assume you know
would would would happen so the question
is are we comfortable with executing
this now as it say anybody has a pro I'm
not trying to force anything on anybody
if anybody has a problem we won't
execute but if the
first well let's well right let's take
let's stick to this one first but
but is there a reason that you would
prefer to hold on so uh yes I I my
inclination would be to say that it be
held and conquered unless a party
objects and requests a hearing in the
county okay um can I just ask for uh
clarification on that sir I don't have
the full rsas in front of me obviously
and I don't have your rules my
understanding is that oh I I don't have
the rsas or the rules in front of me my
understanding is that the board does in
fact uh Begin by
trying to meet the requests of the
parties and it's because of the
difficulties in finding an appropriate
place that this would then come in am I
wrong about that that's that's my that's
my understanding and I you know I I mean
you're I I think I I would say
representative you are correct that in
this sense if we were to pass this the
parties would not be able to object to
having it Inc conquered um um and so
that I mean that's that's true but I
think for the reasons my inclination is
for the reasons that representative
Smith was saying it you know that um
that there is this problem that and I
guess one of the things that would
concern me if we to leave the law the
way it is if there is significant
problem with finding places um somebody
could insist on well I don't care what
your problems are you you know I want it
in this location which could end up
delaying proceedings and some and maybe
that maybe one party or the other in
some particular case would like that to
to just delay the proceedings so but
perhaps if the board came back and said
we're you know Mr Smith we're having
difficulty finding a place the parties
would then agree to hold it and
conquered I I just
think I just think people should have
the at least in the first instance the
option of requesting a a hearing in the
county all right so let me add I mean
again I are you objecting then to our
voting
now yes because I don't think this bill
gives any option I don't know maybe we
could quickly hear from the witnesses
again as to whether even if this bill
were passed CL the hearing no you know
what given given your uh representative
Manos concern and the fact that we don't
you know we we have a number of people
missing I'm I'm not going to I'm not
going to go forward with executive okay
all right thank you moving
on we try
um representative BD but I call upon you
just to to introduce House Bill 337 all
you have to do is say you're introducing
it and you will not take any questions
and uh we'll then turn it over to
somebody who is prepared to respond okay
so we're discussing 337 is that correct
to go
to
really your big
moment7 sure you
smile smile
good morning
everybody 337 now what do you want to
just the analysis
or
I'm the ACT is relative to reporting
requirements of the judicial
Council and the House Bill
337 Dan berson representing Manchester
thank you
[Music]
oh I'm sorry Mr I'm sorry Mr Bucky uh
I good afternoon Jay Bucky executive
director of the judicial
Council uh I came this morning um not to
take a position either way on the bill
but mostly to make myself available if
members had any questions and also just
to one point of clarification I had when
I read the bill um which is that the
bill uh states that all members of the
judicial Council should file disclosures
um and then it lists two specific kinds
of members who should specifically file
disclosures my only um the only thing I
wanted to point out would be in
interpreting the bill for me I think
future directors it would be perhaps
simpler just to State all members of the
judicial Council and then not
specifically enumerate different kinds
simply because it adds a little bit of
ambiguity um when I read the bill and
that was my only clarification point
that I wanted to bring to the attention
of the committee all we have yes uh
representative trip is it clarified
elsewhere who are members of the
judicial
counil yes representative there's a the
the members of the judicial Council are
enumerated in statute and it encompasses
judges uh Court administrators members
appointed by the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court members appointed by
governor and councel and then other
members who are appointed by Statute uh
such as an AG representative um
representatives of the head of the house
Judiciary and Senate Judiciary Committee
thank you other questions for this
witness Mr Bucky can I ask you with
regard to the to section one of the bill
the the reporting requirement am I
incorrect
that other than judges and I'll get to
them in a moment but but other than
judges um all the members of the the
judicial council is an executive branch
agency I thought all the members of the
judicial
Council other than judges who have their
own Financial disclosure requirements
and legislators who we also have our own
Financial disc that all of them had did
had right now had to file closures am I
wrong on that I I believe the ambiguity
becomes um because some of them are
appointed by the Chief Justice and not
by the governor Council and in reviewing
15a uh It generally speaks to me it
speaks to appointments by governor and
counsel not by not to appointments by
the Chief Justice and that was the
intent of the legislation I see I see
okay all right
um yeah yes of course so thank you for
taking my question are you looking to
strike on line three everything after
judicial Council so including members of
the appointed by the Judiciary and
members of the half Bar Association and
just leave
it I I believe that would be simpler
from from my perspective yes and I think
it accomplish what I understand the
goals of the bill to be thank
you other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you Mr Bucky
thank you repres than
you are there any other Witnesses who
wish to appear on House Bill
337 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
e e
can I can I raise uh can I raise um and
I raise a question here regarding um the
bill that we just heard
um I you know I I I understand in uh the
the point that um the witness made and
that in response to the vice chair's
question um and arguably we could take
out that the language on line three that
three and four that says including
members appointed by the Judiciary and
and members of the New Hampshire Bar
Association
you know in terms of if we wanted to if
we wanted to exec this bill now um I'm
not sure that that is particularly
important I mean you know if we had that
language in there so what it doesn't
seem like it you know I'm
not yeah no it might have been I mean
yeah exactly I don't think that so I
guess the question is um are we is
everyone comfortable with executing this
now um if anybody you know if anybody
has a problem again I'm not going to
exec something if people have a problem
with it but if nobody has a problem yes
so the so the change would be to remove
lines uh one through four no we wouldn't
make any changes we wouldn't make any
changes we just we just OTP the bill as
is it includes those members but it
doesn't exclude anyone else that's part
of the council so
right um I come on come on come on in
so um so um you know Eric what just uh
I'm sorry representative tur I apologize
um what um what we were just talking
about is um should we exact
337 now um as you I think you were in
the room when there there was discussion
between the witness and uh in response
to uh Vice chair manion's uh question
about you know suggesting that we
possibly could remove the language on
lines three and four that says including
members appointed by the Judiciary and
members of the New Hampshire Bar
Association um the what we were
discussing is if we wanted to execute
now I mean leaving that language in
doesn't hurt anything it's not it it
doesn't really hurt anything um and I
think as representative Perez had
pointed out you know there may have been
a specific reason why they wanted to
emphasize that point um so I guess the
question is is I would propose if
everybody's agreeable to ex cheing this
now with an ought to pass but again I'm
not going to do it if anybody's
uncomfortable with doing that everybody
is everybody okay with
it all right so then we'll um
uh yeah oh no absolutely we're g we're
gonna wait a moment so that we can the
clerk can have time to do
this one two three four five two three
four five
just want to make sure we had a
quarum we do
I'll I'll
well okay all right somebody somebody
willing to make the motion on
this don't everybody speak at
once I'll do it I'll make the you make
the motion
represent Oh I thought you had a
question want you to be surprised by
making the
motion which I think is a very good idea
because it introduces you you will then
by the chair who won't tell you now but
will tell you
after that you have to write the
report that will go in the calendar when
we vote on it in the house and I will
just like you to know that all of us
will help you with that so don't worry
about it and this means that once this
happens you've been introduced so I
would go ahead but I just want you to
understand not to be surprised when the
chair then says okay by the end of
tomorrow you have to write the report
okay good all right all right so
representative Burger on uh
moves uh OT OTP on House Bill 337 is
there a
second second by representative Andress
um I just want to make a note
all right um is there any further
discussion on uh House Bill
337 seeing none I would ask clerk to
call the role please a motion is ought
to pass on House Bill
337 representative Manion yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew representative kutab is absent
representative
Perez the clerk votes
yes representative Morton
yes representative Smith yes
representative
Manos yes representative tur yes
representative Rambo yes representative
berson yes and chairman Lynn yes did I
miss anybody there's a lot of absences
so I gotta thank
you vot is 12 to Zero 12 to zero okay
all right um and um does anybody um
object to this going on the consent
calendar all right so it'll go on the
consent calendar and um representative
buron could I ask you to write the
report and in fact I um I could almost
uh give you the language if you what you
know when we when we take a break or I
can almost give you the language can be
very short and I can almost give you the
language of what of how it might look
why the forget
about leave a word out yeah well you
might have for for example you might say
something like this this this bill is
designed to um um
clarify um uh an A A an open question as
to whether
um members of the judicial Council who
are
appointed um by the
Judiciary uh are are required to file uh
Financial uh
disclosure
statements and it also uh um requires
that um the judicial Council uh report
fee
schedules
um that it establishes to the
legislature and to the Supreme Court I
think they're already reported to the
Supreme Court I think but this would say
to the
legislature um and that really you know
I think that uh that could be it it
literally can be one or two
sentences great all right so
representative you write this and you
then send it to the
chair and he will okay it and take it
from there right and thank you very much
I I really appreciate you're doing this
um good bill of doing um yeah so you
know all right so um you know what I
this is um I know we don't have
everybody here but um
I wanted to um I I briefly discussed
this with representative Manion and and
representative Smith but I just want to
raise this with
everyone we've there are seven bills
that that came in after the scheduling
I've I've done for February there are
seven bills that that came in that we
have to hold hearings on at least one or
maybe two of them I don't have the I
don't have it right off the top of my
head our early bills so what that means
is we are going to have to have another
day of hearings
beyond the um the 5th the 12th and the
19th in order to get our work done and
so as I've tried to figure this out
including like the availability of this
room I think we are down
to there are two potential days that we
could do that one would be February
Monday February 17th and that's while
I'm still away uh and that personally
that would not be the preferred day to
me but but I is that a Federal
holiday yes that's president is it okay
some of us will be celebrating okay so
this may
okay February 17th yeah President's Day
all right now I'm sorry
so I guess then that what expain to you
why I
know I was born on February 22nd which
is George Washington birthday I remember
that and in fact we can never celebrate
George Washington's birthday on the 22nd
because the latest it can be because we
need a three-day weekend is the
21st and so that's how I know okay all
right so in light of that I'm sorry
sorry I'm glad somebody raised
it so I think what we're down to then is
um we're going to need to hold that
hearing either on the 26th or the 27th
now that's the week that you know people
are are so who's going to I know who's
going to be away I object okay all right
I think we have to find another dat all
right so how many bills are there well
on the difficult bills right there's
they are difficults no they they are
they're they're difficult we're not
going to get through them in half
so um you know what the problem is this
I've scheduled I mean I you correct me
if I'm wrong I I I I'm for three of
those days I'm not going to be here and
so I tried I mean I think I've scheduled
relatively aggressively for those three
days there's seven bills on two of them
and eight bills on the third one I think
that's you know if you tell me you want
to hear more I'm Not Gon to I'm not
going to be here so it'll be that's fine
with me but I think that you're I think
that that's probably not fair to you um
so if
we I just it seems like if you don't
want to do it that
week
um then and we can't do it on the 17th
then we're gonna well no the problem is
we can't do it can we
yes I think you're I think you're
reading from you're reading from you're
not reading from our bills I don't
think representative trip
representative
trip repres representative
trip vacation week right now the the
notice did say that you know you could
but obviously again I'm trying to you
know it's late and it's right now I hear
you I hear you and it sounds like a lot
number of people are going to be away
that's that's fine looking at any I'm
just looking at the C okay so this what
we can't do we have no want to go back
to February let's go to
February okay
February so what what's happening on the
week of it can't be it can't be oh it
still be next week because we could get
it the calendar get it in the calendar
today
it could be next week or the week you
could do it or the week of the 10th or
the week of the
10th
um or the
we I'll be I'll be wait minute on the 3
I think hang on I think I wait a minute
what's going on on the thir give me one
second February
3r
um I didn't put in theth 12 the 19th
that's I
could I could do it I would be here on
the third and I could do it on on is
that that work that work for everybody
if we do it on the
third but I mean all right so I mean
it's just this these will be just
hearing they not going to be not going
to be any exec session I mean unless we
have something that everybody agrees on
but um would that work for everybody the
third yeah
per
thata problem is I have to do this I
have to I have to put it in the calendar
by noon that's my problem we want it for
next week it has to be it has to be in
the calendar by noon all right so next
week we do have the third what you could
be here and we have um we're already
here on the
fifth we have the
seven no no we don't no because state
federal uses this room on the on the
there no other room available I I don't
know I mean I know that last year when I
tried to get something and they're
meeting every week they I think they
think they are
until you know through February I
suspect I think this is too early before
they you know they they do
meet the third the ground day too so
they'll know what the weather's like
right right right all right so you know
what is um does my inclination is to go
with the thir
third all right so that's what I'm
that's what I'm going to do and I'm
going to we're going to take a uh brief
recess while I get this to
uh while I get this to to Karen to uh
put it in the calendar
yes on the third well we're gonna have
seven bills and some of them as as
represent Smith yeah we're GNA do those
why don't we do it on two
days third
and what what's the other day 10 the
third and the
10th what does everybody say about that
third I it's my birthday my son's coming
to town and it won't
be come will come two days yeah no I
think I'm going to do it on the third
I'm gonna just put seven I'm gonna put
the seven of them in on the third all
right we'll take we'll take a uh yeah
the
for
e
e e
BR my suitcases in right to the
airport going to the airport yeah what
are you are you leaving on the third no
leaving on the fifth leaving on the
fifth feel all right well so you could
still come in in the morning on the
5ifth and do
a I could I mean I your FL my flight is
that it's not till 9:00 at night so no
I'm kidding
if I
said I do value my marriage and if I
told you I was coming out the fif it
would be like would want that she'd be
sending me to Vietnam permanently glad
you all
supp all right so we're after we're
after 11 okay 369 369
um69 369
pen okay you see it Kelly P okay all
right so I'm going to open the hearing
on House Bill
369 and uh recognize uh the prime uh
sponsor uh represent
pention put okay thank good thanks
morning representative thank you so much
chair um my name's for the record is uh
representative Kelly Penza straford
District
19 um this bill is a is in a sense um
comes on a on a personal level uh I
didn't know how I was going to testify
on it today um this affects my family
and uh I basically you in the judicial
system I've seen firsthand so many
different things that are um broken and
this fixes it so currently
um this affects my daughter and we have
not had we haven't even had our initial
hearing so this won't even take effect
to um to help our family a a prosecutor
up north is the one that told me this
has been a problem for a long time and
this fixes it
so the person that was arrested in
regards with a sexual assault that took
place um was arrested in the fall of
23 we still haven't even had our hearing
yet in District Court up North but after
we do which will be probably at some
point this spring
my daughter will have to go through it
all over
again and from the time that the assault
took
place and then when it does go to
Superior Court because it will
definitely be appealed there's no doubt
um four or five years could have passed
that means all of the witnesses all of
that will all be done so um it just
penalizes victims
and um and it's it's absolutely
ridiculous that we would ever let
someone have to go through this uh twice
and I Tred to because there is a sort of
a fix I guess that you could have so we
appealed to the county
attorney to try to get him to bypass the
district court to take the case he flat
out ignored every single
request email phone call
so this bill has to pass it's why would
we ever have something where we're going
to
revictimized um
victims it's it's crazy so it doesn't
hurt at all that's still completely due
process and for someone that has been
um someone that has been arrested and
they're you know fighting of course for
their um if they believe that they're
innocent or all of that that it doesn't
change anything here it's just why would
we ever go through this
twice so give the person that has been
charged the choice in the beginning and
and that's pretty much it so if you have
any questions I'll answer them but this
is um this came to me because I realized
this loophole from a prosecutor up north
uh she explained um how we how to you
know she's like you should you should
hear leg legislator she file a bill and
because this affects you personally uh
you can speak to it and so that's why
I'm here all right questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very
much next I'm going to call on Pamela K
Kylie please
kyliee good morning Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Pamela kyg and
I the public policy specialist at the
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence um our community um our
Coalition serves um roughly 15,000
survivors across all of our 12 uh
community- based crisis centers in New
Hampshire including survivors of sexual
assault both adults and children um I'm
here to speak in support of this bill um
we really appreciate um what the sponsor
has brought forward the goals of this
legislation really recognizes the impact
our judicial process has on victims in
New Hampshire of offenders in Domestic
and Sexual Violence cases often use the
court process to delay Justice and
further perpetuate abuse with the intent
to wear down the victim and hopes
they'll give up criminal proceedings in
sexual abuse cases can take years um and
as you've heard from the sponsor can be
a really really trying experience for
families um the more time that passes
the more the lives of victims are
impacted Ed without the ability to move
forward and heal um passing this
legislation would help streamline and
improve what is already a daunting and
scary court process especially for minor
victims of sexual assault um as a state
we should do uh be doing everything we
can to support child survivors um and
ensure that offenders are held
accountable the traumatic nature of
sexual crimes against children can
prevent victims from coming forward and
even disclosing abuse I think most uh
when I share this statistic most people
are really a back but the median age
that a Child Survivor comes forward to
report their abuse is 52 um so the
lifetime impact of trauma can really
delay this process um so anything that
we can do to really ensure that we are
streamlining and closing loopholes in
our law that would prevent someone from
coming forward should really be
addressed um many people who were abused
as children report that they didn't know
that what was happening to them was
illegal um so we should also be um
supportive of survivors who are enough
to come forward and Report their abuse
um and I think especially just knowing
that a lot of people don't believe child
victims um and so that adds to the
daunting nature of this process um it
can leave victims feeling silenced
disheartened and alone to cope with the
aftermath of abuse whether facing
threats by offenders or disbelief from
family members victims are faced with a
double bind when it comes to disclosing
their abuse and then being able to go
through this process um the fact that
child survivors May face a second
criminal proceeding should the should
the the first Lower Court decision be
appealed is devastating um this bill
recognizes how incredibly difficult it
is for child survivors to come forward
and is a small measure we can take to
limit the long-term trauma that
survivors experience and their families
um I ask the committee to please support
um this bill um and thank you so much
for hearing my testimony today questions
for this
witness s none thank you very much thank
you um next I'm going to call um on
Eva here I'll put
another oh it's already okay hi hi good
morning
good morning chairman Lynn and members
of the House judice
Judiciary Judiciary commit my name is
Eva this is my first time ever
testifying before the
legislator I'm a sex I'm a Survivor of
sexual assault and I'm here today in
support of HB 369 when I was 14 I dated
someone who was 2 years older than me
who was possessive and controlling he
told me that since we were talking I
wasn't allowed to take talk to anyone
else I couldn't speak to other voice
boys he wouldn't take no for an answer
even when I would try to have a say he
would just ask me the same question in a
different way to get the answer he
wanted all while telling me he loved me
I can tell you it doesn't make it less
dramatic to get assaulted by someone who
says they love you it makes it worse in
addition to being victimized by the guy
was dating I was continuously silenced
ignored and abandoned by the people who
are supposed to help I was let down by
my guidance counselor our re our school
resource officer in the police
department instead of finding support I
was left feeling guilty embarrassed
ashamed and less than and I was only 14
years old I fought my way into the court
system only to be failed again all I
wanted was my voice to be heard for the
guy who assaults me to be held
accountable for harming me and to have
some hope that his punishment would be
like my Justice instead I was denyed my
voice yet again and I would victimize
this time by the people who are supposed
to protect me and give me my Justice the
process made me depressed suicidal and I
was bullied at school all why my abuser
continue to walk past me in the hallways
and laugh at me what he did affected my
relationship with my family my mental
health and I also now have difficulty
creating new friendship with boys I
distrust people and assume the worst
always wondering if their intentions are
real or fake I am a survivor I survive
my abuser I survive the court system and
I survive my trauma victims of sexual
assault have to live with what happened
to them for the rest of their lives what
happened to me and what has happened to
too many others in New Hampshire is
serious the the New Hampshire
legislator has an opportunity today to
support survivors like me and simplify a
process that is extremely ret
traumatizing I was committed to taking
my case as far as I need to but the
truth is most wouldn't testifying once
against someone who harmed you and
silenced you is a really difficult
experience having to do that and go
through the entire trial process all
over is something a lot of survivors
might not have the strength to do and I
don't want them to Once is enough while
my case was resolved through a plea deal
it was no less grueling and antagonizing
I had to fight every step of the way to
be heard I felt powerless and I felt
like I didn't matter nobody deserved
this I don't want anyone to feel how I
felt as a young Survivor it's important
to me that we make a change I decided to
share my story with you today to be a
voice for other survivors who have been
failed by the justice system in their
communities I'm here to stand up for
those who can't stand up for themselves
thank you for letting me he thank you
very much all right um thank you next
I'm going to call on Steven Anders
please good morning chairman ly members
of the committee my name is Steven
endris I'm an assistant County Attorney
at the maram county attorney's office
I've been a PR uter for um over 20 years
now I am in support of House Bill
369 and just to sort of start at the
beginning and maybe assume you're not
familiar with the process what this bill
would do is in misdemeanor sexual
assault cases specifically brought under
RSA
um A4 I'm sorry misdemeanor sexual
assault cases normally would go forward
in circuit court because it's a class a
misdemeanor and there's the potential
for the person to go to jail if
convicted under the New Hampshire
Constitution they have the right to a
jury trial unfortunately there's really
no mechanism in New Hampshire to get the
ma jury trial in the first instance so
the system we have in place is that if
you're convicted in Circuit Court you
can appeal to the superior court for a
denovo jury trial which means as if what
had happened in Circuit Court had never
happened the difficulty of course is
that we know testifying can be traumatic
especially for children and especially
in sexual assault cases so the way the
system is set up now you would have to
have a trial in Circuit Court testify in
circuit court and then if the
defendant's found guilty the defendant
could appeal for a denovo trial in
Superior Court where it would be a jury
trial and again you'd be called on to
testify a second
time and you'd obviously be exposed to
that same trauma of testifying fing
twice what this bill would do is have a
defendant charged with misdemeanor
sexual assault in Circuit Court make an
election early on whether or not they
want to go forward in circuit court and
wave the right to a jury trial or have
the case immediately appealed to
Superior Court for a jury trial in the
first instance um I do think this is a
good idea it would certainly limit the
uh the trauma that that victims are
facing as was mentioned earlier there is
a statute which allows cases to be
brought in the Superior Court in the
first
instance it's actually RSA 592
A1 and I certainly in my experience I
can think of at least one case where we
had a vulnerable victim in circuit court
and we brought it in Superior Court in
the first instance in order to avoid
having to have this person testified
twice the difficulty with this the
statute indicates that Superior Court
May dismiss a prosecution originally
begun which is within the jurisdiction
of the circuit court so in order to
bring these charges in the the Superior
Court in the first instance under the
current
statute the judge and Superior Court
could dismiss it at any time because
it's within the circuit Court's
Jurisdiction and sort of knock us back
to to circuit court so you have to have
Buy in from the Superior Court judges
which may be difficult when they have
their own busy f
dockets there is one small tweak I would
recommend on page
two lines 24 and 25 it says in a
prosecution for a violation of RSA 632
A4 involving a victim 16 years of age or
under at the time the prosecution is
commenced that phrase 16 years of age or
younger um I think becomes ambiguous and
there's there's actually some
interesting if you're ever interested in
doing legal research on this the the
states are about split 50/50 of what 16
years or age 16 years of age or under
actually means there's some people
that'll tell you until a person turns 17
they're 16 years of age or under there's
other people that will tell you if
you're 16 and a half you are not 16
years of age or under so there's a
question of 16 years of age or under
does that mean until your 16th birthday
or does that mean until your 17th
birthday um the Preamble on line 23 says
with victims less than 16 years of age
which I think is is better language if
you wanted to
clarify um victims less than 16 years of
age or victims less than 17 years of age
would make it clearer um who
specifically you're speaking
about other than that small uh Amendment
I have I I do support the bill and I'm
certainly happy to answer
questions questions for this witness
representative
Smith thank you um can you tell me the
reason that we would use 16 here and not
18 I I think that's a policy decision
for the committee um the one thing I can
indicate is that the misdemeanor sexual
assault statute does refer to persons
under 16
um in both
subsection B and
C so that's the only thing I can think
of why 16 is being used instead of 18
could I ask one other question certainly
yes thank you
um you identify a very serious problem
um if you've been around for a while you
you saw the start and the end of the
felony first
um
experiment recognizing the same problem
of I mean
not this the problem of the
differentiation between the two
courts um if we were to pass
this are there other
examples that are there of the conflict
that exists between
the Circuit Court well the the circuit
court and the Superior Court as we have
constructed those courts
now I think the answer is yes from from
my point of view um and going back even
further than felonies first at at one
point in the state we had what was
referred to as the jury trial project
and i' I am old enough that I remember
the jury trial project and got to
participate in the jury trial project
where everyone who was charged with a
Class A misdemeanor I know at least it
existed in both marac and Rockingham
County everyone who was charged with the
class A misdemeanor had to decide at
arraignment I think it was whether or
not they wanted a jury trial or a bench
trial and we were doing jury trials in
the first instance in um domestic
violence cases in DWI subsequent cases
in circuit courts or District Courts at
the time in I think Portsmith conquered
I think Derry had a a jury trial project
where we were doing jury trials in the
circuit courts to try and eliminate the
the two-tier system um the the that
two-tier
system has some inherent difficulties in
in my opinion and in my experience and I
can tell you the the first difficulty is
that you are having all Witnesses
essentially testify
twice uh that creates difficulties
because a lot of witnesses don't want to
be involved in the process to begin with
and they're being involved in the
process twice so it is a fairly major
inconvenience for them
secondly one of the things that occurs
during cross-examination is you ask you
look for differences in people's
statements if you testify under oath and
defense Council has a transcript of that
and you testify a second time almost
inevitably there's some minor difference
in perhaps what you said which can be
used to impeach you as a witness the the
third problem that I've always had with
the the two-tier system is that we often
bring alternative Theory charges so for
example in a driving well intoxicated
case if a person agrees to a
breathalyzer test and is over
a08 we would charge two theories of
driving well intoxicated one that
they're under the influence and one that
they have a blood alcohol concentration
over a
8 the difficulty is that in Circuit
Court when we have those trials a lot of
Judges will find the person guilty of
one but not guilty of the other and as
soon as the judge in Circuit Court says
not guilty we can't bring that charge
again for the trial Den noo so we've
certainly had experiences where I I
personally had a case where an
individual was charged with both
stalking and Theft the court found him
not stalking in what theft uh he had
actually stolen the key to his former
girlfriend's apartment and had let
himself into the apartment a number of
times the judge in Circuit Court found
that I hadn't proven stalking Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt and found him not
guilty of stalking but did find that he
had stolen the key to the apartment and
found him guilty of theft he appealed
that to a jury trial and because he was
found not guilty of stalking we couldn't
talk about the fact that he was actually
using this stolen key to go in and out
of his girlfriend's apartment and it it
just sort of leaves a lot of information
that is maybe relevant out of the
equation thank you very much other
questions yes representative
CH yeah thanks and thanks for taking the
question uh I'm just curious because you
you mentioned the the misdemeanor sexual
assault statutes um and I notic in the
language um on page one um in in the new
language we talk about the victim's age
at the time prosecution is
commenced is that typically the standard
I'm I'm curious why it's when
prosecution is commen versus when the
when the assault took place I assume
that the purpose of this bill is to
prevent children from having to testify
twice and to prevent victims of sexual
assault from having to testify twice
twice so I would presume that if for
example a person was a victim when they
were 15 years old but charges weren't
brought until they were 18 years old
when they were 18 I think the assumption
would be that they can handle testifying
twice or at least we willing to put them
through that that trauma twice so I
again I think that's a policy decision
up to to you guys whether you want it to
be the age at the time the prosecution
is commenced or the age at the time of
the
offense okay so so not your impression
even if it went forward the way it is it
doesn't change the standard of what the
misdemeanor sexual assault on a minor
would be at its core it changes it would
be a policy decision of whether this
should be different than that standard
correct this wouldn't change the
misdemeanor sexual assault statute at
all it would change the process for
someone charged with misdemeanor sexual
assault whether they had had the chance
to have essentially two trials or
whether they elected to have either a
bench trial or a jury trial can I do one
more followup yes of course so I guess
flipping it over do you see any problem
if this was to state that uh this is all
based on uh assault that happened when
the victim
was under under 16 or or 18 if it was
changed but under age at the the time
the assault took place versus the time
that the that the that the trial
commences I I don't see a problem with
that and the and the only I guess just
correct me if I'm wrong but if you if
you changed it to the
time you made it hinge on the time of
the
assault then I mean to carry your
example forward and I think there have
been some cases like this if the witness
was now 35 right um you you would you
would this would you would this would
kick in and they would only have to
testify once and correct I mean I
suppose that could be the law but you
know that it would in other words if if
somebody's assaulted when let's say
they're 14 but the case isn't brought
until they're 35 and that can happen um
I'm not sure that you know this I it
would seem to me that the same argument
of let's not yet let a young victim have
to testify twice doesn't apply if at the
time the person's testifying there's 35
that that's that would be my only
concern about that where whereas the way
it's worded it it's uh it is limited to
somebody that's young at the time of
that they're going to have to testify I
I agree what you just said is very
accurate other other questions yes
representative Manos thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question I
was confused by something that I thought
you said which is you were describing
the process for going to Superior Court
and you discussed Superior Court judges
kicking the case back to the um circuit
court and I was but if the defendant has
elected a jury trial and therefore is
going to be in Superior Court how what's
the Authority for the judge to kick it
back to the Circuit Court right I so if
it's an appeal to Superior Court the
judge can't kick it back to Circuit
Court if it's initiated in Superior
Court in the first instance but it's
within the jurisdiction of the circuit
court and and again the the example that
I had was we had an individual in
conquered who was
assaulted um and was developmentally
delayed and we brought those charges in
Superior Court in the first instance
even though they were misdemeanors
because we felt like this person
probably wasn't going to be able to
testify twice to begin with um in order
to do that though you have to get Buy in
from the superior court and it's sort of
a a once in a great while that I think
we can bring misdemeanors in Superior
Court in the first
instance yes follow up I I'm just
curious where you successful in that in
that case so I was involved in the
Circuit Court aspect of it my
recollection is that a number of people
were convicted in Superior Court of um
assaulting this young man other
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you oh I'm sorry
representative
BRD thank you Mr
chair I just had a question I didn't see
anything in here as far as assistance
for folks that I don't know if that
doesn't fit here but as far as
assistance Medical Care whatnot or just
to be assigned a I don't know a
psychologist or whatnot but I'm just
curious why if you feel like that kind
of language would
um help a defendant
or that wouldn't necessarily be in in in
this statute I think there's certainly
um a restitution statute that talks
about uh costs in terms
of psychological care after care that
type of thing um I think they kind of go
together really but and I I certainly
don't disagree with that
but it to me it makes more sense to be
in the rest of restitution statute
because that applies to all crimes with
victims um and certainly you can have
restitution with with multiple
crimes representative Morton you had a
question yeah so um what you were
speaking on the chair about thank you
and thank you for the uh question here
um this wouldn't apply to cases like
what's going on YDC for example because
of the length of time it's been and so
forth for a number reasons yes right so
the the wording of this couldn't be
changed but by this passing that could
open the door for Expediting Expediting
uh justice with that sort of
situation if so if this passed I don't
think this would have any
impact you know sort of on on what's
going on with YDC um if if this passed
and you had a misdemeanor sexual assault
at for example YDC and the victim was
still under the age of uh 16 or 17
however you word that this would then
apply and they'd have to elect either
have the circuit court trial or the jury
trial okay so a followup to that if this
passed another bill could be placed that
would be based on this but
including the cases that are years
later potentially you could or you could
amend this to to change the age to the
time of the offense okay thank you all
right any other questions for this WT
thank you know representative pens could
I could I just ask you to come up for
one one second
um Mr Anders the witnesses just has
raises a very valid point I think um
there is some ambiguity to the way the
the um 16 years of age or under is yeah
lines 23 and 24 and so
um I guess the question would be I mean
we could because the way it's now worded
theoretically somebody you you could be
read to be some that doesn't apply until
somebody's turned 17 so I mean are you
do you have a preference of
to thank you so much uh chairman Lynn I
was going to ask to come up again too
because it was you know this was um of
course put together um through the
lawyers down in OSS and um I believe
that and and he could maybe back me up
or you could so line
23 if that just changes to less than 17
years of age then it fixes it it you're
right no you're absolutely right it does
and you would be comfortable with that
yes I would be okay all right
um yes of course representative katat
thank you for taking my question
chairman ly so for clarification
purposes if we said less than 17 that
would be at the time that the initial
proceedings that the that the person was
charged because we're hearing that
sometimes this takes a really long time
to go through and so I'd want to make
sure that let's say the person was
arrested when the victim was under 17
but then it took three years for the
case to get to trial
would i' I'd still want it to apply in
that case so would it be from the time
that the
person how would that work it says well
it says at the time the prosecution is
commenced so you know uh I mean that
would be that would be an an issue I I
would say normally it would be the time
that the complaint is filed in the is
first filed in court so if it um if it's
first if the person is under 17 at the
time that the complaint is first filed
in court then it would it would apply um
if it took and so if it took you know a
long period of time uh to get to get to
even a trial in the district where I
think it would still apply the person
would have to make the
election could I speak to this real
quick sure okay cuz uh representative
cutab you missed um the attorney that
spoke on this so it actually wouldn't
apply so um I didn't think I was going
to be so emotional today so the assault
that took place with my daughter
happened in
22 uh the person wasn't arrested until
23 the assault that happened on my
daughter she was 14 she's now
so as time goes it's really hard with
Witnesses and all these other types of
things and um and I don't know if this
person's going to be brought to justice
but it's this thing that's just hanging
over us CU we haven't even had our first
trial yet so um I understand where
you're coming from but the bill as
written does not so let's say if this
was in place now and my daughter because
she turns um my daughter turn she's 16
now and she turns 17 um at the end of
March uh if another years goes by then
it wouldn't apply to her and maybe
that's another bite at the Apple at some
point in time but I really want to fix
what I can right now and to answer your
question representative Morton this
really this applies for misdemeanor so
the cases with YDC are full-blown felony
charges so um in my case it could have
been a felony but uh she ran away so I
just um I really want to fix this and my
daughter had this snow day today and um
she didn't want to come and I really
wanted her to speak so I I just want to
thank the other victim that came up to
speak because this has been really
really hard for our family all right
thank you very much man all right oh I'm
sorry representative tur do you have a
question yeah and first let me say sorry
for for whatever your uh your family has
suffered and uh I I just on this point
about the the date of the offense versus
the date of the
trial do is is there a reason why you
think it would be problematic to set it
back to the date of the offense so that
it would cover a broader group of people
and and in my mind I'm thinking not ret
traumatize
victims um
who who make may be older now but are
still talking about a a trauma when they
were
younger I agree and I think that would
be great it's just right now how the
misdemeanor statute is it goes based
upon that age and so that's why how the
bill was organized I don't know if it
would the language wise legally e and
representative ly you could maybe speak
to this you're a lawyer or judge you I
mean you know this stuff more than I do
um this was the way we could handle it
at first but I I understand what you're
saying I don't know if that would
fundamentally change one the support for
the Coalition um and I don't want
anybody to be revictimized twice and as
time goes on like I said it's really
hard for these cases to um to be proven
um if it wouldn't fundamentally um hurt
the bill or um you know um imp its
progress or passage I'd be okay with it
but um if it would if it if it would
then I'd like to keep it the way it is
all right other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
any I'm sorry represent Smith I don't
have a question for the for the witness
um I have a question for you as chair of
the Judiciary Committee and I see
sitting in the audience and now I
understand not for this bill but for the
next bill um our colleague who chaired
um the special committee on the Circuit
Court um I sit here and listen to this
and um I don't think the word horrified
is too strong a word for me to use
thinking about how the structure itself
of the relationship between the circuit
court and the Superior
Court might not best
meet the appropriate judicial
requirements of the citizens of the
state um I don't see this as a problem
that relates only to juveniles I see it
as it relates to people who are older
and I don't and and
this whole lack of I think there's a I
think there might be a lack of
appropriate division of responsibilities
between the circuit court and the
superior court and at some point I would
like wiser heads than mine to be able to
take a look at this at this issue and
see if we ought to consider some
fundamental changes and I don't expect
you to respond although I would love to
hear your response but I'm very
concerned about what we've all just
heard it doesn't seem right to me well I
guess what I I guess what I would say is
is this I mean I I think that you rais a
legitimate question but it seems to me
that that's I mean we're not going to
we're not we're not going to be able to
get an amendment to this bill for
example that would you know that that
might well be something that would be uh
you know appropriate for some some
further legislation in the future or
some further study but I don't think it
AG I don't think we can do anything
about thank you for indulging no for
sure is there anyone else who wishes to
be heard on SB uh HB
369 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing I'm sorry I yes did you want to
say something
further okay please come up
hit that red button so we hit the button
so we get the red there you go yes okay
um hi again I just wanted to say
that I really think this should be
passed I'm really urging you guys to
please just think about it the incident
itself wasn't traumatizing it was coming
to court and having to relive it and
retell your story over and over again
for people to not only shame you but
make you feel embarrassed about what
happened to you and I think that's not
okay I just again for her her daughter
couldn't be heard so I want to stand up
for her because or just for anyone not
even just for her because this has been
going on way too long it's really thank
you very much thank you right anyone
else who wishes to be heard on HB
369 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on HB
369 and I'm going to open the hearing on
HB U 480 and I'm going to recognize the
prime sponsor um representative Mark uh
Pearson thank you Mr chairman and
members of the Judiciary if I may uh
first respond to ranking member Smith
who served next to me on that special
committee for two years I asked the
speaker if given the successes of that
special committee we could have two more
years he said no but as chairman of
Children and Family Law I could appoint
a
subcommittee I am in the process and you
beat me to it of going to some of the
members of the special committee to say
give us some good items we can go to
work on and so if you would send me a
good email on what you had just said
uh that will be something under
consideration thank
you for the record my name is Mark
Pearson I chair the children and family
law committee which meets in this room
on Tuesdays a year and a half ago
attorney Holly Stevens of Nami which is
the National Alliance for the mentally
ill asked if I would work with her on
legislation having to do with
restoration of Competency for those
accused of a crime it is a fundamental
constitutional right that people be able
to assist in their own defense but some
people are found to be not competent to
do that Most states have programs in
place to help people come to competency
New Hampshire which tends to be first in
some things and last in many other
things is not one of those States as a
result while 70 to 80% of the people in
those states that helped them come to
competency the rate in New Hampshire
where it's run along now good luck is
30% a bill was filed to establish a
bamal and bipartisan committee to study
of the matter representative tah served
on that committee we heard from members
of the Judiciary from various mental
health organizations DHHS Behavioral
Health division New Hampshire hospital
we looked at a sampling of what other
states did well it's been asked why
would you want to help people be able to
be competent which means now they got to
go to trial well the answer is
severalfold and again remember this is
red States and blue States doing this
and they've answered the question we do
this first because it gives closure to
the alleged
victims a decision one way or the other
has been made by the court and now life
can go on
we've heard from people where there was
not a decision not a decision and
they're hanging in there without closure
it also gives closure to the alleged
perpetrator that person could be found
not guilty but even if the person were
found
guilty sometimes the sentence that's
given out is less than that person
bouncing around all for the mental
health
system
also although it doesn't happen every
time when a person is undergoing the
kind of counseling that would assist him
or her to come to
competency it may be helpful in other
areas where that person suffers from
mental
issues our committee came to several
conclusions number one it's generally
considered that an intentional program
of assisting in restoration is a good
thing second we found that having a
forensic liaison person would be very
advantageous this person would be
appointed to assist the person coming to
competency if they're having issues
which keep them from competency they
probably will have issues in showing up
to appointments whether that be in the
court or a counselor or what have you
and this becomes a financial problem
because it costs just as much to have
the the heat on and the lights on and
the staff present and the building
rented if a patient doesn't show up then
if the patient does well we don't want
to waste that money we want to make sure
that the individual goes to hearings
goes to
appointments and the forensic liaison
person will assist in that that forensic
liaison person will also be the one who
will find out amongst the various
counseling programs and Community Mental
Health places what programs are
consistent with what other states are
using
also we were convinced that the agency
overseeing
this should not be in the judicial
branch because we don't want this to be
seen so much as a juridical matter
although a judge eventually will have to
render a verdict on competency we wanted
to see this as a mental health thing we
wanted to help people that was the
purpose so we thought DHHS would be the
best place to oversee it well our
committee worked hard we learned much we
talked to a lot of people and then we
were up at the deadline of Bill filing
so the bill that you had before you that
you probably have read over was put in
as a
placeholder the amendment 00 61h which
has been passed around is the replace
all Amendment let me say a few things
about how that came to be I called
together an ad hoc Gathering of
individuals people from agencies and
bureaus and departments that would
actually be responsible for doing this
we had people from the Judiciary would
what we're trying to do work would the
judges see that this is something in the
Hampshire akin to what other judges are
finding across the country
we would uh we also invited people from
the New Hampshire hospital from local
mental health organizations from
dhss we invited a bunch of people and
the amendment that we crafted was a
joint project that everybody liked now
certain ones may not yet be ready to
endorse
it for the simple reason it does not yet
have a fiscal note it will when I I
talked to the budget people they said no
it's got to go through the process here
then should it pass here off it will go
to get a fiscal
note I have been I was actually called
by the governor remember she was a
attorney general and cares very much
about this issue she called me to say
we'll make it work financially we'll
figure it out so you don't have a fiscal
note you may not have a endorsement in
this hearing but I will tell you that
the amendment you're looking at is the
amendment all of the stakeholders worked
on
together and I'll be happy to take any
questions you might have questions for
this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you next I'm GNA call on I'm sorry
did you have a question I'm sorry it's
more of a procedural question for for
you I believe um since what's before us
right now is just the original bill
which has no content I'm wondering when
it would be appropriate to offer the
amendment well what what I I mean I was
I was going to ask I somebody on the
committee has to offer the amendment and
I was certainly prepared to do that but
if representative tur if you're prepared
to do
that once we hear the by leave Mr
chairman I asked him to do it because he
was on that committee oh oh that's fine
sure no no I would definitely um so we
will I mean we will get the amendment
before the committee for sure I just uh
we don't have to do that until we're
ready to exec but for sure that the
amendment we'll get before the uh we'll
get
before except Mr chair that if for
example there might be an opportunity to
um make improvements in the amendment
that might have come up since chairman
Pearson uh drafted this um wouldn't it
be helpful if it could be introduced
today by a member of the committee
and then perhaps even
addressed
and if there were to be changes those
could be proposed in time for an
ultimate executive session yeah no no
I'm sorry I I didn't I wasn't saying
that I I agree with what you're
suggesting all I'm saying is I would
rather I'd like to hear from the other
Witnesses um and then you know at at the
end of that well uh consider the
amendment for sure but I I I hear what
you're saying
um all right uh Stephen Enders
please good morning again my name is
Steven Andis I'm an assistant County
Attorney at the Marat County Attorney's
Office I've been a prosecutor for over
20 years I haven't seen the amendment
but I can certainly Echo the sentiment
that competency and restoration are
serious issues in New Hampshire and the
system we currently have in place
doesn't seem to be working at all
especially in terms of restoration and I
say that because there really is no
system in place for restoration so
something has to be done thank you all
right thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
next I'm going to call on Holly Stevens
please
hi good morning Justice Linton members
of the committee my name is Holly
Stevens I'm the director of public
policy in Nami New Hampshire the
National Alliance on Mental Illness Nami
New Hampshire is a nonprofit Grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide through
support advocacy and education um on
behalf of Nami
New Hampshire I'm here today to speak
not only in favor of house bu 480 but I
have seen the amendment so I am here to
speak in favor of the amendment as well
I um helped work on the amendment with
uh chairman Pearson um as you've heard
um New Hampshire lacks any formal
competency restoration program uh
currently and Nationwide about 81% of
individuals are restored and in
2019 we restored um 44% of our
folks if somebody is not restored within
a year those charges are then dropped
and as you heard chairman Pearson
mention that you know not only um are
you talking about the person who is um
on trial there in a lot of those cases
is somebody on the other side who may
have experienced a traumatic um crime
against them and they are not able to
receive clo Ure if the person is never
restored and additionally as you heard
the person may not get their day in
court which is a right for folks to be
able to go to court and defend
themselves and there are folks that
would like to be able to defend
themselves I mean a lot of people think
you know why would you want to be
restored it means you actually have to
go to trial well we heard from um a
psychologist Dr bomersbach um when this
committee was
uh contemplating House Bill 1020 last
year um and he mentioned that he works
for the office of Fric examiners and
there are folks that he has examined
that he believes might be able to
actually show that they are not guilty
and so being able to have your day in
court is really important for these
folks and without any kind of formal
competency restoration it's impossible
for them to do
that um in Nami New Hampshire's
experience um we've we've worked with a
lot of families who see this as a missed
opportunity they see that their loved
ones are brought into the justice system
and there is no treatment they're just
basically told go get restored and
they're on their own to do that we know
that there's a Workforce shortage here
there's a mental health crisis and folks
don't even know how to navigate the
system in order to be able to get
themselves services to even try to get
restored if they wanted
to um as a result of that folks end up
um again in the criminal justice system
they end up potentially homeless and um
have other negative
outcomes the legislative study committee
as you heard Le heard from a lot of
stakeholders including um attorney
Michael Grandy of the Attorney General's
office attorney gry reported to that
committee on the work of a competency
subcommittee of the governor's advisory
Commission on mental illness in the
correction system
he reported that the subcommittee Met
for over a year and although all the
members agreed that a forensic leaon
program was appropriate they could not
decide um or come to consensus on what
that should look like which is why um
Nami New Hampshire requested that study
committee um last year so that the
legislature could take a look at all of
it and they could make decisions about
what kind of a competency restoration
program we should have in the state of
New Hampshire
as you heard after the interim report
which had a lot of recommendations on it
I encourage all of you to take a look at
it one of those was the forensic leaz on
program um a group of stakeholders met
and um talked about a forensic liaison
program which
is the amendment that you see in front
of you that was the the work product
that came out of that the forensic leaon
under the pilot program would act as
intensive case managers link individuals
with Services they need to restore their
competency and to assist in reducing any
barriers to getting those services in
place when uh the legislative committee
study committee met they heard from Dr
Shannon Bader who was a forensic
psychologist who previously worked at
New Hampshire's office of forensic
examiners and she provided testimony
that in her
experience many individuals who raise
competency have psychotic symptoms who
once treated with antis psychotic
medications later have their competency
restored and that's why you know when we
looked at where this forensically aison
program should go um our recommendation
as na New Hampshire was the Department
of Health and Human Services because
largely a line share of these folks need
treatment um it's less less of them need
education about the legal system and
most of them need treatment a majority
of them I said have psychotic symptoms
and with the proper medication and the
proper mental health treatment they are
able to
re You Know M Ste I I don't mean to can
I just ask is it is as far as you know
based upon the testimony of the prior
witness and now um yourself is there any
is there any opposition to this it
sounds like you know I mean you you you
you've made a very persuasive you and
representative Pearson have made a very
persuasive case at least to me and I I'm
just wondering is there some it it's
about the money so I'm we're just trying
to you know I know that you are the
policy committee and I understand that
but eventually you're going to have to
vote on the money too so
um so that's why I and I just wanted to
just mention that um in the Senate
there's another companion bill to this
bill around um looking at some charges
that could be potentially dismissed if
the court um deemed um
it appropriate for violation level
offenses and low-level misdemeanors that
are of non the non-violent type um in
order to help facilitate because we've
found that people don't show up for that
initial forensic Le forensic examination
thus costing the state more money and so
the forensic Liaisons would be involved
when competency is raised not when
competency is not when they're found to
be not competent so that they could help
get them to that initial examination to
begin with and so just to wrap up for
those reasons we support the bill and we
support the amendment and we appreciate
your time and attention to this matter
thank you questions for this witness
thank you very much thank you next I'm
going to call on Cynthia babonis
thank you chair Lynn and members of the
committee for the record I am Cynthia
babonis legislative liaison and chief
Community integration officer for New
Hampshire hospital the Department of
Health and Human
Services um the department is providing
information today on HB 480 relative to
Restoration of Competency to stand trial
for criminal defendants the department
would like to thank sponsors of this
bill for their interest in addressing
options for those experiencing
behavioral health challenges in our
State many individuals who could be
impacted by this legislation are
currently served by the mental health
system including New Hampshire hospital
DHHS and New Hampshire hospital are
committed to minimizing justice system
response to people with mental illness
the department recognizes the importance
of HB 480 DHHS participated in the study
committee including the brainstorming of
conversations about the pilot
program we believe this is an important
time for stakeholders to come together
to to understand the resources
programmatic design and collaboration
necessary to advance any new model thank
you be happy to take any questions
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you uh Aon krian
please good afternoon Aon krian general
counsel for the judicial branch um I
compliment chairman Pearson because he
brings so many people together when he
works on an issue uh he was kind enough
to bring uh the judicial branch as well
as DHHS uh the governor's subcommittee
on competency a number of experts uh
different legislators to look at what
has been a long running and incal
intractable intractable problem uh in
New Hampshire uh which is uh which has
really sty the work of the governor
subcommittee I think they have really
struggled to to chart a particular path
forward on on improving competency
outcomes uh we do not have a formalized
competency restoration process in New
Hampshire there's a 12-month period
provided by Statute but not necessarily
a program there are other states that
have um either a department of forensic
Sciences or or a committed um part of
their DHHS which specifically works on
this issue that's that's just not
something that we have in New Hampshire
um the governor subcommittee did come to
a conclusion that a forensic liaison was
a first step toward moving forward even
then there was a robust debate about
what the duties and and and operations
of that person or that office should be
um through a lot of work by the
Legislative subcommittee members
including those present in this room um
and others working on this replace all
Amendment uh it does seem that there is
a potential pilot program that is a path
forward in what has been a very
difficult area um and I also have to
complement DHHS with the seriousness and
thoroughness which with which they have
looked at um assuming potentially a
little more responsibility in this area
to that has been so challenging um for
someone to to chart a path forward in I
I think that they have brought an
incredibly robust look at what they can
do and what they think they can improve
in the in the situation that is very
impressive to me and I think it will be
to you as well uh so I I wanted to take
any questions that you have about how
competency works now or any questions
you have about how it implements uh
within the judici to have this change um
but if you have no questions for me I'm
also happy to questions for this witness
seeing none all right uh I don't is
there anyone else who wishes to be heard
on h48 yes please did you fill out a pin
card ah come on come on or know you can
give it to yeah give it to
representative trip right there right
there there we go thank you
hi good morning everyone um my name is
Janelle llant I
am a prospective graduate student I've
been applying to PHD programs for
forensic psychology but I worked for
almost four years at the AA psychiatric
Institute and about a year and a half on
the forensic competency restoration unit
um and have done a fair amount of review
as it um pertains to the research
literature on competency restoration um
and I did want to speak to a
conversation I had with someone in
Colorado this morning um who and I want
to mention that Colorado was
specifically mentioned um Dr Sharon
Bader who's a friends of psychologist
here in New Hampshire um who testified
attorney Stevens men mentioned her um Dr
Bader had spoken to how Colorado
specifically has done some tremendous
work in the competency restoration space
and so I was very fortunate to connect
with someone who works for the Colorado
district court this morning and asked
him a few questions about competency
Restoration in Colorado
and what I would specifically like to
highlight to the committee is the um
kind of their equivalent of the forensic
wayon program there they have two um and
he very strongly spoke to the advantages
of having those staff and specifically
said um out of the two programs one of
them specifically that competency ra
restoration that it made all the
difference to have those essentially
Navigators um and helping to address the
underlying needs at some of these these
folks have um things like housing
getting a job addressing substance use
Mental Health um and was just very
strong about the difference that those
staff members made in the differences of
the lives of folks who are up for
competency restoration um so I
specifically wanted to highlight that
for the committee this morning all right
great questions for this witness seeing
none thank you very
much so um I know we we we're very short
on time we have to be over to the to the
state house but and I know that this
amendment that representative Pearson uh
prepared was was just recently
distributed however I've had a chance to
look at it I believe representative tur
has had a chance to look at
it it seems like this is something that
has been very thoroughly vetted by
representative Pearson and the and the
working group um and I think that there
is some there is an interest not only
for the people who for represented
Pearson and his group but I would
suggest it's also an an our interest to
try to get as many matters out of the
way and moved on because this will end
up going to finance at some point as
possible
so I guess I'm I would propose to exec
this now I would I I would propose to
have representative
tur move the amendment and then then
exect this now uh but if there's again
I'm not going to do it if people have a
problem with
yeah thank you chairman Lynn since this
is my first term on Judiciary this is a
subject that I'm not overly familiar
with and I would be more comfortable
voting once I have a little more time to
vet this issue nope NOP no problem no
that's a re very reasonable request no
problem yes representative Manos I just
wanted to ask a question about the lack
of fiscal note and how that gets how
that gets dealt with or impacts us
that's that's that I'm I'm I'm a little
bit curious about that myself
representative Pearson but uh oh oh well
representative Smith you want to do
it I I I share that thought but I called
the budget people and they said we've
got a hearing on the 28th and there
isn't a fiscal note and I want one and
they said ' have you ever done this
before and I said ' no and they said
some other things that were encouraging
but they said it has to come out of here
and then they'll do a fiscal note and
then it will come back to the house with
it I do not understand how they work I
am just told they are not going to do it
until it comes out of here so you know I
just just should know I I had thought
until I just looked up the schedule I
got from Paul this is not listed as an
early bill it's not listed as an early
bill so I you
know as I say I I don't may represent
Smith can you ask can you put any more
uh give us any more information on this
well I I think I can um in fact they
cannot do a fiscal note on it until
it's it's gone the next step and that is
the routine would be if we accept the
amendment and passed the bill as amended
it would then generate a fiscal note um
that would not change the status of the
bill it's not still not an early
bill um I uh they will go and do the
fiscal note meanwhile there are a couple
of other things that will happen the
first thing that will happen is if this
bill then passes the house as it is this
you know the fiscal note may or may not
be ready it doesn't make any difference
because for those of you who are paying
attention there's almost no chance that
any new money is going to be identified
in the house so it's irrelevant um it
will however have a fison on on it by
the time it goes to the Senate and then
the Senate can add it
to um uh to the budget Bill uh which is
what's going to have to happen not
adding it to this bill but to the budget
bill and the other thing that can happen
is um because of chairman Pearson's
great skill and chairman Lynn's great
skill um if we get it through the house
um early enough chairman Lynn and
chairman PE will talk
to um let's see that would be chair well
it's confusing it will be
either either uh Maguire or Edwards
depending on whether it's going to go to
division no it won't go to division one
because it won't go to Judiciary it will
go to division three Edwards and they on
their own can put it in so we don't have
to worry about it in other words we have
to worry about the policy and it's up to
um the finance committee to make it work
or not and they're going to have a hard
time making it work but they might very
well particularly if it's not an
enormous cost chairman Pearson has
already had lengthy conversations with
uh Finance 3 representative wer and with
Finance chairman W uh Edwards and
chairman Wier have had these
conversations all right thank you all
right so I guess what I would say then
is um it I we won't exec this today but
this might be one of the bills U that
you consider during the time I'm away
exec because it sounds like I mean once
representative Pell has had a chance to
familiarize herself with it and the rest
of and it'll give everyone else a chance
to look at the amendment more carefully
I don't we could even do it on Monday
well that's possible we might even be
able to do it on Monday that's a like
that's that's a very good point anyway
um I I think that this would be
something that it would be in everyone's
to try to get this down move this down
the road and uh maybe we can do that
maybe we can do it on Monday um with
that um I'm going to recess
uh
oh so yeah so
um yeah so I I I guess sure do we not
introduce the amendment when we're
voting on the bill or do we this is
testimony right now until we adopt the
amendment when we vote on it right so
you know I think I think technically
correct me if I'm wrong representative
Smith I should open a brief executive
session to allow representative tur to
introduce the amendment I'll second it
then I'll recess the executive session
um uh until you closed have you closed
the area I I don't think I have closed
hear no I don't think that I think I
don't we have to do that
main amendment I think that as long as
the hearing still open representative T
can now introduce this amendment we okay
so we don't have to go to any executive
session all right no that's fine I
recognize I recognize representative tur
thank you Mr chairman um I'd like to
move uh Amendment 202 introdu we're not
voting on it you're introducing okay I
am I am stand correct to that mean no I
appreciate yes you did
uh I I'd like to introduce uh Amendment
61h um to the Judiciary
Committee all right so that all right so
the yes the the amendment has been
introduced and it's before us and we
will deal with it as quickly as possible
hopefully we'll be able to do it Monday
although we have you know a full day of
hearings on Monday but anyway so now I'm
going to recess the hearing on this bill
and um I will see everyone on this
committee um in 40 minutes over in the
in ref's
hall for those for those of you who have
have not ever had The Misfortune of
having
to
e
e e
live and I'm going to call the Judiciary
Committee to and I am going to open the
hearing on House Bill 254 FN and I'm
going to recognize Representative Bob
Lynn to introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee U my name is uh Bob Lyn
I'm representative excuse me from Windam
and I'm here uh as a prime sponsor of
House Bill
254 um this is a bill um that has been
has been named as the end of life
Freedom Act and I think that that is an
appropriate name because what it really
is about is giving people at the end of
their life the freedom to end their life
in a dignified way rather than endure
continually suffering this is a bill
that was this is basically the same bill
as was introduced last year um and pass
the house on a bipartisan basis I say
you know I'm I I always believe in in
just laying my cards on the table last
year it passed on the bipartisan basis
candidly it had although it had
significant support on my side of the
aisle it had less support on my side of
the aisle than it did on the other side
of the aisle and there was some
significant opposition on the other side
of the aisle also so it's fair to say
that this is a the bill passed on a
bipartisan basis and was also opposed on
a bipartisan basis I hope that this
committee and eventually the H the Full
House will once again pass this bill
because I believe it is the right thing
to do it provides for as I said before
Freedom that's to me what this bill is
is really all about it says that if you
are a person that is within 6 months of
dying and represent I thank
representative Perez for just pointing
out to
me you should not just as a to clarify a
PO point the bill says that you are as
one of the provisions you either within
six you have been diagnosed to be within
six months of death or in medically
certified
hospice medically certified hospice does
do mean you're within 6 months of death
you may be in hospice for longer than
that that is not medically certified but
medically certified hospices within six
months of death this bill has a great
many protective features it requires
that two doctors independently certify
that you meet all
of for lack of a better term the the the
requirements that we might all think of
you would have to you would have to meet
that you are competent to make a
decision that you really are uh you know
within 6 months of death that you're
competent to make a decision that you
understand that you don't have to make
this decision that it's completely up to
you um that you are that you are um you
have the mental capacity to make the
decision and if there's any question
about things like mental capacity
there's a a provision in the bill that
that allows um for a referral to a
mental health professional who will
again review the matter and make sure
that um that in fact you meet all the
requirements
so I think if you look through the bill
you will see that it has a tremendous
number of appropriate protections to
ensure that people are not are not taken
advantage of um and it's it
it seems to me that it really does make
um a lot of sense if you believe as I do
in Freedom and that people should not be
uh at the you know in the very last days
of their life that they should not have
to endure un uh unnecessary suffering as
I mentioned La you know last I pulled
out my speech on the house floor last
year when I said I'm 74 years old well
now I'm 75 years
old fortunately I'm INR relatively good
health but you know I know that I'm I'm
in the Autumn of my life uh that I hope
you know I hope I have many years to go
but uh at 75 uh I'm certainly not a
spring chicken and I guess what I would
want to say is I believe that if the
time comes that I am within six months
of death and I'm suffering that I ought
to have the I ought to have the
opportunity to end my life with dignity
and you know as I think about it just as
I stand here now I don't know if I would
ever actually do it you know I I love
life I love my life I love my family my
wife and my children and you know my
family I love I love frankly being in
this legislature and the thought that I
would actually do that um it would have
to take an awful lot for me to do that
but I think that if when the if the End
come is coming and I'm in you know
really in great pain or distress that I
ought to have that op that option to
make that choice and I think all of you
in this room and in our state ought to
have that option also and I know that
there are people who have really you
know strong religious views to the
contrary and I respect your
views I guess what I would say to that
to those of you who do have those views
is I don't want to interfere with your
religious views those are your views and
that's that's fine with me but I hope
that you would do me the the you know
reciprocal respect of saying that that
if I don't share those views that I
ought to have the right to make that
decision
um I want to
emphasize as I I think we've heard to at
Great length during the last during last
year's hearing the evidence the the
surveys have shown that a majority of
New Hampshire residents I believe it's
over 70% including a majority of
Republicans believe that that that uh in
this principle of allowing people to to
uh to have the option of Medical Aid and
dying when they're at the end um
interestingly you know I still quite
don't quite understand this the survey
apparently asked gun owners and they and
the the majority felt that uh that that
that this bill was appropriate now why
they asked gun owners to be honest with
you I'm not quite sure why they did that
what exactly it's got to do with with
this issue but they did and I'm one of
the gun owners I was shooting last
night in nashille at a uh where I always
shoot on Tuesday nights um so I'm a I'm
one of those gun owners and I guess I
you know I guess I speak for the
majority of gun owners according to this
survey um I want to just and I don't
want to go on for forever I want to
emphasize sort of two points that I
think are important to consider one is
there's this argument that is made that
well this will be subject to abuse that
you know people and it probably would
generally be older people uh people that
you know people obviously elderly people
are the ones most likely to be affected
by this that they will be abused and
that relatives or the Health Care system
will you know will will sort of try to
coers them into doing this and look can
I say that will never happen no of
course I can't say that that will never
happen but you know we have very strong
procedures in this bill including
criminal penalties um uh Etc to prevent
that from happening and I I guess what I
would say is you know there in the in
the whole area of estate and Trust law
um there's this same kind of issue you
know that somehow you know a potential
beneficiary or an heir will coer
somebody to uh uh leave the leave the
estate to them or whatever the case law
if the casebooks are full of cases about
that kind of thing happening but we
don't say that you know we're not we're
going to sort of do away with the Trust
In the state law because sometimes there
are abuses I think we say that mostly um
the law works pretty well and that when
there are abuses there are remedies in
the law to take care of those abuses and
that's the that's the same that is true
here the the broader the other issue
that is often raised in opposition to
this is really and I and I hope you'll
as you listen the members of the
committee as you listen to the testimony
on this you will ask yourself are people
objecting to the terms of this bill or
they are they expressing concern about
something that might happen not under
this bill but something in the future
that um you know that that the law will
be it will be amended and change to make
it broader than it is right now well
members of the committee and members of
the leg understand that that's in your
hands that I don't think that you need
to be afraid afraid of yourselves afraid
that you might you know be persuaded to
to go too far I'm not afraid of that
that you will go too far and I'm
certainly not you know sure that I'm not
going to go too far I guess the analogy
that I would draw in this whole area is
this you know if you give people the
right to freedom of speech some people
will yell fire in a crowded
theater if you give people the right to
have to to have firearms in in defense
of themselves and others some people
will use the firearm to hurt somebody
unlawfully if you give people the right
to privacy in their own homes under the
Fourth Amendment privacy in their own
own homes some people will use the
privacy of their homes to store drugs or
or other elements of of
crime but we don't say that because
those possible things could happen that
we're when we should do away with the
First Amendment or do away with the
Second Amendment or do away with the
Fourth Amendment and that's the
situation here it seems I I submit to
you we in the legislature draw lines
that's what we do every day and we can
draw the lines here properly and I
submit to you respectfully that that's
what this bill does so for those reasons
I hope that this committee will support
the bill and I'm happy to answer any
questions are there any questions of
this
witness representative
Perez thank you thank you for taking my
question I do um have a lot of questions
about this bill it is the same bill that
was put in last year exactly the same
bill except for two changes in names and
adding hospice to it and I have some of
the same concerns that I had last year
so under qualified by specialty or
experience does that there is nothing in
this bill that says the person who has
been treating me through my terminal
illness is involved at all is and what
concerns me and you say qualified by
specialty does that mean that one of the
people certifying
my my availability to take my life if I
have cancer it has to be an
oncologist or if I'm in renal kidney
failure and I'm dying from that does
that mean one of the people that has
to certify my ability for this be a uh
um a neurologist or if I have ALS does
that mean that a neurologist has to be
there's nothing in here that says that
so basically it's my understanding and
correct me if I'm wrong but I could go
to my primary care physician who has
sent me to a neurologist or a
neurologist or an oncologist or some
other uh somebody else's family practice
and that person could certify me because
there's nothing in here that says the
Doctor Who has been treating me has to
be involved but in order to be in
hospice your treating doctor has to be
involved can you answer that so I I I
think the answer to your question is
that you're you are right in this sense
it doesn't require that it be your sort
of longtime treating physician and I
think the what what it does require is
that both of the people who make the
diagnosis that you are that that you
meet all the criteria including the
being within six months of death have to
be qualified to do that they and so and
it seems to me that the the answer to
your question is
I I think that it's entirely appropriate
the way it is worded because I I think
one of the things that we do not want to
have happen is if my treating physician
that I've treated for a long time if if
that person you know doesn't believe in
the in in Medical Aid in dying and
therefore wouldn't be willing to certify
because they they don't believe in it
and by the way there is a provision here
that says you you know gives people the
right to have have that doctors the
right to have make that decision but it
but it also says and I think
appropriately if if my treating
physician has to happens to be one of
those doctors who doesn't believe in
Medical Aid and dying that shouldn't
mean that I'm that you know that's that
binds me I should be able to go to
another physician who might be a new
physician for me but does believe in
that and as long as they're able to say
yes I've examined Lynn and he is within
6 months of dying he does know what he's
doing and he believe you know and and he
wants this to be done and the other
conditions are met he should be able to
do this so I think the answer to your
question is yes but there's a good
reason for not requiring that follow
up follow
up the other term in here I won't go on
with a 50 times but other term in here
is you use Healthcare entity um I did
look up as I did last year and a weight
loss clinic and a medical spa are both
considered Health Care entities I'm
sorry I didn't hear the first part of
what a weight loss clinic right run by a
physician yeah and a medical spa run by
a physician are both
considered Health Care entities the term
that you use here is there anything
stopping a weight loss clinic to have a
sidebar of of
issuing medical right and dying there's
no provision for that I think I think
the law I think the bill says that they
have to be qualified by by experience
and uh and qualific qualifications to
make the diagnosis now if there is a uh
a weight loss clinic the doctors of whom
you know can can make that diagnosis and
can go before the medical board and just
ify that they're in qualified to make
that diagnosis I suppose they could do
that I you know if I were running a
weight loss clinic and I had never um uh
been diagnosing somebody as to whether
they're within six months of death I
think I'd be um I'd be a little bit
worried about what the medical board
might say about my deciding that you
know you or I or whoever was was met the
criteria follow up thank you any other
questions for the speaker representative
P
pel thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Lynn for taking my
question I had this exact same um
question last year on the bill so on
page nine line eight um Roman numeral to
If you're looking at it when a death has
occurred in accordance with this chapter
the Death Shall be attributed to the
underlying terminal disease now say for
example I have a heart condition and
driving my car at 100 miles an hour and
I crash it into a tree and I die what
would the cause of death be if you had a
heart condition and you and you drove
into a tree and and you and you died I
mean I I think it would probably it
would probably be that an accident but
contributed to by by um by the heart
condition I mean I I you know to be
honest with you and how a doctor would
would diagnose that circumstance I don't
know I would assume they'd have to make
reference to both conditions
followup one
followup so he somebody has okay let's
make it let's as phrase that differently
um somebody's being treated for cancer
right and they in a car accident and
they die right what's the underlying
what is
the what is the ca I asked the first
question incorrectly what is the cause
of death in that situation so again I
think if if if I was diagnosed with
cancer tomorrow and the doctor told me I
have you know six months or a year to
live and I was in a car accident
tomorrow afternoon I assume the cause of
death would be the car accident but if I
was diagnosed with cancer three years
ago and I was getting you know and the
doctor said you've got a couple of days
to live and I was in a car accident and
there was some SU suggestion that the
cancer had caused me to lose my ability
to drive the car I would think that a
doctor and they assuming they could
determine that that they would say that
both of those things contributed to the
death so that I mean that's I guess that
would be my answer to that question
thank
you there any other
questions I'm gonna we have a lot of
people to get through if you have
comments to make or you want to um
all right I'm going to give you one
opportunity just but ask a question
please thank you thanks for taking my
question do you have any concern where
there is no residency requirement on
this that we won't have people I'm going
to backtrack when I was a teenager
abortions were not legal anywhere in the
United States I had wealthy friends
whose parents took them to
England uh for
abortions I'm telling you no residence
requirement do you have any concern
about people coming here over the Border
like people here now are going to um
Vermont for this for this I I you know I
don't I I mean I guess the you know if
the the argument apparently is New
Hampshire will become what the the death
State people you know I I guess I I
really want I haven't heard don't get me
wrong speaking personally and from my
philosop I have a a lot of problems with
the way they do things in Vermont on a
lot of on a lot of issues but one of
them is not this I have not heard people
say you know for and I guess Maine has
it too I haven't I haven't heard people
say oh you know don't go to Vermont or
don't go to Maine because that's a place
where you can go to end your life that
that um I you know I guess I would not
have I don't think that it would be
detrimental to New Hampshire's
reputation in any way to say New
Hampshire is one of the states where you
can come to die with dignity I'll I'll
I'll I'll run the risk that of
that representative
Morton yes so I want to follow up with
uh thank you for the question by the way
uh with what um representative Pell was
going with there uh if you follow that
further down it talks about death
following uh admin self-administering
medic ations does not constitute grounds
for postmortem
inquiry um and going back to it's the
death is attributed to the underlying
terminal disease this kind of reminds me
of what happened a few years ago with
there was people dying in car accidents
but their death was listed as covid
death right they didn't die of Co they
died of Smashing you a tree at 90 M hour
it but it was listed a covid death or a
motorcycle accident right and based on
what you're saying here
if it's listed under the underlying
there needs to be a question here the
the the question here is how would that
not skew statistics going forward as to
how many people actually die of a
particular cause of death when they're
not actually dying from that cause
they're dying from assisted
suicide well I guess what I see I'm not
I'm not sure that I that I draw the I'm
not sure the analogy you drew is an
accurate analogy because if if it's
correct that you have that you within 6
months of
death and and all of the other criterias
are met I
mean you
are you're going to die within six
months anyway and I guess I don't see
what the um what I think what this is
designed to prevent is to have you know
sort of the um
the the the to the extent that there's a
reputational issue of per the person
well the the person that the person
committed suicide I mean I guess that
would be what the what the um what the
issue would be but why I mean isn't the
person going to die anyway and and not
you know someday but very soon so so is
a followup no hold
on do I do you want to follow up because
it has be a question here not a comment
you have an actual question no a
followup but is it a question or just a
comment well I I guess it' be a question
to what he just said so I'm going to
allow but make it quick because we have
to we have a lot of people that want to
speak so so as a followup um my aunt uh
was in the hospice she was told she had
a few months left to die she had bone
cancer and lived for 2 years so who
decides that somebody only has 6 months
to die and how how do we make sure that
that determination is is solid I guess
what I would say is we have two doctors
that are charged with making that
decision and again you know if your
question is could the doctors be wrong
could there could two doctors say the
person's going to die in six months and
it's not actually true sure I think you
know am I saying that that could there
could never be um you know there could
never be a two mistaken diagnosis I'm
not saying that but it seems to me that
the the chances of that are relatively
slim and I would also think I have to
add I would also think that if you're
one of the people that you know they
said you have six months to live and you
know you're you're you're getting close
to the six to the six months and you're
you know you're not feeling great but
you don't feel like you know I'm taking
my last breath tomorrow I would suspect
you're probably not going to use the
medication I C I certainly
wouldn't thank you
um thank you this is um oh for this is a
question for the for the sponsor um some
of these issues um Fallin the purview of
the uh vital I guess the Department of
Vital Records which is part of the
Secretary of State's office and I don't
see anybody from there in the medical
inspector's office but uh did you did
you I did you consult with these while
drafting the bill which I may not be
surprised if you didn't but um so you
any see input what like uh the experts
on this particular part of the larger
issue uh think about
this the answer to your question is I
did not do that consultation I suspect
that there will be people here that will
testify after me that can answer that
question more you know with more
knowledge than I than I can thank you
are there any other questions seeing
none thank you thank
you we have a lot of cards to get
through here so unfortunately other than
the prime sponsor I'm going to have to
limmit your testimony to 3 minutes and
it's going to have to be a strict 3
minute uh limit um if you have questions
and it's an actual question not
commentary I will you can ask the
questions I'll I'll recognize you but we
have an opportunity to give our personal
opinions on this bill during executive
session so in the essence of time if you
have a question by all means ask it but
limit it to a question and I'm probably
not going to have
follow-ups representative
Woodcock thank you Mr chairman and uh I
will stay with my uh notes uh so I won't
go off task um the Medical Aid dying
bill is not about your personal
philosophical political party or even
your religious doctor in a sect it's
about Freedom of Choice unlike some
folks position between pro-life and
pro-choice this is not a decision about
The Unborn this is a decision made by a
adult who lives in New Hampshire at this
point or may be here as a resident and
makes a choice of what they want to do
and how they want to pass this isn't a
willy-nilly decision or made on a whim
as representative Lynn pointed out this
is a very limited restrictive option of
a fully competent adult this is not nor
can it be a a decision of someone who is
deficient and mental capacity let me
provide a quick point of context when I
was in high school my mother had a
stroke as a very vibrant and young nurse
they said she would not live
long it was then in 1978 13 years later
that she passed would she have been a
candidate for this absolutely not my
mother-in-law a widow Social Security
social school secretary an activist in
the community and a heavy smoker began
her decline respiratory failure was in
the hospital by her 70s by 72 she was in
the hospital so much they never let her
out she was on IVs respirators full
force feeding Force to feeding etc etc
etc and time I won't go any further
would she been a candidate for this
probably not because she couldn't meet
the restrictions of this bill because
she could not do it herself she could
not make that
decision finally the reason for my
passion for this bill my brother 64240
PB college football player Adventurer
hiker lover of the White Mountains for
Appalachian Gun Club hutman crazy guy I
love to be a smoke jumper and jump out
of
planes finally train get had heart
disease finally transferred to Albany
who became another outside Hunter guy
and then he came back after the alanes
and retired to New York to Village of
Scarsdale when he retired he said I want
to move to the adex so I can finish my
outdoor adventure active life but his
hot began declin he had to use a
quadible bypass he went through all that
one to another he had the last possible
suggestion in elad and he said to me
Steve you are my medical proxy and this
is what I want this is how I want to
pass but the elad for those you who are
lay reason L lay folks like myself
basically means there a battery charger
and you're hot just keeps going you
carry battery pack and keeps going you s
the battery he's done so at the end he
had hide issues in aronx New York we
moved him to Vermont because only two
hospitals will treat this went from
Vermont
he said no more took him down to Mass
General Hospital the only other one Mass
General said I'm sorry Pete there's no
more we can do for you but there's
nothing we Sorry representative your
time is up if you can close one sentence
and just close
it
okay I'll get the my one
sentence I would like to present the
final closing this is simply an en
abling
legislation as you supported many many
times if it was City or towns this just
allows a competent adult to make their
own decision thank you if you have
written testimony you can turn that into
the clerk if you would if you wish thank
you representative
Burton representative
Burton okay and after will be
representative uh Damon you'll be next
uh good afternoon I'm Wayne Burton
representing Durham district
10 and I've been editing my speech down
to get under your three minutes was it
three minutes three
minutes thank you Mr chairman and
members of the Judiciary Committee I
wish to convey my strong support for
House Bill 254 the Endo light freedom
act a bill whose Time Has
Come excuse
me in 20 2023 my very best friend was
the first mayor to end his life under
that State's death With Dignity law
which he strongly supported leading the
effort to achieve its successful
passage Rob and I were very close
lifelong friends so decision to end his
life with dignity he deserved and wanted
a decision that I
supported it sens by a column by a
religious person and an editorial andion
leader critical of those favoring a
similar bill in New Hampshire a few
years ago I emailed a note to the paper
in support of that bill which to my
surprise they published as an oped piece
it's a fairly short piece I'd like to
read into the public record than answer
any questions
in the fall of 2013 a longtime close
friend a main resident told me and
others in his large circle of friends
and family that he planned to end his
own life at a date certain under Main's
successful death With Dignity law that
house built to 54 mirrors like me he was
a Vietnam veteran and SilverStar
awarde who had had led a marine platoon
in an area DST in agent orange during
the war we helped him through a year of
radiation and chemotherapy which did
little good the rabbit cancer
metastasizing into his bones late in the
summer of that year nothing worked just
doctors lamented because agent orange
induced cancer unlike others was somehow
impervious to Conventional treatments
and my friend would suffer severe pain
for the rest of his foreshortened life
he broke his hip in October
2019 as the cancer shredded his bones
his remaining strength and indomitable
Spirit caused him to fight his cancer
the only way he could making the
decision to take his own life before the
cancer did save his strength and family
the torture of watching him die slowly
in ever increasing
Agony who was in a better position to
make that decision my friend or the
editorial editor for the Manchester
Union leader in the February 23rd 201 19
guest column he s sarcastically titled
should we not be doing everything we
can well he said they quote they should
we not be doing anything we can to
support such person and having the I'm
sorry representative that's your time if
you want to read a sentence to close it
with yes thank
you the union leader the Catholic church
and others who sanctimony support in
human suffering at life's end might hike
of Mile in my friend's boots he spent
his professional Life Counseling kids
and especially other veterans in trouble
with compassion and kindness he deserve
no less thank you for listening I'm
happy to take any questions and I I will
submit my complete text other any
questions nothing thank you thank
you so again I apologize for the limit
on this but if you do have written
testimony we can email it to us or you
can deliver it to us down here we'll
certainly take it
representative uh hope
Damon good afternoon thank you Mr chair
and committee I'm state representative
hope Damon Sullivan District
8 I vigorously support this law or this
proposed law last
spring we lost our friend
Michael and we sadly and joyfully
celebrate the loss that he was ble to
choose to end his life on the terms that
were right for him and save his family
from watching a heart-wrenchingly sad
decline Michael died in
Switzerland with his family around
him I want everyone to have the
opportunity should they so choose to
make that choice and not need to have
the resources to go to Switzerland thank
you for your careful consideration of
this moral and right bill
representative
Perez oh she oh she can't
testif representa
perz right yes I I think I think uh
representative pel is correct if you
already asked questions you can't
testify
then I can't testify that's
how are you really going to deny me
testifying I'm not I'm but that that's
the rule that's the rule so hang on I've
been here for two years I've never heard
that I asked questions last time and
testified
too I will ask the house clerk to
clarify yeah we I'll call you again as
soon as we get an answer
Sam
Safford and that will be followed
by is it Ben
saford yes I have one for Lori as well
so if there three of you want to come
down
yeah I've already
I can't
see good
afternoon thank you good afternoon my
name is Samuel Stafford I'm from pelum
New Hampshire at age 4 I was diagnosed
with a rare genetic defect called dued
muscular distrophy it is fatal and there
is no
cure the doctors told my parents that my
brother and I would not live long enough
to graduate high school never mind go to
a college or get a job but they were
wrong my life has not been easy my
father passed away when I was 13 I was
only kid in a wheelchair in high school
I was sad lonely and
depressed back in 20 2021 after a
hospital stay I was diagnosed with a
brain bacteria called Bartonella this
illness is an opportunistic pathogen
from a tick or flea bite it causes brain
inflammation and it gave me many
psychiatric
issues uh my physical disability was
nothing compared to
it the symptoms of this illness were
unbearable my depression turned into
Despair and I began waking up every
morning wanting to Die the Suicidal
Thoughts became too much for me if
assistant suicide had been legal when I
was in the depths of my
despair it would it would have seemed
like the best option it would have been
a permanent solution to what I felt like
permanent
pain fortunately I had a strong advocate
in my mother who instead found me help
and support from a counselor and a
homeopathic
doctor four years later I can say that I
am well and enjoy a rich and Abundant
Life I'm a member of a Toast Masters
group and I enjoy giving speeches I'm a
writer singer and artist and I'm active
in my community my life has value and
dignity in my living I urge you to
oppose this bill the medical community
and insurance companies will only use it
to end the lives of people like me
instead let's provide Compassionate Care
no matter how you look at it there's no
dignity in suicide thank you for your
time thank
you Ben saford
it's
good chairman ly and house Judiciary
Committee members my name is Benjamin
Safford I live in pelum I'm 28 years old
and I live with the fatal disease with
no cure called Duan muscular distrophy
I am here to oppose a bill that
threatens my very existence HB 254
promotes an ignorant ableist worldview
and is offensive to myself and the
disability Community as a whole all
national disability organizations and
those based here in New Hampshire oppose
this cruel
legislation they recognize as do I that
bills like this oress people like me and
discourage medical professionals from
treating us with dignity and Equity able
individuals are encouraged to seek
Mental Health and Pain Management while
those with disabilities like me are
often encouraged just to end it all this
build doubles down on these ableist
attitudes great strength and courage are
shown by those who chose to continue
living despite chronic and debilitating
physical mental and emotional pain and
suffering
more energy should be spent by the state
to support these courageous
individuals I am tired of living in a
world where people with disabilities are
isolated and pushed to the outskirts of
society Health and Human Services and
Medicaid are a huge part of our state's
budget it is my really not fear but
concern that this bill will be used to
limit medical treatment and services to
people like me respectfully the sponsors
of this bill fail to recognize the
dangerous precedent this bill sets for
the treatment of my
community thank
you Lori Stafford
I handed in my testimony and I'm going
to um read my
daughters my name is Lydia Safford and
although I am not able to be here in
person because I am working in the
disability community at my job I thank
my mother for reading what I wrote I am
a 25-year-old woman artist disability
Advocate sibling to Two Brothers others
who have disabilities and a career
resource specialist my job is to help
all people including people with
disabilities find meaningful work not
only find meaningful work but together
change the world of work by challenging
World Views and subconscious biases by
showing that all people can work life
does not end when you are diagnosed with
a disability chronic disease or mental
health illness in fact it truly begins
because you then learn just how valuable
life is I do not have a disability but I
have struggled with depression anxiety
and suicidal ideation for 13
years there have been moments and there
still are moments where I feel that the
world would be better off without me I
think back to my junior year of college
when I was struggling so heavily with
suicidal thoughts that I called my mom
crying like a baby because I felt
completely hopeless to emphasize just
how much I was suffering I hardly ever
open up to my mom about these
things I have wanted to take my life
many times but I fully believe that the
moment I did I would regret it if I had
taken my life in that empty student
apartment I would have missed out on
graduating college College meeting the
love of my life and learning how to use
coping skills to manage my anxiety and
depression I would have missed out on
meeting people who have completely
changed my life I believe that passing
this assisted suicide bill would be
dangerous not only for myself and those
who struggle with mental health but for
the disability Community it would not
only put these groups in danger but
reinforce the idea that people with
disabilities have no value and are
better off dead just because life is
hard does not mean it is not worth
living living with depression and
anxiety is hard but it does not mean
life is not worth living watching my two
older brothers battle with lose their
battle with duchan musu aistrop is hard
but it does not mean that life is not
worth living disability has made my life
harder but it is the greatest gift that
I have been given in this life I
wholeheartedly believe that passing this
bill would encourage people to view
disability as a problem to erase instead
of recognizing the invaluable
perspectives and blessings that come
with it please vote no on HB 254 thank
you thank you
Mary
fahe followed by Laura Allison you'll be
next good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the Judiciary Committee my
name is Mary fahe and I'm here
representing Cornerstone in opposition
to HP
254 I'm also here today as someone who
suffers from five incurable diseases and
as the Survivor of a teen suicide
attempt and strong suicidal
ideation while I have gotten the help I
need to learn to live happily with
chronic and life-altering disease it has
been one of the hardest tasks of my life
when I was 21 years old I was
misdiagnosed with treatment resistant
bipolar disorder shortly after I read a
headline describing Canada's upcoming
expansion of assisted suicide to include
mental illnesses such as bipolar
disorder at the time I wish that we had
that option in America that there was an
easy way out to my suffering the mere
knowledge of this legislation existing
in other countries nearly led me to a
second attempt you may hear supporters
of this bill assert that assisted
suicide is not actually suicide because
those who utilize it do not wish to die
and those who end their lives by Suicide
do wish to die and therefore puts no one
at risk I find this claim to be
incredibly false when I attempted
suicide I did not wish to die rather I
desperately wish to live I simply saw no
alternative to the mental and physical
suffering I was experiencing HB 254
affirms this option it asserts that
intentionally and unnaturally ending
one's life in the face of suffering is a
legitimate decision it puts countless
New Hampshire young people like myself
at risk by normalizing Suicide as an
acceptable solution to one's
burdens we strive to prent prevent
suicide and healthy individuals because
of the knowledge that their lives have
inherent and immeasurable value it is
not our place to remove that value
simply because a life however short is
plagued by
illness due to my health conditions I no
longer remember what it is like to not
live in pain yet that pain does not mean
that my life or lives like it are any
less worth living when the proponents of
this bill state that it is not only
permissible but dignified to take one's
life when confronting great illness it
undermines the efforts of all those like
myself who have fought so hard to live
in the face of grave and often silent
suffering the majority of young people I
know have struggled with suicidal
ideation some of my friends have lost
their lives in that struggle if
legislation like this existed in New
Hampshire several years ago I might not
be here today New Hampshire sure
Citizens need Suicide Prevention not
promotion we need to be told that
contrary to the message of this bill our
suffering does not define us our lives
however difficult however limited are
worth living and celebrating thank you
for hearing my testimony and I urge you
to please vote itl and HP
254 will you take a question sure
representative Perez thank you thanks
for taking my question um last year we
heard many young people concerned that
the passing of this bill would justify
young people who um are suffering from
um severe depression and feel that that
is a terminal illness that this would
legitimize them take in your life do you
feel that that is a possibility I do
absolutely um given that I was in that
position myself and just knowing about
this legislation and similar legislation
expanded in other countries nearly led
me to attempt to end my life as time I
absolutely believe that that could be
the case thank
you thank you Laura
Allison good afternoon thank you for the
opportunity to testify my name is Laura
alasam and I'm from London Derry excuse
my reading I want to keep this short uh
this bill I urge you to vote against
this bill
itl it does nothing to determine whether
an individual may take his or her own
life rather it attempts to exercise the
power of the state to legitimize The
Taking of Life thereby implicating all
of society in the Judgment that some
lives are devoid of human dignity even
worthless we do not need to walk down
this dark road to see where it leads we
need only look to Canada where Medical
Aid in dying has metastasized at a rate
of 30% a year-over year for most years
since it was legalized in
2016 I'm providing testimony about the
latest official update which was
published in December of
2024 the Canadian experiment illustrates
that death once state approved as a
solution inevitably becomes a duty
especially for the poor the mentally
challenged and the
lonely just one other note in Oregon
where assisted suicide has been legal
for 27 years a recent NIH study shows
that pain and the fear of pain don't
even make the top five reasons for
choosing assisted death I urge you
please for the good of everyone facing
natural death or God forbid
contemplating suicide to focus on
paliative Care Mental Health Care
accompaniment and encouragement for
those in this predicament thank
you thank
you representative visard bman
after that will be Rebecca Brown go
ahead I'm sorry no that's okay I was
adjusting the mic because I'm short um
thank you for hearing me today thank you
to the committee my name is Paige bman I
represent Hillsboro 3 and I represent
NASA Ward 4 within Hillsboro 3 I am a
registered nurse I specialize in mental
health as well as Health Equity I would
like to put out there my specialty is
Maternal Child Health but as a nurse I
do have the background I think in these
spaces that um I can provide some
important information um first of all I
do believe this is a body autonomy bill
and I believe throughout medicine we
should be able to make decisions about
our own bodies taking away that right in
any instance is taking away our rights
and runs against how we practice
medicine in every other instance I'd
also like to speak to the um to the idea
that this would legitimize or send a
message that suicide is okay I have been
working like I said on decrease in
mental health and I work in the area of
Suicide Prevention in some of the work
that I do this is actually a
misconception that we have long been
fighting and in fact in medical spaces
we are taught when we are assessing for
suicidal ideation meaning the thought
that somebody might want to commit
suicide that we should be very direct
and that we should speak about it we
know over and over that bringing up the
issue and talking about it yes people
might think about it but it does not
increase the instances of actual suicide
it does not increase the risk that is a
misconception um in terms of Health
Equity I would like to say that I have
been working on uh building Health
Equity programs I'm very familiar with
groups who are um who who end up with
health discrepancies um and I am very
sensitive to that unfortunately I see
that everywhere in medicine there is not
one area of medicine where people are
not affected in different ways because
of their identity group my this is my
biggest um uh point of contention with
this is that we don't withhold
appropriate care
because it doesn't work for everyone
this is not the correct Avenue for that
we should be doing for instance we
should do we should work on other ways
to improve mental health and decrease
suicide we should work on Health Equity
we should work on discrimination within
healthc care we don't take away specific
options from people that they have a
right to have just
because it will affect one
group finally I would like to say that
if I get to the end of my life if you do
and you decide that that is your
appropriate and your preferred next
action you should have the right to do
that that is your right to say I don't
want to live out my days on pain
medications I would like to die with
dignity and I would like to do that when
I choose to do that I have also heard
your time is up if you want to just
close it real I'll just close it up the
recommendation would be that people can
still do that on their own from a
clinical perspective that scares me uh
because any anybody has the right to
have the appropriate medication and have
that be controlled by a
provider thank you very much Rebecca
Brown oh you're not taking
questions hi thanks for this opportunity
I'm Rebecca Brown from Sugar Hill and
I'm the organizer of New Hampshire
Alliance for end of life
options I'm doing this work because my
husband ended his life In fact when I
was sitting in that seat over here in
our
legislature I'm here because I believe
that we can help prevent that kind of
endof life experience for many people
here in New Hampshire he was a military
veteran a New Hampshire native and he
was a tough guy from the North country
and you know people like this they do
not want to suffer as he was and they
say there's euphemisms maybe you've
heard them the 38 solution I'll just go
out to the
Woodshed we're present we're not
presenting this bill as a suicide
prevention bill but I'm sure you know as
I know that there are plenty of people
for whom this option would help prevent
that kind of violent death and if we can
prevent the kind of anguish that my
family felt as a result of that that
success you're hearing stories and will
continue to hear from people who have
loved ones who want this for themselves
or for their patients because this is an
accepted part of compassionate end of
life
care you know already from the testimony
this is for people whose lives are
imminent and you will hear a lot of
courage today because it's very
difficult to get up and talk about a
difficult
death we want to acknowledge that for
people living with disabilities there's
terrible inequities in our culture in
our health care System but defeating
this bill will not help that what this
bill does is prevent more suffering from
people already suffering and facing a
difficult end of
life in your folder you will find a
booklet called our stories that details
New Hampshire people
who have wanted this option for
themselves for their patients some most
of them are still with us some have
already
died these are your
constituents you'll also find fact
sheets on the process of Medical Aid and
dying what it is and is not there's a
peer-reviewed bioethical medical journal
just published on rates of suicide in
states that have Medical Aid and dying
that know that shows no impact up or
down there's also a wonderful piece from
one of our leading mental health experts
in New Hampshire on why this is not the
same as
suicide and there is a memo from the UNH
polling Center about their techniques
and why that poll is uh all the results
from it for you there also a summary of
that people come here and join our
movement because usually they've
experienced trauma in a dying process
but they're here today because they have
hope and it's hope that you all of us
will be holding compassion in our hearts
is your time if you want to give a one
sentence wrap up thank you compassion in
your heart and freedom in your minds and
allow New Hampshire the same rights as
our neighbors in Vermont and
Maine Live Free Die Free thank you and
I'm happy to take questions
representative
Perez thank you thanks for taking that
question do you have um this type of
offering for Citizens has been around
since 19 what 1994 when Oregon put it up
yet there are only 10 states that have
been active enacted it and it has never
been discussed at the federal level do
you have any insight where you've done
all this in but why that hasn't happened
10 out of 50 and never at the federal
level thank you for the question
representative it's not been discussed
at the federal level because the Supreme
Court has declared that this is a the
right to die if you'll call it that is a
state-by-state
issue the reason that 10 states 11
counting DC is that as we can all attest
to this is a difficult subject people
would rather not talk about death at
all and this is putting a uh
it brings it right out of the closet
which we think is a good thing we think
it is far better and healthier for
people to have clear discussions with
their care team as you just heard with
their loved ones about this but it's
part of our culture to avoid it right
now two out of 10 people in the US do
have this law so it is a significant
number thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you
Kathy
Baker yes hello my name is Kathy Baker
and I'm asking you all to oppose this
law I have no doubt that the
well-intentioned that there are good
intentions that lie behind this wanting
to give people control um and the desire
to alleviate suffering however what is
intended for good in its implementation
is actually evil um first of all suicide
is not legal we are not stopping anyone
from committing suicide but this law
makes many individuals accessories to
Suicide all of the doctors all the
mental health professionals the
pharmacists the witnesses who have to
attest that this person who wants to
kill thems is indeed mentally competent
to do it the person who has to sit with
the person who kills themselves we are
creating accessories to the suicide and
all of the people in the Senate and the
house who vote for this legislation
become accessories to Suicide another
really dangerous and terrible thing
about this bill is that it medicalizes
death it turns our institutions for
health and healing into an
infrastructure for death and it equates
killing with care and I've heard
multiple people today talk about
assisted suicide and assist assisting in
suicide as care that is not medical care
that is not health or healing the
mentality of the discussion alone is
taking us down this path it also
devalues the lives of those who have
illness and disability and as eth
ethicist lean Cass warned the right to
die invariably becomes a duty to die and
in Washington state according to the
physician responsible for ending their
patients lives 10% of all assisted
suicides in 2022 were because patients
were concerned with financial
implications of treatment in Canada this
form of death is now the fifth leading
cause of death it was intended as a last
resort for rare cases after only seven
years of implementation this is being
marketed to every patient as an option
for care and it's a lot cheaper than
Medical Care they've even studied that
that in Canada how much money they save
as people are choosing assisted suicide
instead of care the safeguards in the
bill do not prevent it from being
marketed to the ill and marketed to the
disabled as an option for care um and
that is extremely upsetting um in order
to com accurately discuss and evaluate
this we shouldn't use euphemisms either
this bill is assisted suicide the very
definition of suicide is somebody taking
their own life voluntarily assisted
meaning people are assisting with it
assisted sadly meaning that the medical
industry I apologize that's your time if
you want to one sentence wrap up I will
um the great state of New Hampshire
should never be tainted by encouraging a
culture of death and encode a
dehumanization of our ill our elderly
and are most valuable in our laws you
don't want to be an accessory to this
death vote against this Bill thank you
Gary
York thank you uh Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Gary York I
live in hopkington and I'm a retired
physician with many years years of end
of life advocacy including all things
medical
Freedom I'd like to ask all the members
uh on the committee to
please weigh the relevance of any
testimony that you receive whether it be
written or oral as it relates to the
specifics of the bill
we've heard a lot of people talk about
hypotheticals and what if and this will
probably lead to this and that but in
fact as long as the end of life acts
have occurred throughout the country
there's been no evidence there's any
been any abuse of this act
whatsoever so I'd ask you uh most
respectively to weigh the relevance uh
is this a real life experience a story
of something that happened to somebody
or is this something that we worry about
that does not relate to the bill as it
is outlined specifically and with
numerous
safeguards now we all know about medical
freedom and our motto
is Live Free or Die in New
Hampshire uh of Interest here is that
some people may recognize this is a
license plate for a trailer well New
Hampshire is a trailer for our
neighboring states Vermont and New
Hampshire who have enacted this act uh
in uh
2013 and 2019
respectively Vermont has probably about
a third of the population of
Maine New Hampshire has a similar
population as New Hampshire 1.4
million 1.4 million
people uh considering the number of
people that would be eligible for this
uh made
legislation we're talking about 20 or 30
people who actually use this in the
state of Maine or in the future State of
New
Hampshire so that's a very small number
that's what we're talking about
so the very core of this as been said
before this is an individual Freedom
it's really freedom for all but we're
talking about individuals here and we're
talking that everyone has a choice to
make this decision we have to
voluntarily apply for
this cannot be under coercion this is
something we volunteer for no one's
coming after us to hurt us I apologize
Dr that short time one sentence wrap up
okay well I'd like to borrow a phrase uh
that we've all heard before my body my
choice and we can apply it to this act
and we could say my body my choice my
time and again I would just ask that you
please weigh the relevance of the
testimony carefully as it applies to the
bill if you do not understand the bill
any aspects of the bill or have concerns
about the bill I will hand you my
onepage testimony and my contact
information is there I'd be happy to
answer any questions thank
you cara Phillips Cara
Phillips hi thank you so much Judiciary
Committee for hearing me today I
traveled from Providence Rhode Island to
to be here um I am respectfully
imploring you to please pass HB
254 I have been pass a passionate
advocate for Medical Aid and dying for
terminally ill patients since
2021 my beloved mom Claire Phillips was
diagnosed with multiple Myoma in
2018 she had a tumultuous diagnosis in
which she did radiation was in and out
of hospice had a period of remission
thanks to
chemotherapy But ultimately stopped
responding to treatment and had a quick
physical decline that led her to her
tragic death on June 3rd
2021 on the on the morning of that day
my mom shot herself in the
head and died alone on the concrete
floor of the shed in our backyard
my dad her husband of over 40 years had
to find her we had police swarm our
property we were questioned by
detectives our lives were shattered and
I lost my best friend and
soulmate in one of the most traumatic
ways
possible I knew my mom was dying I could
see it happening in front of my eyes but
never in a million years did I think she
would do what she
did my mom and dad adopted me from China
in the early '90s she was selfless
compassionate gentle and the best mom I
could have ever asked for in this
life the fact that she was desperate
enough to do what she
did just kills
me but I have now made it my life's
mission
to share her story and dedicate my life
to this work I'm getting my master of
Public Health from Brown University
which I'll be graduating in August and I
hope to have two collaborative papers
published on maid um from the research
um team that I'm working with at
Ruckers Medical Aid and dying is an end
of Life Health Care option and I
strongly believe it is prevention until
cancer ALS and other degenerative
terminal conditions are curable made
prevents suffering it prevents
terminally ill people from resorting to
desperate violent Andor illegal
methods to cease their suffering and it
prevents us the surviving loved ones
from having to endure this trauma I'm
sorry that that's your time if you I'll
let you get a one sentence wrap up New
Hampshire I dying from terminal illness
deserve this right to freedom and death
and I have provided my full written
testimony which I hope you will take the
time to read thank you very much for
your time and consideration thank you we
will and thank you for sharing your
story Brenda
Mari my name is Brenda maray and I'm
from dorham my sister was rushed to
danaba Cancer Institute briam women's
and operated on for a cancerous throat
tumor in early March
2022 my brother-in-law took care of her
at home for almost 2 years the care
required 247 attention because my sister
had a trusty and a feeding tube inserted
to stay alive she died on February 22nd
her dying was painful to watch I do not
want to experience death like my sister
in 1945 New Hampshire adopted as the
state's motto Live Free or Die the
people's elected representatives should
make clear that a person in New
Hampshire is free to live and to die as
provided for HB
254 it is an individ ual Choice thank
you I would like to compliment the first
Speaker uh for his support but if he is
in the late Autumn of his life at 74 I
am in the dead of winter at
85 thank
you is it is it Pam is it juac
juac from Nashville
yes good afternoon Mr chairman uh
members of the House Judiciary Committee
my name is John jersi and I am the
President of St Joseph Hospital in
Nashua I also for the first 25 years of
my career uh was a practicing pharmacist
in New England but as a health care
provider I must Advocate against HB 25
for the New Hampshire end of life
Freedom Act due to the ethical medical
and societal implications of legalizing
medical Aid and dying the primary
responsibility of healthc care providers
is to preserve life not to facilitate
its termination even in cases of
terminal illness the sanctity of life is
a fundamental principle in medical
ethics and the shift towards allowing
Physicians to prescribe
life-ending uh medications contradicts
the hypocritic oath first determining
prognosis is not always precise many
patients outlive their sixth month life
expectancy and by providing an option
for
maid we risk denying them
there there that they might otherwise
have had to experience life see
treatment advancements or even Achieve
Personal
Milestones second there is the potential
for coercion in subtle pressure from
either family members or financial
concerns especially among vulnerable
patients despite legal standards the
psychological state of terminally ill
patients including depression or fear of
being a burden could influence their
decision making third as a health care
provider we have alternative tools to
manage pain and suffering our
organization has had an established
paliative CARE program for over three
decades serving many in NASA and Pila of
care and Hospice Services focused on
improving quality life relieving pain
and providing holistic support support
to patients in their families rather
than hastening death we should focus on
enhancing these services to ensure that
patients die with dignity free of pain
and distress encouraging Medical Aid in
dying could also undermine trust in the
patient provider relationship as
patients May fear that provider their
provider is too quick to offer death as
a solution instead of endorsing Medical
Aid and dying we should prioritize
compassionate patient centered care that
affirms life even in the final
stages thank you any question
questions representative Perez yes thank
you thanks for taking my question you
mentioned coercion are you aware that in
this bill if I try to coer you
to to commit maid there's no Penal peny
but if I try to stop you from doing it
it's a class B felony coercion can be
incredibly subtle and it can be from
even discussing the cost of treatments
to you know who is going to take care of
me so I look at it as it can be
incredibly subtle and very elusive
around and great absolutely thank you
thank you any other questions for me it
saying none oh oh represent
morning thank you for the question um
going back to what I mentioned earlier
about Co um in your professional
experience would you say that there was
coercion during during that time period
and is that something they could apply
to this in the future that people could
be coerced in the same way they were
coerced to get the vaccine and things
like
that
um I don't I don't quite the connection
from the bill uh as it's written and uh
the co pandemic for healthc care
providers there was no choice um other
than a medical exemption or religious
exemption to having the vaccine uh we
were required by CMS the centers for
Medicaid and Medicaid services to
vaccinate all
employees um so as a I can only speak to
how it impacted the provider community
thank you thank
you Colin
McNab good afternoon my name is Colin
McNab and I'm the director of mission
and spiritual Care at St Joseph's
Hospital uh in nsha here to oppose this
bill 240 years ago the government of
this state approved a Constitution which
still proudly proclaims the natural
essential and inherent right to the
enjoying and defending of life that
right I suggest is uncon unconditional
and prohibits suicide which despite the
fancy words is what you are considering
today one of the greatest privileges of
a healthc care Chaplin is to stand with
a dying person and to love and pray with
them as they seek to Die the way they
lived in patient obedience to God's will
willing to wait for him to take them
home on this side there are those
praying with the dying person and
relieving their pain while on the other
side are all who love them in heaven and
wait to welcome them home in God's good
time like Pope Francis I believe
assisted suicide is a defeat for
everyone and I join with him and with
the constitution of this great state in
urging you to defend life and not
participate in taking it through making
suicide SU suicide the law of this great
land we all want to find ways to love
those who are in pain especially those
who have been such important parts of
our lives but the loving thing is not to
encourage someone to end their life but
to embrace every moment encourage them
to find meaning and to love every moment
with every fiber of their being for all
the time that they are
given any questions seeing none thank
you Michael Flynn or is it Michelle
Flynn I'm sorry Michelle
Flynn
yep hi there I'm Dr Michelle Flynn I'm a
retired Internal Medicine physician and
I'm here to oppose the
bill I just have to go back to basics
first Do no harm I'm going to strongly
suggest that doctors should not
participate in killing their patients
just have to say that outright I think
other people have spoken to the slippery
slope that we see happening up north in
Canada where we see this starting out
small and as somebody Apple said
metastasizing to now they're even
looking at drug addicts as mental health
having them choose assisted suicide I
feel that when we open the portal to to
choosing death as a treatment people's
lives become tied to the
economic situation of their illness and
not so much to the Compassionate Care
that they um need I understand that
we're all here on both sides of the
issue to be compassionate to our
patients and we we really hate to see
them suffer I agree with that and I hear
some of the horrible stories and I my
heart bleeds to hear them but I feel
that just down to the basics a physician
is there to Shepherd a person through
their life even into the difficult times
and there's so much room for improvement
with paliative care and hospice care we
have so few hospice houses that do so
much good there are ways of asking a
patient if they don't want to get
further treatment and get pain relief
there's a lot of room for improvement
that doesn't involve killing the patient
out right one of the things in
researching this topic that really upset
me there's obviously two ways to do it
you can do an IV
injection or you could do an oral
injection I mean oral um cocktail the IV
includes a paralytic and that is very
concerning to me because I think we all
want to see the peaceful death of our
loved ones or patients and when you're
giving them a cocktail that includes a
paralytic they are unable able to move
when they did autopsies of people that
receive Lethal Injections their lungs
were filled with
fluid and you're paralyzing them and the
deaths could take IV it could take up to
10 minutes of a patient's lungs filling
with fluid but they're unable to move or
show that they're in un any
distress orally they're so snowed they
probably can't move either but that can
take hours and hours and some people
need a second cocktail and you don't
really know you don't have a actual
knowledge that that person isn't
suffering or feeling air hunger or
feeling like they're drowning and I feel
like if there's any uncertainty about
the actual comfort of that patient that
patient could be suffering but because
the exterior looks peaceful I apologize
that's your time if you could just wrap
up in One S thank you well I just want
to know that I think we should accompany
people compassionately through natural
death and not put them to death thank
you any questions you have some
questions excuse me we have a couple of
questions if you don't mind sure
representative pel hi thank you for
taking my question as a physician I
assume you've had to diagnose um people
with terminal illness from time to time
in your practice have you ever diagnosed
somebody with a terminal illness where
you were able
to um comfortably predict the moment
that they would die or exactly how long
they would have left to
live I always got it
wrong I would say I think you have six
months and people would have two years
or vice versa I think it's really
sketchy it's a very difficult thing to
do but I'm not an oncologist and I I
defer to people that have expertise in
other areas but I could not do that at
allk you representative perz thank you
thanks for taking my question since you
brought up about the cocktail are you
aware that in Oregon that they are
stating that there are distressing
complications from ingesting these drugs
and 14.8% of patients had difficulty
swallowing or experienc regurgitation
seizures or even regain Consciousness if
I had more time I probably would have
gotten into that but I'm very very
concerned that we just accept this to be
a peaceful death and I think in a lot of
cases it's not it is not thank you thank
you any other questions seeing none
thank you thank
you Dr Scott is it
dire good afternoon oh excuse
me I'm Dr Scott Dyer uh I'm trained in
clinical ethics and currently teach
philosophical ethics with emphasis on
medical ethics at Duane University uh I
earned my doctorate by writing a 300
page dissertation on legalizing medical
aided dying in the United States uh
furthermore I grew up in New Hampshire
while going to Keem State College where
I got my undergrad degree in
communication and philosophy uh growing
up in New Hampshire there's one Mantra
that we all kind of agreed upon everyone
across the aisle Live Free or Die uh
therefore one should be able to
self-determine how they live and
logically how they die especially if
facing a terminal
illness uh substantive due process as I
assume the lawmakers in this room are
aware of uh protect prot US citizens
from excessive government meddling this
applies to end of life Medical Care as
well the ninth Circuit Court of Appeals
in buvia V Superior Court in 1986 upheld
the patient's right to refuse medical
treatment uh which then granted Miss
Elizabeth buvia the right to remove a
feeding tube that was inserted and kept
in against her will essentially Force
feeding her the decision was in line
with several court cases of that era
that allows patients to stop medical
treatment at any point
uh today due to case law precedent and
modern medical ethics a patient is
legally and morally able to stop medical
treatment at any point even if that
sensation results in their
death so essentially removing a
ventilator feeding tube whatever it may
be is both legally and ethically
acceptable in the clinical realm even if
death will come from that uh the nth
Circuit Court of Appeals found that it
was not just to deny adults with full
mental capacity the right to pursue
medically dying when the patient is
facing excessive pain and suffering
while having a terminal illness the
appell at court further stated that
those terminally ill patients have a
constitutionally protected Liberty to be
free from those undue government
intrusions which applies to choices of
Medical Care the Oregon state law that
some people have talked about up here it
was then replic was passed in 1994 put
into place in 1997 uh and has been
replicated around the world in countries
and states in the US due to its efficacy
and its regulatory framework uh many of
these laws have been called death With
Dignity laws because it allows people to
do just that die with dignity instead of
rising in pain for the last six months
of their life uh many people will put
forth arguments against this bill one of
those arguments says it's equivalent to
killing patients um legalization will
lead to the slippery slope that people
could die with however they want to in
the hospital and doctors can kill with
impunity uh this is not the case in the
United States has taken a long time for
us to get to this point where only a few
States even allow it um also I think
that if we maintain Physicians and
Professional Medical ethicists uh to be
passing these bills we can ensure the
slippery slope does not
happen uh we allow our pets to be put to
death when they're at end of life and
suffering why can't we do the same for
fellow humans Humanity uh further
because of the strict regulations that
are in place i e the slippery slope will
never come to fruition opponents may say
that this bill will threaten vulnerable
populations uh however there have been
several studies that show the vulnerable
populations actually are in favor of
these bills because it gives them
options uh they face discrimination if
they're not allowed to end their lives
on their own terms due to their
disabilities when it comes down to it
patient autonomy must always that's your
time if you can do a one second wrap up
sorry one yep um the multiple biomedical
ethics uh principles come into play here
specifically autonomy beneficence and
non-maleficence autonomy is know
ensuring patients are able to do what
they see is right and fit in their
medical care benefic do what's best for
the patient non-maleficence avoid
harming the patient sometimes allowing a
patient to end their life is indeed
doing what's best for them and avoiding
harm uh thank you I'll take any
questions if anybody would like any
saying none thank you thank
you Katie Kelly
Callie for anyone that's just arrived if
you wish if you want to speak you got to
fill out a pink card and you can turn it
in down
here good afternoon my name is Katie
Kelly and I'm a policy Council attorney
with Americans United for life but my
background is in Prosecuting healthc
care fraud and the physical emotional
and financial abuse of vulnerable adults
with physical and mental
disabilities today I urge your
opposition of House Bill
254 representative earlier you asked us
to consider and you asked the Comm
committee to consider specific terms of
the bill that we might oppose I ask
y'all to look to section 137
dm4 here a healthc care provider is only
required to refer a patient to a mental
health professional if the physician
quote has doubts as to the mental
capacity of the
patient but a physician does not even
have to formally evaluate a patient
requesting physician assisted suicide
for depression or any other mental
health conditions that might impact
their decision-making
abilities in New Hampshire 25% of adults
have reported a depression diagnosis at
some point in their lives this means
that at least one in four individuals
requesting Medical Aid and dying under
this bill may be suffering from
depression and under this bill they will
not be adequately screened by it
studies in Primary Care settings suggest
that only about 50% of depressed
patients are recognized and that number
is even lower for elderly
patients the standard of care for
patients with end of life conditions
requesting to end their lives ultimately
requires that Physicians evaluate and
treat patients for depression and
suicidal ideation well under house bill
that requirement is not
here in conclusion House Bill 254 will
result in discrimination against
vulnerable people suffering from
depression I respectfully ask you all to
review section 137 M4 review the doubts
provision and consider that that is only
one of the many flaws in this bill my
written testimony has also been
submitted online thank you for your
consideration today thank you um
representative for
thank you thanks for taking my
question is it reasonable to say that
anyone who is in the last six months of
their life who would request this would
be somewhat depressed yes representative
studies actually show that poor mental
health is comorbid with chronic
illnesses such as diabetes heart disease
and these are even com more common in
elderly patients with hidden depression
and so you're absolutely correct
any other questions seeing none thank
you thank
you Rebecca
leak Megan Smith will be next if you
want to get
ready good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Rebecca leak and I live in Andover and
I'm testifying in opposition could you
just pull the mic down a little bit so
we can hear you thank you my name is
Rebecca leak and I live in Andover and I
am testifying in opposition to HB
254 God gave us life creating Us in His
image and so taking an innocent human
life is sacred so an innocent human life
is sacred from conception to Natural
death thus murder The Taking of an
innocent human life is evil it is
immoral and wrong to assist individuals
in taking their own life State sanction
suicide in any form is is incredibly
immoral and dangerous creating a culture
of death instead of a culture of life
this is is especially dangerous for
young people who are turning to suicide
and shocking numbers a study conducted
by the CDC found that in
2021 10% of high schoolers actually
attempted suicide by permitting assisted
suicide in any form the government is
conveying to young people that suicide
is an acceptable way of dealing with
their pain or helplessness moreover once
we have started down this path to
devaluing human life where will it end
while some have objected to the slippery
slope argument it is completely
reasonable and even wise to consider
what other states and countries have
done with this issue for they are
warnings about what might happen here in
Canada the medical assistance and Dy
program began in 2016 with very similar
restrictions to those in this bill only
5 years later those restrictions were
expanded to include incurable patients
and in 2024 before they were further
expanded to include patients with mental
illness and drug addicts there have also
been document instances of misuse and
abuse of maid furthermore document
doctors are encouraged to bring up
medical assistance in dying before their
patients do for example a paralympian
veteran who requested a chairlift was
instead offered a medical assistance in
dying kit Canada is not alone similar
atrocities are occurring in the
Netherlands where doctors are allowed to
S dat and euthanize Advanced dementia
patients who had previously indicated
their consent but later resisted the
procedure within the United States
itself in Oregon where assisted suicide
is legal for terminally ill adults more
than half of the assisted deaths in
20121 were of individuals who said they
felt like a burden on loved
ones furthermore while this bill
requires an individual to have a
prognosis of 6 months or less to live
such diagnoses are far from certain as
some individuals have gone on to live
for over a decade after such a prognosis
therefore I strongly urge you to re
recommend HB 254 as inexpedient to
legislate thank you for considering my
testimony thank
you Megan
Smith good afternoon my name is Megan
Smith I live here in BO New Hampshire
I'm a master's prepared board certified
registered nurse having practice in the
state of New Hampshire for the last 20
years I'm here today to share my
personal and professional support for
New Hampshire's end of life Freedom Act
20 years ago when I was 21 years old I
lost the first man I ever loved he
raised me from the time I was two and
was hands down the best dad I could have
ever had the privilege of having
unfortunately my time with him would be
dramatically cut short when in the
winter of 2004 he was diagnosed with
stage 4 lung cancer he fought for two
years participating in clinical trials
and receiving harsh rounds of
chemotherapy we knew these two years
were only prolonging the time we had
with him as his diagnosis was terminal
but at just 56 years old none of us were
ready to say goodbye despite all all of
us not being ready in October of 2006 he
was actively dying he was less than 90
pounds at that time and was suffering
from intense pain due to the m
metastasis of his cancer he wasn't
eating he wasn't drinking he was
frequently hallucinating from the
medications we were giving to attempt to
control his pain because of his symptoms
the dramatic change in the way he looked
and his General suffering he asked for
no visitors in those final weeks and
days in his final three days he
developed painful pressure ulcers
because his skin was so Frable from his
malnutrition and his extremely low
weight as nurses my mom and I knew what
had to be done we turned him every two
hours day and night trying to offload
his hips his heels and his tailbone but
despite our best efforts the pressure
ulcers prevailed and in the last 24
hours utilizing every medication we had
available to us through our hospice uh
benefit we couldn't give him his one
wish which was not to die from drowning
he suffocated to death and that is
something that my mom and I will never
forget if he was able to have access to
Medical Aid and dying we have no doubt
he would have chosen to take control
over his dying process we would have had
an outdoor get together at our home with
all his friends in family and we would
have celebrated his life we would have
had a DJ playing music because he and my
mom were known for their block parties
he would have had one of his favorite
meals which was goulash with raisins
gross he would have had um after the
celebration was done he would have
chosen to take his maid prescription and
drift off into a peaceful sleep and
eventually a peaceful death he would
have been able to choose to end his life
on his own terms before his pain and
suffering became unbearable currently as
a a full-time registered nurse and
actively working I'm also a full-time
doctor of nursing practice student and
I've spent that countless hours
researching maid I have looked through
the evidence and here's what I find mate
exists to address a deeply sensitive and
complex problem the suffering of
terminally ill patients in the final
stages of their
life uh maid currently provides two five
uh people in the dying uh in the US the
autonomy dignity and compassion during
the end stages of their life but not
here in New Hampshire and that's not the
New Hampshire way after all we are the
live fre or D I apologize but that's
your time you can go one sentence your
last p page can either be a a page
that's sorrowful tragic and traumatic or
it can be an affirmation of the time
you've lived we all leave this world I
can't think of a better way to do it
than to the sounds and voices and
laughter of our loved ones thank you any
questions at all n thank
you honorable Kurt welper
Suzanne steel will be
next uh thank you Mr chairman for the
record my name is Kurt welper I will in
straford New Hampshire and I'm chairman
of New Hampshire Right to Life whom I
represent here today on your on your
desks I left a little packet with four
pieces of information on there packets
couple Pages the one from Canada talking
about what you just heard about their
their demise into uh what happened after
they started with this uh one from New
Hampshire right uh National right to
life one from Americans United for life
and one from the National Council on
disabilities all of whom all of what are
there to talk about the Myriad issues
with Medical Aid and dying in general
and I want to talk to a couple couple
things specifically to this
bill representative L talked about
trusted in state
law well yes trusted and state law
applies after people
die but it protects their wishes not
their
lives there is a protection at least
proposed within this bill that
uh coercing one to administer the drugs
after they've got the prescription would
be a class B felony but there'll be no
investigation there are no
Witnesses and I don't I can't imagine
any way that could ever be enforced so I
find that to be along with the other
prescriptions in this bill like the
conditions and all of that which have
failed everywhere they've been willfully
inadequate the mental health protection
is similar as you've heard a lot of
people suffer from depression
particularly near the end of their lives
it takes a lot more than one meeting
with a person
to determine whether or not that person
actually has mental
illness my son has mental illness and
he's had a lot of meetings where they
told him he was
fine right my I find this bill to be
unnecessary my brother had pancreatic
cancer for five years they weren't very
pleasant years
he was in hospice care when he died at
home it was it was fine it was
beautiful right there's no we don't need
to have this so people can buy
peacefully at home we
have the protocols in
place there are no protocols really for
assisted suicide I was reading yesterday
about the pro the the drugs that are
used and how there are no
standards which is understandable
because many of the patients who would
be requesting and actually wanting to
take these drugs I'm sorry that's your
time if you have a one sense wrap up
I'll do one more thing studies showed
that if we do this the suicide rate
outside of it would increase by
6.3% which in New Hampshire amounts to
eight more dead people from suicide each
and every year it's a price we should
absolutely not pay I ask you urge you to
oppose the bill are there any questions
at all seeing none thank you thank you
Suzanne
steel followed by Melinda Sims you'll be
next
good afternoon I am here today on behalf
of my husband to share the pain that
Jeff went through every day for the last
eight years of his
life he had atypical Parkinson's disease
and passed away eight months ago on May
23rd three days before his 71st birthday
and our 34th
anniversary over the course of this
disease he had lost his ability to move
on his own to wash to use the bathroom
to walk to hike to ride his
bicycle to ski to teach
skiing in short so many of the things
that made his life what it
was which gave him meaning gave him
Joy he was no longer living he was
existing especially the last five years
he was in emotional and physical
pain constantly looking at the clock
waiting for the day to go by crying
being
frustrated angry and feeling feeling
helpless because he was not able to do
anything on his own he knew that this
disease would kill him having the option
to die on his own terms may have given
him back some of the sense of control
and peace of
mind compassion kindness love caring
this is what I wanted for my husband and
those who are in a similar situation
please help us change that you can make
a
difference for those that want to stop
existing and suffering after having
lived a long and happy life those who
meet the qualifications for Medical Aid
and dying terminally ill six months
you've heard this all I'm going to skip
it New Hampshire is the live free and
die state which you've heard Also let's
make it so by allowing those who want to
die to do so with dignity and give them
the option if it is right for them to be
at peace the pictures that are there
show his progression of his life and the
last two were two weeks before he died
and not quite the first two pages thank
you I have a question you wouldn't mind
representative you all set thank
you Melinda Sims
hi my name is Melinda Sims I'm a
disabled veteran I got hurt serving our
country and like many vets I had to
rebuild my life from scratch today I'm
fighting a different battle one that
threatens every disabled veteran in
person with disability in New Hampshire
let me be blunt hb24 is deadly they're
calling it medical assistance in dying
but that's just fancy words for giving
up on people like me in Canada where
they passed this kind of law deaths
skyrocketed in Canada medical assistance
and dying programs have exploded from
1,8 deaths in 2016 to
13,241 deaths in 2022 a staggering 1200%
increase in just 7 years think about it
it's now their fifth leading cause of
death here's what keeps me up at night
they're actually counting the money they
save when disabled people die 139
million a year they're turning our lives
into budget cuts even worse they're now
using 6% of organ donations from people
who choose to die they're literally
turning our deaths into a business
this hits home in New Hampshire we've
got over 71,000 veterans and 163,000
people living with disabilities half of
us are already struggling with poverty
now imagine your doctor who's supposed
to help you live see seeing you as a
cost cut that's not just wrong it's
terrifying you know what's really
shocking 80% of doctors admit they
biased against people with disabilities
they look at something someone like me
and think our lives aren't worth living
I'm here to tell you my life has
value every disabled Veteran's life has
value every disabled person has value
the same the same state that says it
wants to prevent veteran suicide is now
considering a law that would push us
towards death we can't let our Society
normalized suicide as a solution that's
not who we are as Americans we did when
did we become so cold that we started
seeing death as a cost-saving measure
our state should be focusing on helping
people with dignity not creating paths
to end their lives I'm not just asking
you to oppose this bill I'm asking you
to stand with our veterans stand with
disabled people and and a clear message
we don't put a price tag on human life
not here not ever our lives aren't
budget items we're people and we deserve
more than this thank
you thank
you I appreciate the Outburst but we I
mean the passion but we have to limit
the Outburst
please representative Perez thanks
thanks for taking my question um
when we talk about a slippery slope that
I am concerned about Veterans as well
are you aware that when the um the New
Hampshire Alliance for end of life
options did their survey they only asked
two questions the first being about if
you believe in made but the second one
do you consider yourself
disabled I am disabled but i h
i I can do everything I'm not in a bed
just being vegetated um it's a hard
question I'm disabled yes but I am abled
I can go out and enjoy life and I do
enjoy life I I have thank you I just
found quality caring I wondered if you
were aware of it yes that uh survey that
you you mentioned uh that's a typical
survey by uh compa care and compassion
and they come out with the same number
in every single state which is
70% just putting that out there check
your numbers thank
you you have a question here
representative
Veron I just wanted to thank you for
your service you're welcome thank
you I'm backing I might need
help thank
you clette Kelly
Norman tibo will be
next good afternoon my name is claic
Kelly and I live in Epsom Mr chairman
and fellow house committee members I
want to thank you for hearing my
testimony in favor of HB
254 the New Hampshire end of life
Freedom Act I also testified last year
just months after my husband passed let
us take a moment to reflect on this we
live in the Live Free or Die State and
currently must go to another state to
assist our loved ones if they want the
option to end their suffering and loss
of dignity why may I ask is this my
husband bill was a very proud man and
strong man who loved his State our state
of New Hampshire after three and A2
years of fighting cancer and was told he
had less than six months to live he
wanted to pass in his home state but had
to go to
Vermont he wanted to pass in peace and
not the horrific end of life that would
have been his see like everyone else has
said here he had a bloodfed tumor and
would have died choking on his own
blood would you would that be the last
thing that you would want to remember
about your loved ones
Journey or would you want to feel as
Bill's family and I did that he died in
peace this bill has nothing to do with
disabilities suicide nor religion we
have the freedom of religion in this
country it is one of the principles we
are founded on that means that no one
especially public servants should impose
their religious beliefs on others this
bill allows people of every Faith or of
no faith at all to follow their own
conscience values and
beliefs it respects each of us as
dignified
humans I am likely one of the few people
here today from New Hampshire who has
had the privilege of being with a loved
one who is able able to die peacefully
because they had the option of Medical
Aid and dying I invite you to ask me any
questions about that
experience and also about how difficult
it was to arrange in
Vermont we were very very lucky in
closing I want you to know that I will
continue to fight for this cause until
the day that I die why because I believe
in this option for those who are dying
and I also promised my husband that I
would fight for it thank
you thank
you Norman
tibo next will be representative
Penza thank you for being here today I'm
Norman TBO I live in Bedford New
Hampshire I speak in opposition to this
bill in 2012 I got a shock both my
Urology in Nashua and Dana Farber in
Boston conferred concurred there was an
85% chance an aggressive form of cancer
would spread through my body if not
treated
immediately what if this assisted
suicide law had been in effect would my
insurance company have authorized the 42
radiation treatments over a two-month
period at a cost of a quarter of a
million dollars what would their
threshold be in determining whether my
treatment was worth
it 75% chance of spread 80 90 with
suicide available as an option an
unintended consequence certainly would
be insurance companies and health care
providers weighing the benefit of
authorizing procedures against the
dollar cost and Lely
survival would I have fallen into the
six-month window I don't know because we
didn't have that discussion there was
immediate agreement between my insurance
and Dana Farber that my treatment would
proceed immediately
as it turns out I was classified by my
urologist several years later has no
evidence of disease I guess I'm a
miracle I'm part of the
15% this law had been in effect and my
prognosis fell within that six-month
window and my insurance company had
deemed my uh treatment not authorized I
would have had three options in my mind
first deny the treatment and just take
my
chances second pay for treatment out of
pocket and use my entire life savings at
the
time three take advantage of the suicide
option saving my life savings for my
heirs
maybe this law would create incentives
for patients like me insurance companies
and healthc care providers to seriously
consider death as a viable alternative
to
treatment the patient would be under
tremendous stress as to what to do
should I put myself through treatment
should I use up my children's
inheritance just to stay alive a little
longer in reality anyone qualifying
under this law would be faced with these
decisions consciously or unconsciously
and not just the patients their whole
families would have to deal with these
issues quite possibly creating conflicts
that channel their thoughts to should
mom or dad end it now rather than let's
enjoy the time we have
left how many families would be torn
apart as the patient is guilted into
ending their life am I being selfish by
living while this bill is intended to
show compassion it has the potential to
create incentivization and pressure
that's not compassion that is
coercion I urge you to consider the
unintended consequences of this bill
please do not let this become New
Hampshire wall we should support living
and compassionate treatment not time sir
you could just one sentence wrap up all
right I have one question for the
sponsors and the supporters of this
bill who appointed you God thank you
thank you any
questions representative Perez thank you
thanks for taking my question you
mentioned insurance companies presently
Medicare and insurance companies do not
pay for this option do you have a
concern that if we put this in as an
option for people that um insurance
companies might look at this and
withhold old insurance benefits for
people who might have terminal
illnesses yes I do they make those
determinations
now with this in effect there's an
incentive of
course thank
you thank you representative Kelly
Penza thank you Mr chair for the record
my name is uh representative Kelly paten
straford District 19 Rochester Wards 1 2
3 4 and six um it's my day I guess to
testify in front of duas Sherry um I am
strongly opposed to this bill and I'm
sure you guys have heard um many many
different reasons my reason is personal
I just don't feel like it's necessary
um I have had the pleasure in sadness of
watching loved ones pass and through
hospice uh my nana uh passed and they
kept her comfortable on morphine and she
lived for about 4 days and she was
asleep and never woke up um another
another very good friend in hospice uh
past of Co pneumonia um up in
dartmouth's hospital house which was um
incredible I just don't feel like there
is a there is a need for this bill I
have um I have seen the the entire
process from that terminal point um in
the level of Grace and love and keeping
people comfortable and and taking the
complete religious component out of this
I just I don't see a need
um and uh and being there with my nana
and realizing that there was nothing
that rarely I could do um it was it was
hard for me so I just I think this as
you've heard this opens up a door to a
slippery slope and I just don't find it
necessary in New Hampshire I've I've
been there I've been bedside um when you
have a terminal endless uh that the
doctors and um and caretakers in the
state are fully incredible especially in
hospice and um and it's already I think
we already have a pathway to peacefully
and gracefully dying in New Hampshire
any questions at all seeing none thank
you Reverend Peter Frederick
good
afternoon thank you for the opportunity
to speak today my name is the Reverend
Peter friedricks I am a resident of keen
and I am a retired unarian Universalist
Minister I'm also a current member of
the board of the New Hampshire Alliance
for end of life options and I am a
hospice
volunteer as a church pastor I have sat
at the bedside of the sick and suffering
those enduring horrific pain as they
face the end of their
lives it is true that every one of them
every one of them wishes to go on living
full and productive lives if only their
health could be
restored every life is precious but the
value of a life is not measured solely
in its longevity quality counts and for
many of those who know that they will
never recover their only wish their
dying wish is to have some control over
when and how their lives will end HB 254
would offer those who were facing the
end of their lives with that
control
hb24 is modeled after the legislation
passed in 10 other states and
jurisdictions in the United States that
have stood the test of time there is
demonstrated evidence that Medical Aid
in dying supports a small percentage of
terminally ill cognitively competent
patients in their decision to bring
their lives to an end peacefully
surrounded by family and
friends I heartily agree that we can and
should do better to meet the needs of
those with chronic illnesses and
disabilities and I concede that the fear
of those who oppose this bill is real
the fear is real but the facts the facts
simply do not support the fears there is
no evidence that Medical Aid and dying
laws increase the rate of suicide or
that they endanger those people who have
a disability or are otherwise considered
vulnerable let me repeat that because
it's important there is no evidence that
Medical Aid and dying laws increase the
rate of suicide or that they endanger
those people who have a disability or
are otherwise considered vulnerable we
are not Canada as much as our current
president might like it to be otherwise
we are not Canada socially culturally or
legally the scope of this bill is narrow
but nevertheless important to the few to
whom this law would apply its mere
existence will provide Comfort even if
they never Avail themselves of its
provisions
at its core HB 254 is a bill that places
compassion for the dying at the highest
value it compels no one it endangers no
one it simply offers a small sub sir
that's your time if you want to wrap up
thank you it simply offers a small
subset of those who have a terminal
illness and are suffering unbearable
pain the opportunity to bring their
lives to a peaceful end should they so
choose I encourage you to vote for
compassion
I encourage you to vote for HB 254 thank
you any questions at all seeing none
thank you Rod
Sims followed by Charlene Joyce will be
next hello thank you for taking time to
listen to all this my name is Rod Sims
my wife is Melinda she's in the back
she's the veteran um I disagree with the
lot of what's been set up here today and
people say there's no facts to back up
what people like myself say but um I
agree with the pretense of this bill but
not in a way these bills end up
operating my wife is a I call her a data
minor she's got a lot more professional
sounding name for it but she's actually
officially recognized as an information
researcher um two years ago when we
first got involved with this um she went
and found all kinds of information about
maid and and we found out it started out
in the Netherlands and how it had
transpired and grown and morphed in the
Netherlands and everybody says well
you're going to have to pass bills to
get these changes made that you're
afraid of happening that is not the case
in the Netherlands it just grew out by
itself so now the Netherlands is
actually having to try to get bills pass
to rain this thing in because it's got
so bad um I do know that paliative care
is used for euthanizing people uh my
wife was offered that option at one of
of her last uh checkups they tried to
separate me from her so they could have
a conversation with her about her life
not being worth living and they could
give her paliative care which would help
that life end quickly so I know that for
a fact I know for a fact that hospice
also euthanizes people if they wish to
be euthanized because I have a relative
that works in the medical industry and
she's told me numerous times about that
and she's told me numerous times that
she's refused to give patients lethal um
doses of drugs to to end their life
because she didn't feel like they wanted
that done but the hospital or whatever
group thought that was to their benefit
so I am very concerned about how this
can grow I am very compassionate against
all the people that says that they've
lost loved ones and they suffered
terribly I really don't understand why
that happened because like I said
hospice and palic Care can help with
that but my concern is that if this gets
passed it's going to take away the
safeguards that the little safeguards we
have now for people like my wife wife
saying okay we're not going to pay for
any more your treatments we're not going
to pay for anything because it's cheaper
for you to be euthanized than it is for
us to spend money on you my wife when
she went started looking for all this
maid information I had to sit and watch
hours and hours and hours of video that
came out of the Netherlands came out of
Canada and stuff where people had done
documentaries and one that really
shocked me was in Canada there was a
young man he was in his early 40s he had
been he had been diagnosed with u
schizophrenia or schizophrenic I think
it was at the time and he'd been in the
system which they have uh their
insurance up there is different from
ours it's um Community Care medicine or
something I'm not sure what the term is
but the state pays for your care um he
had been in the system had done well in
2016 once they they brought in uh maid
they told him we're no longer going to
continue your care and so he was
basically turned out I'm sorry sir
that's your time if you want to wrap up
but basically he was told he was worth
$24 million
in body parts and if he would take and
commit suicide that that would be
helping out the
Canada I'll take any questions any
questions at all seeing none thank
you Charlene
Joyce anyone Charlene Joyce
okay this one's going to be tough up
Camala and I the last name is way too
small
CH and I can't throw us through it thank
you could you just state your name full
Mard I'm going to look at my notes thank
you I was born in Canada and I came to
United States many years ago go and I
never thought that I needed to become an
American citizen because I wasn't I
didn't care about
voting but this year I thought I really
want to vote and I became a citizen well
I just want to tell you two years ago
when my sister
Claire uh had been diagnosed with cancer
leukemia
and it was difficult they of course it's
hard a doctor to say how long you have
to live so when her children who all
lived far away came to be with their
mother at the last moment well it took a
little too long it it was like three
weeks and she was still alive and those
people needed to go back to their job
and you know their children were little
and so one of the of her children was
very four this bill and uh so my sister
was not able to do really what she
wanted she was pushed into well you know
this is taking too long they didn't say
it but the way they acted so for that
reason she accepted the injection that
took her life and I am against this bill
of course
because I believe that life is from the
moment of conception until natural death
and this was not natural thatb and I am
so sorry that this we had to live
through
that and being a citizen of United
States I really believe that we cannot
pass this thank
you thank
you Mar read
Matthews I tripped sorry my name is
Margaret Matthews I'm a resident of
Durham New Hampshire I um am here to
urge you to vote in favor of house bill
number
254 I have been diagnosed with a fatal
disease um I was given uh 18 months two
years
ago I refuse treatment and am living out
my life as best I
can I am a Performing Artist I have uh I
was honored to receive the governor's
2013 bed Kobe living treasure award and
I have served two terms as New
Hampshire's artist laurat I visit small
towns throughout New Hampshire and
neighboring states where we do
performances based on the work of noted
New England
authors I feel as though it is my
decision of when it's time for me to end
my life I appreciate that we are in a
live free state I expect that I should
be able to live free right up until my
last
breath and I don't think I need to be um
influenced or or or persuaded by other
people's beliefs other people's
religions they're not mine it's not what
I believe I am enjoying my life here in
New Hampshire I'm getting great joy out
of touring around and uh and meeting all
the people in our wonderful State I plan
to live as long as I possibly can but
when I decide that I need to stop I want
to live a comfortable death I do not
want to drown in my own blood as other
sufferers from lung cancer have done I
feel I deserve
that that's the end of my statement and
I'm glad to answer any questions
representative Smith thank you it's not
um a question um well I guess I can say
it as a question um wouldn't it be
wonderful if everyone in this room could
take an opportunity to see the work of
the pontine theater thank you very much
thank you any other
questions thank you thank you I urge
your support for this bill it's
important for so many of us thank you
Bishop Peter laash
thank you all very very much for this
opportunity to speak I um come today as
of course the Roman Catholic bishop of
Manchester responsible for the Catholic
Community here and also other people of
Goodwill and speaking today I'm changing
my text a little bit you have the
printed text but I have to give this
part um it was asked what would happen
if a person had cancer and then were in
a car accident and what would be on the
death certificate it anybody watch the
TV program
bones I love it well it's forensic
anthropology and what you're supposed to
do is premortem perimortem postmortem
premortem doesn't really work with
anything there for the evidence
postmortem well the person may have died
here and fallen into a river lungs are
not filled with water it wasn't a
drowning we look at the forensic
evidence right here the perimortem and
eliminating by evidentiary and
systematic examination this is the cause
of death and so in the situation that
you hypothesized it would not be the
cancer that was the cause of death nor
would it be necessarily the crash but
the traumatic injury and what was the
specific thing a torn order or don't it
sound so
knowledgeable these things are important
to take a look at so that the Integrity
of the death certificate would have to
really say cause of death ingesting of
overdose of medication drug whatever it
might be so that's an important fact I
think it must
be a reliable death certificate and
that's okay that's the truth the other
thing that's important for me is in the
bill it says that the person must have
free will and give consent and of sound
mind and conscious and the document will
witness that this is the person's Free
Will for
us that becomes a very serious issue for
a Catholic human being and a Catholic
Church why because for time in
Memorial the conditions for a mortal sin
and Catholics will understand this
others may not and that's all right but
this is our
situation the conditions for mortal sin
that the person knows it is Gravely
wrong that the full consent of the will
I choose this I want to do this no
matter and then actually committing the
ACT what will happen is as we've had
suicides many times and we we say it's
the the poor person was tragically upset
not in the right mind we offer the the
mass there's compassion we do everything
we can what this bill will I apologize
Bishop but that's your time if you want
to give a one sentence sure very quickly
this bill will be actually making a very
very terrible situation and a disclaimer
would have to be in any kind of
advertising or we would have to make
this very clear that this is seriously
wrong for a Catholic to inv be involved
in so it is in a sense a persecution of
our faith thank you any questions at all
seeing none thank you
question Bishop we have a question if
you wouldn't mind representative Smith
I'm sorry yes thank thank you very much
for being here we certainly appreciate
it do you see anything in this bill that
in any way would
require um anyone to
participate whatever their religion is
or their belief um
uh well do do you see any anything in
there oh no no it would be the person's
choice but to be influenced to make that
choice without realizing the
consequences would be horrible thank you
good thank you so much thank
you Kelly roachford
thank you for your service to New
Hampshire my name is Kelly
rodford because of my professional
experience I support this bill I'm a
board certified licensed massage
therapist with 25 years experience and a
specialty supporting those with terminal
diagnosis I am also an end of life Doula
and have been a respected team member of
a local hospice
agency nobody wants to talk about
gruesome
death but there are certain types of
conditions that the amazing tools of
hospice care can't
manage I'm going to say that again there
are certain types of conditions that the
amazing tools of hospice care can't
manage bleeding to death is one of these
this is because some Types of cancerous
tumors can't be managed in ways that
prevent them from
rupturing I have been and hospice team
meetings where colleagues discussed
needing to tell a patient and their
loved ones to buy red or dark towels in
preparation for their
death so imagine this for yourself or
your loved one you have a terminal
cancer and your hospice nurse tells you
to have dark towels on hand to prepare
for your
death why because the risk that your
inoperable cancer cancerous tumor will
rupture and will cause you to bleed to
death the dark towels will help to
disguise the blood from your dying
process so that this will be less
distressing for you and your loved ones
to
witness this is horrific and this is
tragic bleeding to death is inhumane it
is terrifying to the dying person and
deeply traumatic for their loved ones
which adds even more heartache and grief
we can and we must do better the
terminally ill deserve to be comforted
by their favorite blanket not surrounded
by a stack of dark towels while they and
their loved ones live out the final days
of their life waiting in fear for their
Timebomb tumor to
rupture please support the end the New
Hampshire end of life Freedom Act and
vote to end this kind of avoidable
suffering for the terminally ill and for
their loved ones at the end of life
thank you I will take
questions seeing none thank
you Susan
jenden Sue jren from London Dairy New
Hampshire um I oppose this bill I ask
you to oppose it uh because it's
problematic on many levels and I'll
address uh some of the sections in the
bill um 137 section
137m in the definitions attending
healthc care provider the definition is
vague and does not specify the person in
this role has a certification or a
degree and this is critical since the
person can prescribe Medical Aid in
dying Med
medications section six
health care provider there is no
guarantee that the health care provider
will be your PCP who knows you
personally or who has had experience in
meeting your physical and emotional
needs section seven informed decision
speaks to providing a mentally capable
individual about what they are about to
do we know from other states and
countries that those in vulnerable
condition that appear to be to be
mentally capable can be easily
influenced really who can tell if
someone is mentally in a c mentally
capable state who's evaluating
them and under the same SE section e the
individual's right to withdraw a request
pursuant to this chapter or consent of
any treatment at any time so the
question is how can anyone who after
taking the Pres prescribed pills
withraw the requests or Express that he
or she has changed his or her mind there
is no detail about what happens after
the person has taken the
pills what if they're unable to speak or
unable to move any part of their body
it's quite possible that people have
second thoughts after taking the the
pills Section 8 medical late and dying
states that a healthc care provider
evaluates the requests determines
qualification and prescribe medications
to a qualified individual who may self
administer the medications what is the
definition of a qualified
individual and under the consent
requests for medications to end my life
in peace in a peaceful manner the last
statement reper refers to making the
decision on my own without coercion
under influence from other individuals
institutions
Etc is most violated in Canada stories
are coming out of Canada that speak
about relatives pressuring to their
their loved ones and nursing homes
pressuring the elderly as we heard from
Camila the premise of this bill is to
give indiv individuals who fear a future
of suffering before their natural death
a quick exit before they their appointed
time to die I'm sorry that's your time
pre yes preempting God's um plan plan
for the individual so I believe that
educating people um through the Hospice
Services which I I use personally for my
father who had cancer throughout his
body um regarding and they helped um Mar
ma Valley hospice helped um in M
managing the pain thank you any
questions at
all seeing none thank
you Tom fennel Fel
if my mother could see me
now thank you for allowing me to speak
to HP
254 I grew up in a small town in Upstate
New York New York where all of my family
were First Responders my dad and all my
uncles were fireman my mother and all my
aunts were in the auxiliary and they
many of them were em qualified I
continued to found the tradition of
being a first responder when I joined
the military's first responder the Coast
Guard in
1958 was I was served as the hospital
Corman during that
time these days I a last responder as a
hospice volunteer in Greater
Nashua and what what the Red Sox refer
to as a utility player I do everything
that's ask except sing I um I
participate in veteran
ceremonies I cook at the cook at the
hosit house I sit vigils and most
importantly I um serve as a companion to
people um it is
each assignment is like a blind date
some of them are very shortlived some of
them grow into very dear
friends an upshot of
being a a Hos volunteer in my interest
in HB
254 I'm also honored to be a member of
the New Hampshire end of Alliance
options and end of life
options um
I have read and reread the bill and uh
am confident that the uh things that are
necessary to qualify are very sound and
that the safeguards are very very are
there for a very good
reason I have talked with hospice
Volunteers in Vermont and
Maine the respective laws that they deal
with are are similar to the ones that is
under consideration here and what they
report is that their jobs as volunteers
didn't change a bit they continue to
listen to care to be aware of the
limitations of pallative medicine and to
co co-s suffer with individuals and
their
families
um Then They Mourn whether or
not the person took the medication
and closing hospice people professionals
and my fellow volunteers are the best
people I've ever met and um I en
encourage you if you have the time to
become a hosit volunteer you'll do good
and you'll feel good that is your time
sir thank you again for the opportunity
to
speak thank you any questions at all
seeing none thank you
Bonnie
Dunham thank
you my name is Bonnie Dunham I live in
marac New Hampshire and I oppos this
bill my husband and I provided end of
life care for his brother for two years
in our home he died on Christmas morning
um a couple of years ago so I understand
how emotional this issue is but as the
parent of an adult son with disabilities
who experiences significant medical comp
complexities this bill scares the beesus
out of me Sean's an active member of our
community but when he was born infants
with Down Syndrome were routinely
allowed to die if they had any medical
condition at all they were starved to
death I don't believe that anyone in who
supports this bill Who's involved in
this Bill wishes people with
disabilities any harm I don't believe
that for a second but it doesn't mean it
won't happen as then Governor Maggie
Hassen who has personal experience with
this issue with disability issues stated
in her June 2015 veto message for House
Bill 151 which would have established a
committee to study end of life decisions
I believe that the goal of this bill
begins to take New Hampshire down a
precarious path the ama's code of ethics
defines assisted suicide as when a bill
when a physician facilitates a patient's
death by providing the necessary means
Andor information to enable the patient
to perform the life-ending act that is
exactly what this bill allows the AMA
the National Council on disability and
many other prominent National disability
organizations oppose physicians
assistant Su suicide bills in their
report on the dangers of um to people
with disabilities of legalizing suicide
the National Council on disability notes
that those bills tend to contain
provisions included intended to
safeguard patients from problems or
abuse however their research showed that
these Provisions are ineffective and
often fail to protect patients in a
variety of ways including that insurers
have Divi have denied expensive life-
sustaining medical treatment but offered
to subsidize legal drugs instead I've
included several examples in my in my
written testimony people with
disabilities and other marginalized
groups are particularly vulnerable to
Social and financial coercion to choose
the Physicians assist suicide due to a
lack of Support Services family members
are often required to become full-time
caregiv givers at significant social and
financial cost annual reports from
Washington and Oregon found that half of
the people who sought lethal drugs
through physici assisted suicide
reported being a burden on family
friends and caregivers as their primary
reasons that's definitely that's a
serious problem but there are better
Solutions than this one the US C
Conference of Catholic Bishops states
that Medical Aid and dying SL assisted
suicide Fosters discrimination by
creating two classes of people those
suici whose suicides we spend hundreds
of millions of dollars each year to
prevent and those who suicides we assist
and treat as positive good suicide is
the second leading cause of death among
10 to 30 year olds in New Hampshire and
because of sorry that is your time if
you want suicide cont contagion means
that suicide increases when bills like
this are passed we don't want that
please recommend I any questions see n
thank you uh Reverend Mary
James good afternoon and thank you
members of the committee on this long
afternoon for your kind attention I am
the Reverend Mary James a resident of
Durham and a retired United Church of
Christ
Minister during my 45 career in social
work and Ministry it was my deep
privilege to be with many dear people
people at the end of their lives far too
many experienced unrelieved forms of
suffering even with hospice
care my beloved husband Bob was one of
them he was a lifelong advocate for
people with disabilities and devoted his
professional life to that he experienced
a traumatic death that he had dearly
hoped to avoid he had a terminal illness
and would have qualified for Medical Aid
and dying under this law but because we
live here it was not there for
him even with hospice care great hospice
care and all the love and support I and
my kids and grandkids and friends and
wonderful community and church offered
Bob he endured unrelieved pain and other
terrible forms of
suffering no one like Bob who qualifies
for Ma should have to die the way he
did this goes right to the heart of the
question of conscience of course and in
my view as a clergy woman Medical Aid in
dying as described under this law is a
deeply compassionate highly ethical
caring option for those who desire it
and who have gone through the rigorous
and extensively safeguarded qualifying
process including of course the ability
to self- inest the liquid medication
there are no injections or pills as it's
practiced in our
country it is an act of Loving Care to
allow a suffering dying person the
option of choosing a peaceful painless
death I respect other religious
objections to this option but folks who
have those concerns need not pursue it
in any way no one can compel anyone to
participate in this in any way who
doesn't wish to
the state should not stand in the way of
terminally ill folks having the freedom
to choose this gentle caring option for
oneself and I will leave you with this
question who
benefits When someone like my dear
beautiful husband who fought so hard to
live and finally understood and that
made peace with the fact that his
disease would kill him who
benefits When someone like that that
whose sound of
Mind suffering agonally and facing the
prospect of a very traumatic death who
benefits When a man like that that's
your time if you can bleeds out in a
fire hose of blood through his
tracheostomy and drowns in his own blood
in the middle of the night who benefits
from that no one thank you any questions
at all thank
you Alexander
leran hi my name is Alexander landrian
and I live in
Madbury suicide is an issue that has
deeply impacted My Generation not that
that's a shock to anyone here we've
heard stories all throughout this
afternoon everyone's been touched by in
some way and I know the sound of those
devastating phone calls all too well in
high school a close friend of mine
attempted suicide I was the one who
called 911 and I beat the ambulance to
her house more than a decade later in
that crisp fall afternoon is still
seared into my brain with each passing
year suicide has become more and more
prevalent as someone who has spent much
of my adult life working with teenagers
I shared the grave concern that many
adults feel
the CDC reports that it's the second
leading leading cause of death for 10 to
24 year olds with a 62% increase from
2007 to
2021 lgbtq plus youth are nearly four
times more likely to attempt suicide
than their heterosexual peers according
to the Trevor Project's 2024 survey
we're facing an epidemic and now we're
going to legalize this by giving
individuals with terminal illness
Medical Aid and dying medication I urge
us all to consider the broader
implications by passing this bill we
send a message intended or not that
there are circumstances where suicide is
acceptable and even
dignified how do I explain this to the
teenagers that I work with what happens
when the law not only legalizes suicide
but Champions it the Bill's safeguards
Overlook the most significant factor in
suicide the human mind feelings of being
a burden pressure loss of selfworth
those can't be legislated away suicide
doesn't care about safety mechanisms
anyone working with teens know that
culture matters just as much to them as
the law and what culture does this bill
create the message will reach far beyond
those with six months to live if we
normalize suicide even in the case of
terminal illness we risk eroding the
strong cultural and moral stance we
fought to build against it we risk
inadvertently reinforcing the idea that
life is Expendable when becomes
difficult instead of a expanding access
to Suicide we should invest in paliative
Care Mental Health Services and suicide
prevention for all ages every life is
worth fighting for thank you for the
opportunity to testify
today thank
you okay this one I'm struggling with I
apologize
[Music]
Ry Jane
juwel uh Nottingham
it looks like R AE j e it's either w l
or
NE super
rain
how could you help us out with that one
good afternoon my name is rilen Shippy
rice is that what that
says could be it notingham maybe close
close all right I live in Nottingham New
Hampshire and I'm here today to speak in
strong support of House Bill
254 also known as New Hampshire end of
life Freedom Act a app
title I've been a registered nurse for
over 50 years 60 years a long time and
in that time I provided care and support
to many patients who were dying and to
their family
members but today I speak to you not
only as a professional nurse with a
specialty in care of older adults but as
a person who learn firsthand how severe
pain and illness can lead to a violent
death the kind of death you have the
power to
prevent please hear my personal story my
father who had just celebrated his 75th
birthday with all his family present
died of a self-inflicted gunshot wound
two days later his death was
precipitated by his inability to Contin
to continue enduring the severe physical
pain he'd suffered for many years caused
by an illness at the hands of the US
government
that was
then why must someone today 50 years
later who is nearing the end of life
suffering from severe pain and
discomfort and saying to their
providers I want this to be over I'm
ready to die now I don't want to do this
anymore why will they not be allowed to
receive Medical Aid to achieve these
goals gos without having to endure
further pain and
suffering for my father there was no
medical support to help him and his
suffering so he tried to do it himself
alone in the
Woodshed had there been medical a Aid in
dying in
1964 we as his family would have been at
his my father's side holding his hand
sharing family stories Kissing him
goodbye telling him how much he loved
him and what a great dad and grandfather
he had been instead we heard a
gunshot
ran blast ran to the Woodshed and found
him lying there bleeding to
death thus my father died in even
greater physical pain as a result of his
attempt to end his pain filled
life he could have been
helped in my earlier professional career
I apologize is that your time if if you
could gra it oh in my earlier career I
listen to patients near the end of life
say please let me die please help me to
go we could not help them then we can
help though we cannot help those today
who ask us the same questions but you
are represent atives can help them you
have the power to enact a bill that will
allow patients who are dying to receive
Medical Aid to achieve their own defined
goals release from
Pain ending their suffering and dying in
peace thank you thank you for your
attention to our patients thank
you George camer
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to speak
in opposition to elville 254 my name is
George kramlinger and I'm a resident of
Dober I'm also a 26-year military
officer veteran and entering my seventh
year in the professional fire
service military personnel and First
Responders see and experience Things
That No human being should have to
experence experience the stress and the
trauma from these experiences often
pushes them to the brink some of them
cross that Brink and take their own Lies
by committing
suicide suicide rates among First
Responders and military personnel are at
an all-time
high legalizing suicide for any reason
even if well-intentioned has the
unintended consequence of lowering the
threshold of the acceptance of suicide
in our society Our Heroes and Patriots
need a helping hand not a push I urge
you to not support this Bill thank
you thank
you Jill
fimble hello my name is Jill fimble
thank you I'm a mental health provider
in the state of New Hampshire and I own
a practice in Amherst I'm in support of
this bill I don't have a enough time to
read my statement but I did pass it out
to you um what I would like to do is
just briefly describe my my scenario um
that I wrote about it was various uh
ways that people would research and
attempt to end their life when they
don't have any options for Humane Ways
to Die uh one of the options I wrote
about did happen to my father and he
researched all of those ways and they
will continue to happen in this state um
I would like like also to adjust the
clear difference between suicide the
word suicide when we use it and when we
are struggling with emotional pain
versus physical
pain there's a lot of treatment that we
have for emotional pain and there's
always room in the future to grow and
heal and manage that pain and reduce the
suffering this is very different when we
talk about medically assisted suicide
when it categorizes you in physical pain
in the category of terminal illness and
additionally within that six-month
estimate in hospice care they're very
different I have training in end of life
and grief and family Dynamics and I
would be able to utilize that with my
colleagues to increase the amount of
safety if this bill were to be utilized
and I would be very willing to take
additional training um to increase a
specific Niche for this if we pass the
bill um that medical providers can
assist families in making the right
choice um lastly I completed oh and also
in addition to that we we take a lot of
Ethics courses to maintain our license
and um supervision on on such things so
people should have an area of expertise
would be the most ethical um and lastly
I spent an entire year becoming
certified in psychedelic assisted
therapy uh we can only utilize this in
our state through ketamine at this time
and we're waiting for other medicines to
come online legally um but psychedelic
assisted therapy is very um profound in
helping existential crisis with the end
of life as well as PTSD and treatment
resistant depression um I plan to uh
continue to utilize this and help
families and connect with local uh end
of life duas or death duas in the state
and I feel that passing this bill would
be a trifecta of care in that they could
have a prescription uh to give them
peace of mind and they don't have to
fill the prescription or use the
prescription until they need to um but
just wanted to reiterate that as a
healthcare provider and the mental
health specifically we are trying to
have the most ethical standards for
people that need it and it wouldn't be
misused any questions at all and my
closing statement is just that um as we
come into this world our our birth
journey is medically assisted and that
is to make it more comfort aable and
safe and so our death Journey should be
medically assisted so it is safe and
more comfortable thank you thank
you Father Andrew
Nelson my name my name is Father Andrew
Nelson I'm from summersworth and thank
you to the committee for listening for
all of us with all of us today in my
work as a priest I've attended over a
thousand deaths I've attended even more
people who are suffering and struggling
throughout their life I've served at the
number one Hospital in the world and
seen some of the most complicated cases
the conversation that happens when the
doctors and nurses leave and when the
family leaves too and when the person
like myself comes in the room and who's
only there to listen and to company the
number one thing I hear is not a wish
that one had more money or any of those
things the number one thing I hear from
people at suffering at the end of life
is the worry they have for those that
leave behind including many I suspect in
this room have experienced that the
worry for those they would leave behind
the worry that they've been a burden
because they've been suffering and
struggling through so much throughout
the end of their
life at the heart of
suicide is pressure and culture and this
bill does nothing to protect those who
are vulnerable from either the heart of
suicide is The Whispers that come in
one's mind that they're a burden that
there people don't want them around or
that they're tired with them or even
that the suffering which can be intense
and Beyond things that any of us here
can understand are very real but that
pressure and culture around one who is
suffering and behind and around every
single suicide whether for those
assisted in dying or assisted Physicians
assisted suicide or those who are young
people it's the same Whispers And the
same pressure and no safeguards in law
can protect people from that
and the danger of legalizing physician
assist to a suicide is it sends a clear
message that the answering to suffering
is
death everyone here on this committee
should remember it was only a few
decades ago that National media
descended on gtown high school and it
was called suicide High because they had
a contagion of Youth suicide because one
youth committed suicide and the next
said well I'm struggling too so it's not
a a bad idea and the next thing you know
the ideas is implanted in the hearts and
the minds of the vulnerable some people
here have said a physician assist with
suicide doesn't increase the likelihood
that those around them will commit
suicide the nhi study actually isn't the
contrary to that if your spouse commits
suicide the likelihood that that person
will commit suicide increases by
300% if it's a member of your family the
nhi study says
200% culture and pressure are real and
we send a direct message that we're okay
without those who are suffering when we
legalize something like that despite all
the good intention and I think everyone
here has good intention in their heart
but that pressure and all those things
are real if you had asked me when I was
in high school would culture ever shift
enough that kids would worry about
whether it' be shot at school I would
have said you were crazy and yet we've
watched culture that's your time if you
okay can I finish for sure if You' ask
me we'd had a culture where we worried
about Civil War because of political
division I would have said such a
cultural shift could never happen yet
we've watched it and I would ask all of
you to consider what cultural shift will
happen if we legalize this bill and I
remind you we are closer to Quebec than
we are to Augusta Maine we're not that
different any questions at all see none
thank
you Katherine Brown
I'm Katherine Brown from Ryan New
Hampshire I'm here because I have had
personal experience of the inability of
hospice to control pain at the end of
life but I'm reading a statement from Dr
Philip lson of the Littleton
area who couldn't be here my name is Dr
Philip Lawson of the Littleton area and
I'm a physician with 30 years of
practice experience across the healthare
Spectrum in New
Hampshire my thinking and beliefs
regarding maid have changed over the
course of my career I have always
believed in the personal spiritual and
relational growth that can be achieved
in the hard work of caring for the
dying ma should not and cannot replace
this
work but my patience continue to teach
me with rare exception and that without
my mentioning it they have told me that
they want the ability to have access to
maid I have had patients of all
spiritual Traditions abilities and
disabilities occupations and belief
systems including to my shock a retired
devout Catholic nun request information
about access to
maid my patients don't think they will
use maid but they want to know that it
can be there for them if they choose
they want the Solace comfort and sense
of control in its
availability as an emergency room doctor
and palea of medicine consultant I have
sat with many patients as they have died
I have encountered situations of
uncontrollable suffering at the deepest
level I have seen despite best efforts
and best palean when dying is not
spiritual growth but indelible
trauma I've heard many accounts of
patients friends and family who have
chosen made for some the experience is
life-altering
for example my sister was invited to
celebrate the life caner
bedbound with uncontrolled pain despite
optimal
pale she sat with her neighbor his wife
and their two pre-teen children to
celebrate his life in his last hours
alert and aware in pain on his terms it
was to date the most moving and
meaningful experience of my sister's
life
as chair of the hos um the Ethics
Committee at my hospital I have
struggled with the well documented and
reported ethical Arguments for and
against made I believe that my medical
colleagues can uphold the carefully
developed standards and guard guard
veils to stop inappropriate influence or
utilization we do not all share the same
values my work is focused on doing all I
can to honor my patients values and not
oppose my I'm sorry that's your time you
can wrap it
up I now believe it is our
responsibility for those who are already
dying to honor and support how they wish
their final hours to be lived I hope you
will consider carefully your role in
this process and support
hb24 thank you James
Farrell thank you members of the
committee my name is James Farrell I'm
from Lee New
Hampshire and I wish to oppose this
bill because quite frankly it is written
in dishonest
language it attempts to be a bill not
about assisted suicide when we all know
and as many people have testified here
it is a bill about assisted suicide and
that the sponsors know it is proposing
assisted suicide side is made evidence
by the many attempts to find less
alarming more palatable language with
which to describe the act of a person
taking his or her own life yet all the
euphemisms and rhetorical flourishes
cannot change the underlying fact that
this bill will codify assisted suicide
it's interesting to examine the text of
the bill and see the many attempts at
these sort of definitional slights of
hand according to the text quote death
in accordance with this chapter shall
not be designated suicide or homicide
but indeed how does sensible people
Define suicide the dictionary says
suicide is quote the act or an instance
of ending one's own life voluntarily or
intentionally and isn't that what this
bill is permitting
right the sponsors also know their
proposal is morally suspect how that's
betrayed by their insistence that the
next in the next section of the bill
that the death quote shall not be cause
of death quote shall not be indicated on
the death
certificate well why
not if what they propose is noble and
decent and
civilized who could object to having a
public record made of such a death right
so instead the bill wants to make State
sanctioned falsification of a vital
record the linguistic gymnastics are
perhaps most in evidence with the
definitions related to healthc care we
talk talks a lot about health care
providers but what is Health Care Health
Care according to the
dictionary involves efforts made to
maintain restore or promote someone's
physical mental or em emotional
well-being does this bill do any of
those things does it Aid the dying
person to maintain restore and promote
Health then the bill repeatedly refers
to the Medical Aid in dying
medication that's a very curious way to
say
poison medicine the dictionary reminds
us is a substance or a preparation used
used in treating disease it's something
that affects well-being I apologize sir
that's your time give a one sentence
wrap I I would just encourage you to
oppose this bill or at the very least
start calling it by an honest title
perhaps help sick people kill themselves
with poison act thank you have a
question sir would you answer a question
sure representative Perez thank you
thanks for taking my question are you
will since you examined this bill so
completely are you well aware that there
is a page and a half
protecting the physician from any
consequences for doing this yes I saw
that there that neither participation in
or refusal to participate in would
result in any consequences on the other
hand coercion as people have pointed out
which can be sometimes very subtle right
could carry penalties coercing coercing
a person to commit suicide or trying to
discourage by coercion a person from
doing this could be considered a felony
so yes thank
you any other questions thank you Gordon
lvery my seventh in in
stretch I'm Gordon ly from King and I
support this bill and I'm here to tell
my wife's end of life story
Marcy's six-year battle with cancer was
over she was in hospice no more
terrifying life-prolonging
interventions Marcy had endured so much
to live to be a friend to so many died
at age
72 as her end of life neared we had a
dream a peaceful painless and dignified
death at home surrounded by loving
family and friends and a couple of real
DieHard cats
let me share instead the anguish and
frustration we endured in trying to
realize that dream and how we failed
largely because New Hampshire did not
have a law like HB 254 in the year
2020 Marcy and I researched end of life
options we could let nature take its
course with help from hospice Marcy
might gradually decline into a medicated
coma or she might die suddenly and
painfully gasping for breath with family
as terrified and helpless bystandard we
had been
there Vermont had a six-month residency
requirement in 2020 a deal breaker we
learned about dignitas an organization
in Switzerland that provides medical
assistance and dying we found the
$10,000 needed and spent months
Gathering documents the best of our bad
options we were ready to fly when
Switzerland closed its border due to the
covid Pand
mic but a person determined to hasten
the end of life and I want to emphasize
hasten this is a person who's going to
die it's just a matter of
when person who chooses to hasten their
end of life in their final days has many
options an overdose of meds for example
but this is suicide now and anyone
assisting can face criminal charges
social stigma and risk of failure
sometimes
catastrophic and sometimes while plans
are being made death just comes on
bidden at age 880 I am in great health
but when my end nears I plan to die in
the same bed my wife died in at a time I
feel is right in the freedom of privacy
of my home and there's really nothing
the state of New Hampshire can do about
that isn't it time to give the
terminally ill and their families a
better option than leaving the state or
the country to Access Medical Aid and
dying free them from the risks and
stigma of suicide give them the comfort
of a legal option in New Hampshire even
if we never use it help more of us
realize that end of life dream we all
share vote in favor Marcy would
approve thank
you stepen
Wade uh members of the committee uh my
name is Steve Wade I'm the executive
director of The Brain Injury Association
of New Hampshire and also a member of
the New Hampshire Coalition of Suicide
Prevention which is a coalition of
disability organizations opposed to
physician assisted
suicide I'm here to speak in opposition
of Medical Aid and dying by physician
assisted suicide of course they go
together it's medical and dying by
physician assisted suicide um I just
wanted to share as to I know a lot has
has been mentioned today but I wanted to
share about why does the disability why
is the disability community so concerned
about this issue and I think one one of
the key reasons is many people with
disability are on Medicaid they don't
have access generally to the best health
care or best supports and people on
Medicaid and most people with disability
particularly people with brain injury do
not have access to good quality
paliative care and that is critical and
it's it's something we've been working
on for for many years trying to really
strengthen paliative care for people
with
disabilities you know we fear though if
this bill passes there'll be no
incentive to strengthen p of care for
the most vulnerable for folks on
Medicaid and I think that's borne out by
the other states that have passed uh
legislation such as this the other point
was um we talk about uh the majority I
think it was mentioned the majority
support this law well we're not a
majoritarian democracy we the minority
matters I I remember a quote by Senator
Hubert Humphrey who said that the
measure of a democracy is how it treats
the minority how it treats people who
are vulnerable who are at risk so again
please it's the the people that are
underserved those are the folks we need
to really worry about I also wanted to
talk about veterans living with
traumatic brain injury uh and and
oftentimes co-occurring PTSD I've spent
30 years as executive director of The
Brain Injury Association we saw some
really terrible things coming out of the
war on terror many veterans in the state
with traumatic brain injury and
extremely high risk for suicide I think
the highest of all veteran populations
so our team at the Brain Injury
Association has spent the last 5 years
really trying to build a strong
culture of we call help seeking trying
to encourage veterans and their family
caregivers to seek help within the
community certainly within the brain
injury Community unfortunately I think a
bill like this goes in the opposite
direction it really focuses not on
help-seeking but the opposite of help
seeking maybe seeking a death perhaps
you know I it's just it just goes
against a lot of hard work over many
many years by many folks who have been
Advocates uh for
veterans I also want to suggest that
sending that passing this bill does send
a the wrong message certainly as the
Judiciary Committee you well aware that
the law teaches the law says what we
value as a culture as a society and I
think again when something like this a
bill like this passes it's it's sending
a message it's saying this is what we
value this is what the law values this
is what we as a legislature
value we've also heard that this isn't
suicide well we that's your time if you
could wrap okay thanks let me just wrap
up there quickly so um anyway the
foundational medical ethic Do no harm I
think is in great danger if this bill
passes so thank you very
much thank you Lee May
Mr chairman members of the committee my
name is Lee May
and I am a resident of the Kendall
retirement community in
Handover a close friend of my wife Linda
and me had a husband with terminal brain
cancer when he received the pro
prognosis of having six months or less
to live he was able to use Vermont's
Medical Aid in dying procedures by doing
so he saved himself months of suffering
his last words were on to my Great
Adventure next great adventure his wife
our friend was comforted by how Serene
and peaceful his death was several years
later our widowed friend was now living
at Kendall she had developed a rare form
of anemia called MDS syndrome it left
her utterly exhausted and it was
developing into leukemia last year her
doctors informed her that she had six
months or less to live unless she
received increasing ly frequent
transfusions even with that treatment
she would become weaker and weaker and
would soon be unable to live
independently remembering how peaceful
her husband's death had been she decided
to use Vermont's Medical Aid in dying
procedure but think about it to use
Medical Aid in dying an 85-year-old
terminally ill Widow with no family left
had to make repeated trips to Vermont to
fulfill all the requirements necessary
to ending her life as she
wished this past December she invited
friends including Linda and me and her
doctor to the Vermont home made
available by two of the Vermont friends
to be with her as she died we spent the
morning talking and laughing as we
celebrated her life then she drank the
strong medication that she had been
prescribed as she became drowsy she said
I want you to take in how un agonizing
this is take that out as a message about
the value of the gift of Medical Aid and
dying I also for one heard her say as
she was close to falling asleep for the
last time
wow thank you for granting me this
opportunity to
speak thank
you Sue Allen
good afternoon my name is Sue Allen I'm
a resident of
Hollis I'm asking you to oppose this
bill we have heard admonishments for you
to ignore the projections and
predictions as to the results and
effects of uh uh Medical Aid and dying
we heard this um earlier this afternoon
but I I uh I I wonder why would we
blindfold ourselves to um how the uh
suicide laws have have played out
elsewhere many points have been made
here um but really what I see as a core
of this
is that
your determinations are going to uh
assign by law who is authorized to
administer
death I believe that's the core of the
question um the interesting part here
now is um the testimony of my oldest
Aunt who joined the Red Cross
immediately at the end of World War II
she was sent to
Germany I grew up with her repeated
testimony so that none of us would ever
forget it that uh in 1946 the German
doctors and nurses told the Americans
how the old people's institutions were
emptied and the handicapped institutions
were emptied so yes I want to emphasize
the slippery slope there are other
examples have already been testified
here today about how the 10,000 suicides
in um uh or use of this in Canada has in
a very short amount of time gone to
13,000 anyway there there are all these
other examples that I think we need to
consider and um the one example that I
want you seriously to consider is organ
harvesting isn't isn't that the next
discussion about appending a uh
suggestion that anyone who is sign on
freely and willingly to Medical Aid and
dying would please also agree to or
harvesting but the actual issue with
that when you read about it and I got
this from the um population Research
Institute because the Chinese are doing
it to the yugar if that's how you
pronounce their name um it actually the
best organ harvesting is right before
the moment of death so I leave you with
that that um please oppose this bill for
the reason that we don't consider death
treatment we don't want death to become
a duty uh we need Suicide Prevention not
suicide promotion so I ask you to oppose
thank you thank
you Mark
lroy followed by representative Glenn
Celli
afterwards you're on
Mr chair uh my name is Mark lroy I live
in conquer but I was brought up in
Berlin I am a Catholic as my father was
a devout Catholic in fact my father uh
was very good friends with Father
Andrew and uh I just want to tell uh my
story just last week I attended a
funeral at St an's Church in Berlin for
the mother of my best friend in high
school and his mom had moved from Berlin
to to live with his
sister at the reception after the
funeral he told me his mom was diagnosed
as being terminal and only had a few
weeks to live she chose to go back to
her daughter's house where medical
assistance and dying is
permitted so he went up to be with her
and during her last few moments when her
breathing was difficult and the end was
obiously near my friend a retired
physician sat on the edge of the bed
picked up his mother and hugged her as
she she died in his arm and he says was
very loving and very powerful
movement and I want to contrast that to
my father my 90-year-old father after
years long battle he was diagnosed as
terminal and while in the hospital he
was able to finally convince the
Physicians for pallative care he had to
be transferred from the hospital to the
hospice house by ambulance which caused
him great discomfort once at hospice
house I gave him excellent care he was
medicated he was snowed he didn't seem
like he had any pain he was
nonresponsive but he lasted two weeks I
saw his body just shrivel up and I was
spending 18-hour days at hospice house
with him but I went home to shower and
to change my clothes and I received the
call that he had died I was not with him
he had died
alone and I
know because he kept telling me if I
could have a
and just go I would go I'm ready to meet
my maker my time is up I'm just ready to
meet my maker um so I will ask you uh
which scenario would you prefer if it
was your parent please support HB 254
thank
you thank
you representative Glenn
cordelli thank you members of the
committee uh Glenn cordelli state
representative representing tuon burough
wolf BR and H in the beautiful Lakes
Region and I oppose this legislation and
I'll start with a personal reason um I
was adopted a couple of months old from
orphanage in New York
City two years later my parents took me
back to that same orphanage I picked out
my
sister at age 39 she was diagnosed after
a messy divorce diagnosed with stage
four ovarian
cancer she lived in pain for 10 years
she was dubbed the miracle woman of
Western
Massachusetts she finally gave up when
her youngest son said it it's okay Mom
I'll be okay I remember that hospital
room I'll never forget it we stood
holding hands at her bedside saying the
Lord's Prayer lightning and thunder
outside the window as she
died there's no doubt in my mind that
God was in that room for some people
people of Faith they don't look forward
to death but they don't fear it either
because they know eternity lies
ahead um next I found this card in my
mailbox today it's a breakfast mental
health and suicide prevention in the
granite state how long before we see
cards like this uh call Joe for assisted
suicide if this bill comes to the floor
with an aut to pass recommendation
I will have a floor amendment to repeal
sections of Statute for veteran Suicide
Prevention assistance and for RSA 193 J
Suicide Prevention in the schools why
bother thank
you thank
you Betsy walkerman
hi thank you glad to be here all the way
from
Vermont I'm Betsy walkerman I'm
president of patient choices Vermont and
we are the nonprofit organization that
serves as the primary educational
resource for Medical Aid and dying in
Vermont so we have 11 years of
experience with a bill that's a law
that's very similar to the bill that is
in front of you many of the issues that
and concerns that have been brought up
today many of the questions committee
members have asked we have experience
with and we're happy to talk to you
about any detail either today or in
separate
meetings I'm here today because I want
to bring the story of a New Hampshire
resident who is coming to Vermont for
Medical Aid and dying his name is Barry
daer this is uh uh these are words that
he authorized me to share with you
um he says when I got my cancer
diagnosis the first thing that came to
mind was Medical Aid and dying in
Vermont because I know how difficult
this end stage for this aggressive lung
cancer will be this really hit me my dad
died of lung cancer too and he used
Medical Aid in
dying um he knows how difficult it will
be I really don't want to put myself
through that I don't want to die but
that's the reality I have a terminal
illness
and so we had a long conversation about
his plans he became a um a patient of a
doctor in southern Vermont has made
several visits already I asked him if
there were some words that he would like
to convey to the legislature here in in
New
Hampshire and he says quote it's not an
easy Journey for anybody who is dying to
travel to another state for people who
want Medical Aid and dying to not have
that ability in my home state is a
severe
hardship I've seen in the polls that the
vast majority of New Hampshire people
want this option so people don't have to
go through a very cumbersome process and
go to another state in order to make the
choice they want to
make he also said I want to say to the
people in Vermont thank you so very
much for making this option to determine
the end of my life in the way I choose
possible so honestly with the number of
people who have been contacting Us in
Vermont since we lifted The Residency
requirement I think it's time for people
in other states including New Hampshire
to step up and to listen to these
constituents I can tell you that um
since May of
2023 um more than 1300 people from New
Hampshire have perused the the our we
website looking for information on
Medical Aid and dying 1300 people are
already looking I apologize that's your
time if you can wrap that up thank you
well I'm happy to share any other
information we have never had a um a
complaint or a whisper of abuse in 11
years in Vermont and I hope you will
positively consider this Bill thank you
we have a question if you if you don't
mind yes representative pz thank you
thanks for taking my question um you
said 1300 people have looked into it how
many people have actually gone to
Vermont and what do you charge for that
we don't charge for
that okay nobody makes money on this I
didn't say I just ask how many people
have actually gone the only data we have
so far is that from the Department of
Health for the year end of June
2024 there were 24 people from out of
state and that covers new there were
people from new um I don't think there
were any New Hampshire people in that in
that um in that group yet that was the
first um 12-month period um 24 people
came from out of state and 70 some from
Vermont um but the number of out of
state people is
growing any other
questions thank you thank you oh I have
Jules
good that's
okay I appreciate everybody's patience
today we want to make sure everybody's
heard
though hello members of the committee my
name is Jules good
I am a non-religious gay multiply
disabled person and I also happen to be
a national Disability Policy
professional from New Market I'm
testifying in opposition to HP
254 I know we've been here for a while
so if you take one thing for my
testimony please let it be this the
disabled people who oppose this bill do
so not because we don't understand the
bill not because we're controlled by
fear but because we know many
disabilities and illnesses can become
terminal if not treated properly and
land Us in the eligible category for
assisted suicide to say it has nothing
to do with disability is demonstrably
false I had lime disease which is an
easily treatable infection but because I
couldn't access treatment it progressed
to the point where my life was in danger
and it left me permanently disabled
there's a huge difference between being
a well-insured person having the privil
privilege of exhausting every available
treatment option before expressing a
desire to die and someone without that
privilege being repeatedly denied care
until death is their only option New
Hampshire is consistently ranked the
lowest among New England states in
providing long-term services and support
to older adults and disabled people when
people are forced to choose between
suffering and death because they can't
afford or access care they are not
getting a real choice this bill makes
systemically steering these people
toward death a protected Act even if
that's not its intent if you think those
deaths in any number are acceptable
because they're happening to people you
don't know or don't like or don't care
about you should reflect on that we do
not need to endanger vulnerable people
to get to a place where people who are
truly terminally ill can get appropriate
pain management at the end of life and
die in the setting of their choice we
can invest in training for medical
professionals to close knowledge gaps in
pain management and pation we can educ
educate providers and patients on
options for making their lives more
accessible through Mobility AIDS Home
Health Care Providers assist of
Technology home modifications and all of
the things us disabled people use on a
regular basis to live full and beautiful
lives it is unconscionable to pass a
policy that makes the true free choice
on whether to live or die a privilege
reserved for those with access to high
quality Health Care thank you and I'm
happy to answer any
questions any questions seeing none
thankk
you David
Zuckerman thank you very much for giving
me the opportunity to speak and I um
just want to say I really respect the
difficult choices in front of you as a
18-year policy maker in Vermont before I
became lieutenant governor for six years
I'm well aware of many of the topics
that you have to face and deliberate on
and thank you for listening to all of us
um I wanted to speak to this from a few
different perspectives one is my dad was
a doctor two is he died when I was 13
years old I remember visiting the
hospital with him in the years that I
can remember and the care that he took
with his patients as a a cardiothoracic
surgeon and the topic has come up of Do
no harm and the hypocritic oath my dad
would talk to patients who were maybe in
their late 70s who had what would now be
called stage four cancer lung cancer and
he would talk with them about surgery
and cracking their chest and not
recovery at that age versus managing
their pain or their
symptoms and they could make that
choice harm is really the definition of
the conversation between the doctor and
the patient and the patient having that
ability to contemplate the
options in this situation the option is
not whether to die or not to die
the the question is at what point and
under what conditions and under what
under what independent autonomy that
that individual so chooses and I think
it's really important because we've
heard about that a little bit about Do
no harm that individual is the one that
really ought to have that choice in that
conversation with their
doctor I also want to add that in
Vermont there was a lot of these similar
concerns brought up and I think they're
very um valid they're legitimate their
opinion their concerns but in Vermont
all of these were
raised and they have not come to pass
because of the provisions in the law
just as your bill
has you are not
Canada you are New Hampshire you get to
control the wording of your law and
whether it changes in the
future you can imagine to open it up
more is a huge task just as the way to
even pass the law would be so if people
are concerned about the law going down a
slippery slope I could just let you know
it has not done that in Vermont nor
other states in this country where
people are making sure folks are
protected I also want to add as a
lawmaker and to folks who are
constituents across the state the ways
to
address suicide for young people is to
fund counselors in
schools the way to address concerns
about um being a bir on one's family is
to make sure if you have a disability
that we
fund the services that help families and
help those individuals live the best
life they can so that there isn't that
pressure burden you can wrap it up thank
you um I'll just add that I've been
approached by many people in grocery
stores and other places who have come up
to me to say thank you that their loved
one died in the most loving and peaceful
way and that's not to say that other
people don't also have such
circumstances but they were all there
and I have two documents cuz someone
else forgot to hand in there so I'm
going to give you I am open to questions
as well are there any questions at all
seeing none thank you thank
you Laura
eloine she's
here hi my name is Laura Allison I
believe Laura elazim took my spot a
while
ago um but that's okay um so I was going
to address the slippery slope today and
I realized after listening to everyone
that I've been on the slippery slope for
the last three months my mother had a
terminal condition she was 85 years old
that's it she was quirky with a touch of
dementia and dementia is the term for a
collection of symptoms without a formal
diagnosis of disease pathology until
autopsy I was her designated health
proxy and my job was to Advocate her
wishes for her end of Life
Care um within a week of my mother's
admittance to the
hospital um I was told that she was not
going to get better her brain was not
going to get any better we knew this
this had been going on for years and she
lived at my
home
um so I over the next couple weeks I was
given a strong sales pitch for making
mom comfortable that word has a special
meaning that isn't what you think
um
and a hospice house had a bed available
this was an amazing opportunity they
told me to get this situation resolved
before the holidays as we were quickly
approaching Thanksgiving mom would be
given drugs to make her very sleepy for
a few days while her body would be
shutting down with no food or hydration
our family could spend quality time with
her since she would just be peacefully
sleeping but I want you to know she was
eating drinking walking and talking
still at this
time in charge of her care I could not
do this and she would not want this she
did not want this um to be clear I was
assured these drugs would not cause her
death but according to the Pala of Team
representative we can go right to the
hairy Edge if we have to Meanwhile mom
was confined drugs malnourished and
dehydrated to manage her dementia
symptoms and I'm hearing the question
this bill is not talking about elderly
or disabled but only for those of sound
mind but failing body to have options I
want to quote um representative margerie
Smith a sponsor of the bill this is a
very narrow and conservative Bill
designed that way to give New Hampshire
a chance to put its toe in the water
this is what concerns me what is the
water why put a toe in unless we're
testing for the viability of waiting in
ankles knees how about a swim this water
is a culture of death not decision not
Authority not dignity and not what
people necessarily are asking
for um I had to continually advocate for
her I met with the hospital Committee of
15 people and me saying this is not what
she wants but yet we continue on the
problem with medical assistance and
training in this procedural standard is
that our society views Medical
Professional professionals as smart
highly trained Bringers of Health they
know no more than me so they must know
something we don't oh this is what she
needs okay our society's fear of pain
and death play into a culture that says
death is better than I'm sorry that's
your
time um let me wrap it up
with um repeating the quote that 82% of
doctors say life is not worth living
with a disability my mom didn't
understand her impairments but she
wanted to die on her own terms I
advocated for her until I was barred
from doing so and even though the
hospital objective was clear I couldn't
fathom the depth of betrayal by those we
entrust with our care and care of our
loved ones we need real options for the
dying not treatment options giving them
another tool in the toolbox what is your
name Laura Allison did you you turn the
card in I did it was way back at the
beginning I'm from
Greenland name yes now I get it y Alexon
I think Laura
Alexon thank
you Linda May
chairman and committee members my name
is Linda May and I live in Hanover until
my retirement I was a senior software
engineer at Nasa I'm here to speak in
favor of House Bill
254 I would like to share with you what
it's like to sit with a dear friend as
she takes the lethal medication and dies
using Medical Aid in
dying our friend had a rare form of
blood cancer and she had a prognosis of
six months or less to live her husband
had died and they had no children at 85
she felt she had lived a completed life
and she wanted to use Medical Aid in
dying although she lived in New
Hampshire this a
85-year-old terminally ill Widow
traveled back and forth to Vermont many
times to fulfill all the requirements
friends in Vermont offered their home as
the place of her death she chose a day
and invited a small number of friends to
be with her we celebrated her life that
morning during warm and laughter-filled
conversations and then short shortly
afternoon we all went into the home's
guest bedroom she sat on the bed propped
up by pillows and we all surrounded her
she called us her
cheerleaders after raising a glass to
celebrate the life she had had she drank
the strong lethal pres
prescription but and then for about 10
minutes she gave us a running commentary
she said okay so now all of you seem to
be going up and down and everything's
getting a little bit fuzzy definitely
quieter and now you're starting to
spin this is relaxed
unusual I feel like I'm in a rocket
being sent out into the most amazing
quantum physics
thing I think I have about 60 seconds
now left to be able to say something I'm
so grateful to every single one of you
she then drifted into an irreversible
sleep and her heart finally stopped
beating an hour and 10 minutes later I
had that profound honor of holding her
hand as she
died this experience taught me that we
don't need to fear
death if a person is near death anyway
Medical Aid in dying is a way to die in
Comfort be because the patient I
apologize but that's your time if you
could just wrap it okay um I ask you to
extend this peaceful way of dying to the
people of New Hampshire who qualify for
it and thank you for staying awake this
whole
afternoon thank
you Debbie Richardson
Debbie
Richardson coming thank you thank you
somebody over here ask yeah oh sorry
thanks so much for uh for sitting
through all of this this afternoon I
appreciate it my name is Debbie
Richardson from Alexandria New Hampshire
uh I come to you as an OB nurse and a
hospice nurse um I've been there at the
beginning of Life and at the end of life
and I will just just spend a minute to
tell you that life is precious every
minute of it labor is very difficult
sometimes sometimes it really is a
struggle if you talk to anybody who has
ever given birth they really really um
go through a very different experience
with every child that they deliver death
is like that for us as well um I have
been part of many deaths um as a hospice
nurse I will tell you that there's many
things about this bill that I I oppose
um so I just want to come out and say
that I oppose this bill because hospice
is uh very flexible um I have been uh a
hospice nurse and have seen people
recertified time and time and time again
when they've only had six months and
they live to be 10 years out you know
they end up dropping hospice coming back
on hospice so hospice is very fluid um
so that terminology in and of itself is
a concern but I have seen death um up
close and and I know that every person
who is part of a hospice program gets a
hospice kit and in that hospice kit
there's morphine and there's uh Adavan
or lorazapam there's howd doll there's
medications to support that death and
sometimes the death goes very peacefully
and sometimes it goes very difficultly
but that the interaction for that needs
to happen on the physician level there
are medications that we have that we can
utilize it needs to be from a person's
standpoint and what the family is going
through for that individual person to
help them be able to have a peaceful
death because I do believe that peaceful
death is obtainable it just maybe we
just need to do more research into that
but the government does not need to
speak into when a person is allowed to
die when a government becomes
responsible for that decision and
allowing that decision to happen that's
when you see the Cascade effect and so I
just come to you just with real concerns
about this bill because there's such
deceit in it when you no longer put on
the cause of death as being because that
person took that medication that caused
the death then that's deceit that is not
that is not it's it's just not right but
you know I I just I feel like our lives
however limited are worth living and
every breath is precious so thank you
for allowing me to speak and and I hope
that you vote no on this thank
you Robin Ma
she'll be followed by Liberty
Milner good afternoon thank you for
letting me speak my name is Robin mower
from Durham but I would like to read
comments from um two people who cannot
attend first I'm reading for Jill
Robinson
Walpole I had Polio in 1954 when I was
three I've been significantly disabled
since I went from poster child with
braces and crutches to Liberation in a
manual gr chair about 30 years out my
disability became Progressive and I now
use a Power Tilt recline Elevate
wheelchair I'm within a hair's breath of
becoming unable to perform my daily
functions without assistance before I
retired I was a disability rights
attorney in the federal Community
Services Administration and the Civil
Rights Commission I completely
understand and respect the position of
some in the disability community against
this bill as far back as my knowledge of
History goes people have been
ostracizing us avoiding us ridiculing us
locking Us in back rooms abusing us and
outright killing us anything that hints
of officially sanctioned death
correlating with disability is
terrifying the other side of the coin is
that we possibly more than others are
too often denied control over our bodies
and our lives and for that matter our
deaths I ER on the side of seizing
control this bill is not aist it's
giving me the control that I want I am
comfortable that this bill has
sufficient safeguards to allow me and no
one else to take control of my
death second
testimony my name this is from Zale z l
Barry and I've been a c paliative care
physician for 35 years in Vermont
initially I was concerned that in
inadequate control of pain and other
symptoms would spur people to pursue
maid that was a time when the specialty
of paliative medicine was in its infancy
but we are now in a different era now
most people who pursue maid are
receiving paliative care through hospice
or other sources most importantly the
safeguards and the Oregon and Vermont
laws have been effective at protecting
the vulnerable and in limiting the use
of made to those with terminal illness
but uncontrolled symptomss are not the
driver for most people seeking Medical
Aid and dying we know from research done
in Oregon at elsewhere that most people
seeking that service have a strong wish
to control their death to avoid
suffering and to ensure that death is
gentle for both themselves and loved
ones Medical Aid in dying must never be
used as a substitute for excellent pain
management or any other aspect of
skilled paliative care but it is
valuable whether it is eventually used
or not as an assurance to a seriously
ill person that if life with terminal
illness ever brings them to a condition
they consider worse than death that they
will be able to die peacefully and
comfortably and in a way that does not
leave fail and Friends traumatized thank
you thank
you Liberty Milner
Milner okay thank you
good afternoon Mr chairman thank you for
pronouncing my last name correctly maybe
the first time that's ever happened I
got two shots at it you did my name is
Liberty Milner I currently live in
Barnstead and I am very opposed to this
bill uh I am chronically disabled woohoo
and I have struggled with mental illness
for a long time and therefore suicide
ideation so this is something that is
near and dear to my heart and I will
attempt to uh keep it very brief brief
as I think that everything that could be
said has been said on both sides I will
say that I'm very um interested to see
the demographics on both sides of the
argument it seems that a lot of people
testifying in opposition or a lot of the
young people who are testifying are in
opposition um and a lot of those uh who
are in favor are um perhaps um older or
know people who are older and uh I
wanted put it in perspective that this
bill is not just for today it's not for
the next couple of years for the
terminally ill today this is a bill for
the future and when we talk about the
possible windfall um about the possible
slippery slope that is a legitimate
concern that's why we have these
meetings is to look towards the future
um and I just want to say one I am
concerned that this is going to affirm
to not just young people to all people
that
suicide is a good thing death is never a
good thing death is always a terrible
thing um how ever painless it might be
and so I think it's silly for us to
pretend that we can somehow make it
better uh death is never good and I hope
that um this bill does not pass and that
young people like me who have uh spent
days years thinking about suicide uh
will not be encouraged
to consider it um as a viable option um
it hurts everyone around them death
hurts everyone no matter how peaceful it
may seem and so I don't think that even
though this bill intends to make death
better and more palatable it won't um I
also think I don't like to make
comparisons to Nazi German Germany often
but I was struck um thinking about how
Hitler um first came campaigned for
Health Care um that's how the genocide
began they used zyon B to kill insects
and rats and other animals to prohibit
disease and and then they went to the
Mental Hospitals those suffering greatly
before the Advent of uh Psychotherapy
drugs that have been very helpful in
treating mental illness they were
suffering greatly and one could look at
them and say they were better off dead
than they're suffering and that is what
Hitler started to do he said they're
better off dead than suffering and then
the disabled people people were better
off dead than suffering and then all of
a sudden the Jews and the homosexuals
and the Romany people were being killed
that's your time you can wrap up with
one sentence um you all have a very
powerful voice as you are in politics
and I urge you to use that voice to cry
to the citizens that you serve that
their life has value and the government
will never have a right to take that
away thank you thank you Robert Wallace
hi uh my name is Robert lws I'm from
penbroke uh I was going to read a a
statement from a physician from Vermont
but listening to the testimony today uh
I decided I wanted to share a couple of
personal stories that might hit a little
harder
um let me I have two that I'd like to
share um both of these friends of mine
have had cancer
um right after Thanksgiving my wife and
I went out to dinner with uh an ex-
cooworker uh who's been battling cancer
uh she had a recurrence of that and um
she'd been doing really well she'd gone
through latest rounds of chemo um and
she looked really good when we were out
for breakfast well within three or four
weeks she's not doing so well as of
today she's back at home she's in the
last stage ofus it's throughout her body
and
when we were out to breakfast she she
had said uh basically I'm waiting for my
uh for the cancer to perforate my bowel
and to go
septic great um we talked about Medical
Aid and dying and she was a supporter of
it um she didn't know that she'd use it
for herself um the other story is just
yesterday I had a call from a friend of
mine in Massachusetts whose wife had
died last week uh she had had lung
cancer and had spread to her bones um
one of the radiations it had been in her
jaw her jaw had broken she had ended up
in Hospice of course and uh he his
description of her final time was awful
um we have to realize that hospice and
pallative Care can only do so much
um she was literally the strongest
physically strongest woman I've ever met
she used to do lofing she's a great
mechanic he's a mechanic her husband um
and she was down to 98 pounds when she
died
um
the the options as it sits now is sure
we can knock you all the way out but
you're going to die of either
dehydration or starvation is that really
what we
want um I don't think so um I remember
my grandmother had had a stroke um this
back in 1987 on my last visit up in
Vermont uh up to her she couldn't
respond to anything and if she could
have seen a if she'd had a crystal ball
a crystal ball to see what the end of
her life was going to be and she's the
prototypical Yankee she'd had a crystal
ball she'd have put a gun to her head
unfortunately that's what a lot of
people are left to do as we've heard
from uh Rebecca her story uh I don't
know uh I'm a uh I'm both a vet and I
have a disabled brother so I have a lot
of the same skin in the game as people
that are here um
all I know is a lot of the Vets I talk
to uh almost out of time get into the
microphone up good good uh let me just
say if you could look into a crystal
ball and see that that was the type of
end that you'd have might you not be a
little bit more supportive of options
we're supposed to be the freedom State
let's live it thank
you Hannah is it rued
hi there U my name is Hannah Rudy close
I've heard it every way um experiencing
the beginning of Life and the end of
life are two things that we all share
and each of these stages are natural and
worthy of respect However unfortunately
there's an Ever growing interest to try
to attack life at the very beginning and
the very end so I stand here before you
today as a daughter a sister a friend uh
resident of Manchester and a Pala of
care nurse practitioner and I ask that
you oppose HB
254 every day of my job I encounter
individuals who are facing some of the
worst news unexpected diagnoses and
prognoses difficult decisions
significant symptoms and limited time as
a result I want to offer my respect and
hold space for every personal story
we've heard here today every end of life
experience is hard and unique in their
own way
way and I think that accompanying
someone through their natural death is a
very Noble act there are many worthy and
compelling arguments that have been made
today opposing the bill many of which I
too worry about such as the slippery
slope and the message that approving
this would send to um residents of New
Hampshire those who are young old
disabled marginalized and alone about
their dignity value and worth but I want
to highlight what I think we should be
focusing our efforts on when considering
Care at the end of life rather than
looking to provide people who find
themselves in one of their most
vulnerable states with a means to end
their life on their own terms we should
be talking about bolstering resources um
to actually care for people through
their final months weeks days hours of
their life we need to be looking to
increase Pala of care availability of
caregivers breast bit care providing
support to hardworking family caregivers
hospice care and hospice houses in the
community for individuals facing facing
these terminal diagnosis we can and we
should be doing more for individuals who
are terminally ill individuals who are
vulnerable and individuals who are dying
more than just considering assisted
suicide as a quote unquote option for
end of life care so again I ask that you
oppose HB 254 thank you thank you
Jeffrey Bart
good
afternoon Jeffrey Bert from
Franconia reading the
testimony
of Lynn ramboy from Raymond New
Hampshire who could not be here to do it
herself I am a New Hampshire resident
with a very personal interest in the
pending New Hampshire end of life
Freedom Act FB
254 I have a new diagnosis of metastatic
breast cancer to my
bones living with cancer is not new to
me between 2020 and
2022 I underwent lengthy and serious
treatment for what was then stage 3A bre
cancer I endured chemo a double
masectomy radiation with excellent
excellent
practitioners at exitor hospital all the
while I was taking care of my husband
with advancing
timers I've done a lot of exploring
around end of life
options with just in case in
mind and this includes the excellent
made Workshop presented early last year
by the oser lifelong learning Institute
at tus
University the presenter was excellent
an
anesthesiologist with extensive
experience in end of life
care this impressed upon me that Medical
Aid in dying is no longer the
controversial practice
those opposing it would have you believe
it is an
accepted part of compassion end of life
care for nearly a quarter of the people
in our
country at this time I have begun
treatment for metastatic breast cancer
but it is not curable only
treatable and the medium survival rate
is 5 years
planning for my end of life as well as
continuing care for my husband is
critical for both of
us with death dignity and peace in mind
that all options are possible right here
in New
Hampshire I urge you to pass this
legislation on behalf of my family and
the many many others who are facing
difficult end of life
situations no one can really appreciate
how stressful this time of life is until
end of the road is in sight and thank
you very
much thank
you
questions Lisa Bodwin
yes we
did we did yes we did we'll get
iters
okay hi for the record my name is Lisa
Bodwin I am a Disability Policy expert
um much has been said so I'm trying to
modify please do read my written
testimony it deviates from what I'm
sharing
now there is evidence of suicide
contagion and there is a threat to
people with disabilities contrary to
what other testimony in the room might
want to tell
you this is the 70 page white paper by
the National Council on disability
this is the study that demonstrates that
suicide rates go up when in states where
assisted suicide passes when compared to
states that
don't this is the list of national
disability organizations all of whom
oppose physician assisted suicide it is
not possible that all of our nation's
top Disability Policy experts are wrong
this is a handout that you received
citing significant problems with the
supposed survey that the UNH Survey
Center did because New Hampshire
Alliance for compassion and choices paid
for that product and wrote the
questions this is a p pictograph that
will help you to read my testimony that
has footnotes
this is the NIH document that
demonstrates the severity of medical
ableism which is discrimination against
people with disabilities including that
82% of doctors self-report that they
believe life with a disability is not
quite worth as uh not quite as high
quality of life as life without it this
is the list of
concerns abuses and coercion that's been
put
together this one tells you that the top
five reasons in Oregon have nothing to
do with intractable pain but the reasons
associated with with um life with a
disability like loss of bodily autonomy
and not um
having not being able to engage and
having a feeling of your loss of
dignity leapfrogging over the real need
to fix inequities in health care is a
problem and that is what HB 254 would
have us
do lethal prescriptions are also a way
to Leap Frog over gaps in two parts of
endof Life Care both paliative Care and
Pain Management need greater funding and
better education as many have said today
I apologize but that's your time if you
can wrap it up in a
sentence I know many people with
disabilities who don't have safe and
trusting relationships with their health
care
providers because their health care
providers treat them as though their
lives are not white quite worth living
this is indeed a threat to vulnerable
populations we can do better with pation
and Pain Management thank you Gary
soilson did I get that right
thank you um I've sat in many committee
meetings and I've never seen a committee
as attentive for this long and for all
of us and what we've heard today has
been very striking for the record my
name is Dr Gary soilson I'm a family
physician in conquer I've been in
practice for 40 years um and uh my I
I'll submit my written testimony I think
frankly one of the worst things we
should do is to repeat what's been said
before and I can't add too much but I do
think what's become clear what's in
front of us today is the difference
between what many of my patients want I
I work in paliative care I work in
hospice environments I work in nursing
home environments as well as in the
community and many of my patients who
come who are diagnosed with terminal
conditions one of the first things that
they are looking at is not the the fear
of the of their death that which is a
true concern for them but it's it's
actually what is that death going to be
like and what control will I have over
that so in the end they're looking for
autonomy they're looking for what what
rights they will have I I think those
are obvious things that most of us and
frankly everybody in the room today has
personal experience with it's nothing
that a physician necessarily can bring
specially to the table but the tools
that we have as Physicians and as other
health providers are dependent on what
you allow us to have as a legislature I
think the the bill as constructed I
speak in favor of course of this bill
gives us a narrow enough definition to
move forward in a way that we haven't
had before and and will and will and
should be used appropriately as we have
seen in 10 other states over more than
25 years with really no evidence of of
misuse abuse and all the concerns that
have been raised you have the question
in front of us is one of individual
autonomy versus Collective concern and
it's a very very valid uh concern and I
hope it's one that you can sort out um
when I started in practice 40 years ago
the tradition if you were if your SP if
you were diagnosed with metastatic
cancer we went to your family and we
asked whether not it was okay to tell
the person that seems a little ludicrous
today but I see some of some people with
my color hair or less hair shaking their
heads because that is true and and
that's what I learned in my medical
training was that people weren't ready
to hear about imminent death or or even
in the like people couldn't cope with it
we moved along 30 years ago to develop
in New Hampshire some of the earliest
and best hospice programs in the United
States and we have them but the Caren
hospice and the Caren hospice is
wonderful and it's something that we
should really be proud of in our state
and our state laws have helped us move
that along but it's not always perfect
the care we can give there is not always
adequate and it doesn't address what
someone else already commented about
which is patients with in at the end of
their life still want that autonomy they
may or may not want to lie on morphine
in a hospice house I've sat with
families sitting vigil I probably think
all of you have as well and the looks
around the room the glance is why are we
exactly doing this um we're doing this
because we really don't have tools uh we
didn't have tools actually often when
you're in that bu situation it's too
late the patient is not conscious
couldn't self- administer but often
we're sitting in that environment
knowing that we were going to get there
and family members look at at the
caregivers and say why is it that you
couldn't do so I apologize that's your
time absolutely I I finished and set it
up and thank you all for your
time we have one question if you would
you take a question
sure representative
Smith thank you very much thank you
completely to take the C question would
you agree with what we have heard here
again and again that the um ability to
access Quality Health Care in this
country is not available to everyone in
an equal way and that people with
disabilities might fact have a harder
time than many others to get access to
Quality Healthcare but that this bill
has nothing to do with that well toasy
you you answered my you answer the
question the way I would answer it yes I
agree that that many of the populations
that we've heard from today who are
concerned have less ability we
absolutely should do everything we can
um with all the means that we might have
to improve the kind of care that's
delivered but it has nothing to do with
the bill in front of us today today
which applies to a very small number of
people listen to the people in Vermont
and look at the data in the end we're
talking about in the state of New
Hampshire probably dozens of people per
year who will access this type of care
that's the kind of autonomy we're
talking about um it's hard for me to
believe that despite all what we heard
today that this is going to lead to some
um some Wellspring of change in how we
view the endly any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Jonathan and having a hard time
reading the last name is
Binger is there an MD after that there
is yeah that's why I can't read it yeah
that's exactly it yeah it's Edinger Ed I
apologize in the uh the signature comes
true yeah so I'm I'm uh Dr Jonathan
Edinger I'm a cardiologist at Catholic
Medical Center I'm president of the
Board of Medicine but I'm not here today
in that capacity I'm here as just an
individual physician in case any of you
know me from the board
I'm in opposition to the bill um for a
couple reasons um some of which I kind
of spoke uh over the last couple years
against it but I you know this isn't the
1970s or 80s anymore we've had a couple
um Physicians speak to what it was like
back in the day um you know right now
the line between chronic illness and
terminal illness is very difficult to
distinguish uh the bill is very clear
and it's being interpreted as being
narrow but um these days when somebody
gets a diagnosis it's a very very
difficult decision to know if it they're
going to be quote unquote terminal and
they're going to be dead in six months
um that might have been the case in the
70s and 80s but right now that's not the
case at all um we have um you're going
to hear a lot of anecdotes today that
are going to pull at the heartstrings
and over the course of this uh the life
of this bill um but this shouldn't be a
bill that is um built on motion it
should be a bill that's built on
objectivity and this area is fraught
with subjectivity it's going to be very
difficult to manage this um and force it
um we had other very kind of learner
colleagues and people that are very
passionate about their discussions today
talk on um their experience in Vermont
and other states for example where
they're trying to monitor this and
ensure that there's no abuse but it's
going to be very challenging to do that
you can't you can't enforce the slope or
or statistically follow the slope people
jump on and off the slope um it's a
philosophical issue it's an emotional
issue it's going to be very difficult to
track that it's going to be easy for it
to be
manipulated um you can see people who
are dealing with suffering who are going
to misinterpret suffering as a means as
a reason for why they should die with
their chronic illness and that's where
it's going to get exploited and um Mis
misused so I have trouble with the
definition of terminal I have trouble
with following it um in terms of how you
um track the potential for abuse with
this I think if you have a gentleman
who's been practicing medicine for 40
years they are going to be at the
Pinnacle of their career they're going
to do a very good job at tracking that
and being able to make a decision where
somebody's going to die very shortly um
but I I feel like that's a strong
minority in state for what you have for
providers you have a lot of growth
towards nurse practitioners and
Physicians assistants that are not going
to be skilled in this area there's no
provision for um what kind of experience
you need to do this I apologize talk
about extra time you can wrap it up with
a sentence
100% um I think you know following up on
the other um comments we just need
better physical psychological spiritual
mental health um care in general this
immediately becomes the cheapest and one
of the easiest options to follow in the
state for healthc care providers and for
providers that are
inexperienced and patients that have
chronic illnesses it is uh an injustice
so thank you any questions at all seeing
none thank you okay thanks Henry
steans good evening and thank you for
your patience and waiting for me to
speak um I have some testimony here that
I'll bring down just a minute takes me a
minute to get down and up and I know you
want to get finish the two things that I
really want to point out I'm I'm not
speaking from a doctor's point of view
I've had bad experience with parents
dying and suffering badly and saying I
want to die what can you do and we've
researched Switzerland we've re
researched all those things we weren't
able to do it but so I became a strong
believer in this and one of the things I
wanted to turn talk about as a lawyer is
is different than all of the stories
that you've heard today I think when you
passed legislation one of the things you
have to do is go back to the
fundamental laws and theories of our
country and the best place to find those
are in documents like the Declaration of
Independence and the New Hampshire state
constitution
the doc Declaration of Independence says
that everybody has the inable right to
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness New Hampshire Constitution
says that men have the inherent right to
um seek uh to life and seeking happiness
now what I think we're talking about
here here is life on both ends we've
heard people talk about life birthing
life and we've heard people talk about
death as part of life also I think that
life includes death and I think one of
the things that we have to do is we have
to consider the options that people have
to go to die do they want to suffer you
heard about a lot of people who have
suffered ed through awful things I've
experienced it with my family or do you
want to go to a
medical a doctor who will say I
understand your pain I know what happens
when they they put you in these rooms
and they drug you up and you end up
dying because you're not eating and
you're
dehydrated and I respect that and if you
want to die here's a way to do it and I
think that respect that individual
respect of people's wishes is what makes
New Hampshire and the United States a
great place and if we if we start um
with the beginning of what is the law
that we're we're trying to overcome here
it's there's a specific law that says if
you assist or solicit suicide you've
committed a
felony that's means that when I when my
mother was was going through the that is
your time sir if you could just finish
up with one sentence I I honestly
couldn't help her and that's an awful
feeling I think each of us as
individuals and as family members need
the right to make decisions about our
life thank you thank you Aubrey fredman
Mr chairman committee members Aubrey
Friedman I live in Bridgewater I speak
in support of this bill I don't have
much to add um I'll just say I've been
kind of Lucky in my family we tend to go
quickly so there hasn't been these
terrible you know of Agony and cancer
and you know that horrible things that
people go through uh in many families we
go quickly and that it but
it still comes down to shouldn't you
have the right to choose how you want to
die and
especially if you are I mean this bill
is very narrow so there's been so much
you know uh talking about the uh this
isn't Canada and and I have to say by
the way on that I generally would be for
the right to choose then this was a
couple years ago then they started
talking about the Canada you know the
maid program that's a disaster there an
absolute disaster and it gave me pause
maybe this is not a good road to go but
this bill is first of all this isn't
Canada their health system is different
than
ours quite a bit and this bill is very
narrow of course they're started out
narrow and it you know there is that
possibility there's not no point denying
it but the bill as it is without taking
all the other things that could happen
that might happen I think it's it's got
the proper guard rails as it is and so
I'm comfortable with it uh even though
you know there could be abuse or
whatever but I think it's pretty good I
do have to say one thing I don't agree
with in the bill that somebody mentioned
it came up a few times you know at the
end of the bill about the death
certificate and the cause of death it is
it it is incorrect and it is not honest
to say that it's the underlying cause
they tick the poison so that is suicide
so I think that part of it is uh is not
good it's dishonest that part of the
bill but I don't think we should strike
the whole bill down just because of that
that's not a major thing the idea behind
it to give people choices is good and if
you have that part of the end of the
bill the record keeping about the death
certificate is a little bit uh unless
there's a compelling reason to have it
that way I think it's dishonest but the
rest of the bill is good and that's why
I support it thank you thank you Steve
Gordon thank you very much for your
patience uh and the time and I will try
uh not to do
at the
stories mic up you're the first person
who wanted to hear me
talk I've been a lawyer in this state
for 50
years and when I first came here as a
lawyer I worked for a federal
judge and he told me a story that I
think is appropriate for you and that
story was very simple
he said when a lawyer comes to you and
talks to you about slippery
slopes unintentional
consequences a parade of
horribles that is a
signal that the lawyer does not want you
to look at and appreciate the underlying
facts that are limited to the argument
being presented
and I would beseech
you when the words slippery slope come
up to be
mindful and
appreciative that what could happen in
the
future is not what is presently before
you
today your bill is
narrow it's
confined it is based upon experience in
other
states look to the sister state of
Vermont look to Oregon look at the
underlying
facts don't join the parade of horribles
and don't slide down the slippery
slope I worked with Bob Lynn almost 50
years
ago and our careers began
together and I join him with personal
emphasis
this is a bill of personal
autonomy I stand before you telling you
that I do not believe that the state of
New Hampshire and you have the power to
be that voice should tell me how I must
die I do not wish to have a stranger
changing my bed pan I do not wish to
have a stranger turning me over like a
pancake to prevent bed sores I want to
be surrounded by people who love me and
people I love and there are two people
sitting right there who I never met
until I went to Vermont to be a
witness to a woman who
courageously applied and took medical
that's your time sir you could wrap it
up so I salute you for being a friend
and I trust that this committee will
look at personal autonomy and not the
slippery slope thank you thank
you Lucy kale do I have that right
Carl thank you sir Lucy Carl hopkington
New Hampshire uh I have stood before
this committee several years I will not
belabor you with my son's horrific death
uh because I'm not sure you really care
anymore frankly but his story is in the
pamphlet the booklet that Rebecca has
sent to you I will also not repeat um
the extraordinary privilege it was to be
with our dear friend in Vermont in
December and I can attest to you that it
was the most beautiful peaceful death I
have ever witnessed I've sit with the
dying I'm an end of life Doula I left
law and became became a end of life
Doula after my son died I am a vigil
volunteer uh there is lots of talk here
about the wonders of hospice and
paliative Care let me tell you home
hospice leaves the family figuring it
out on their own often times family
members are afraid to give more
medication because they don't want to be
accused of
overmedicating it was not until I became
became aulla that I understood all the
signs of pain at the end of life this
bill is not about the living it is not
about people living with disabilities it
is not about people with suicide
ideation and depression it is for the
dying people who are dying they have no
hope of living and I beseech you that
you find it in your hearts and as leg
legislators to Value the lives of the
dying as much as you value the lives of
the living I have three points I want to
make uh number one about unintended
consequences I am a duel of both in New
Hampshire and in Oregon I have never
ever ever seen anyone denied coverage
for medical care because they were
progressing Beyond ter chronic to
terminal illness I have never seen
anyone who are in their final days
denied care before they choose to enter
hospice uh and I would say here
that neither my son nor my dear friend
um felt fear at the end of their lives
my son did not end up using the
medication he slipped into a coma
beforehand but as as that cancer filled
his brain we literally saw his head grow
by the day with that
cancer and it gave him such Comfort to
know that he could take that
medication if he needed to be and not
suffer trauma for himself his wife and
his three-year-old I implore you to
support this that's your time you have
one more point to make you good I just
ask you to listen to the stories we are
not pulling heartstrings we bear witness
to the dying it's not a bill about the
living thank you Brent
Richardson good evening thank you for
your time and attention uh my name is
Brent Richardson I'm a nurse
practitioner in pulmonary uh critical
care and paliative care with 25 years of
experience I'm a board-certified healthc
care ethicist and I'm currently uh chair
of their Hampshire Alliance for end of
life options uh and I'm a fellow in
bioethics the Harvard Medical School
Center for bioethics and I'm here
speaking as a personal citizen from
Chester um you've heard so much I won't
belabor it uh this bill is about I'm in
favor of s of HB
254 and um this is about personal
autonomy and about addressing suffering
at the end of life as uh so many before
me have stated uh there have been a
number of uh misstatements that I would
love to correct if we had more time when
I first walked in there was a physician
I believe talking about injections and
paralytic medications I wish
representative Perez was still here um
this law does not address intervenous uh
administration of medications and
neuromuscular blocking agents or
paralytics are never used in these
combinations of medications I could get
into extreme detail and in how these
laws and medications are used in other
states but we don't have time I will be
happy to accept uh any questions and
again this is about autonomy at the end
of life for people who are suffering and
the control of the end of their life and
uh with dignity and peace thank you any
questions at all seeing none thank you
you last card I have I called earlier
Charlene
Joyce so anyone else that has not turned
in a pink card that wants to speak on
this
bill seeing none I will close the
hearing on House Bill
okay you going to speak on
this I just closed
oh he okay I'm going to adjourn the uh
host Judiciary Committee thank you